THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY. SO LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING. DUE
TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HEARING
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. ROSS REQUIRE MASKS THE
WOMAN IN FISCAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE IN THE ROOM OR THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITES YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES- FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. REPUBLICAN THE
ROOM TODAY IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS WE CAN ONLY COME IN A
MINIMAL CONTENTION OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACE IN. THERE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
WELL AT. THE MICROPHONE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THE MAKE THE PUBLIC AND TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE. DONE
RETURN YEARS. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE JUST IN UPON LEAVING
HELLO. INCLUDE LIMITING. YOU
ONE. TIME. WE TAKE NAY OR- IT
ON THE- IN DAILY FILE. BETTER
OF THE OFF REGARDLESS OF CA
MEMBER AND TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
WE HAVE SOME BILL WITH MAKE USE
OF A WITNESS VIDEO ROOMS WHICH
ARE LOW HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
ARE NOT TESTED A TESTIMONY
STATE LOCATED ON THE CAPITAL.
IN OTHER LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO WHERE
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO ASK
THEM QUESTIONS. WE'LL BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
TO WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN.
HERE IS EIGHT. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IN IN THE
DAILY FILE FILE AND
CONVENIENTLY ON YOUR TELEVISION
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
FIND DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN IN IN THE IN THE
QUEUE. BASED UPON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT FOR WAS A BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASED TO
LIMóN A ALL THE NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MEETING LIVE BROADCAST
IN YOUR SMART DEVICES TO ROOM
REDUCE THE SOUND DOORSTEP.
PLEASE BE AS IF YOUR MAIN THIS
IF YOU ARE A WITNESS. TESTIMONY
FOR OR AGAINST A BILL. YOUR
MAIN ON A LIVE LINE WILL NEED
TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED UPON TO SPEAK. HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SIR YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. ALSO
WANTED. THE WRITTEN TEST AND-
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEES.
EMAIL ME THERE AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. THERE'S LIKE TO RESPOND
TO A ROLL CALL ASK A QUESTION
OR PROVIDE COMMENT YOU NEED TO
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE SO THE
STAFF CAN ACTIVATE IT WHEN
YOU'RE RIGHT NICE TO. BE ALSO
PLEASE STAND AND FACE MICHAEL.
KING TO ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS
AUDIBLE AND CAN BE RECORDED.
MEMBERS WILL NOT BE RECOGNIZED
THAT THEY ARE NOT FOLLOWING THE
GUIDANCE OF LEADERSHIP AND
WEARING A MASK IN THE CHAMBERS
TODAY. TIME LIMITS AND THESE
LISTEN CAREFULLY TO THIS. IN
FAIRNESS TO EVERYONE WE WILL
NEED TO BE ESPECIALLY STRICT ON
THE TIME LIMITS TODAY. WE WERE
HERE. BUSINESSES THREE MINUTES
EACH FOR EACH SIDE. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION. IF
THEY REPRESENT ONE AND POSITION
ON A BILL. NOW IF THERE ARE
THREE WITNESSES AND I
UNDERSTAND ON ONE BILL THERE
ARE THREE WITNESSES. WE STILL
HAVE SIX MINUTES AND AT THE END
OF SIX MINUTES TESTIMONY WILL
AND PERIOD. SO BEAR THAT IN
MIND IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN TWO
WITH THIS AND WE WILL DO OUR
BEST TO KEEP YOUR AS TO WHERE
YOU ARE AND I'M IN THE- SENATE.
SENATE IN ANY MEMBER THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER A BILL FROM
THE CAN CAL I NUMBER TWO SB ONE
TWO BY THE COUNT. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS HAVE BEEN REMOVED TODAY'S
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHT
EIGHT FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR PAN
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB TWO
SEVENTEEN SENATOR PORTANTINO.
WITH THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO OUR FIRST BILL I'M
GOING TO MAKE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT
NOW WE HAVE AT. WE HAVE BEEN
BILLS BEFORE US WE HAVE A LOT
OF MEMBERS MISSING. WHEN WE-
TWO SB THREE NINETY THREE SEVEN
NINETY THREE WE WILL NOT
PROCEED UNTIL ALL FIFTEEN
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT. SO IF
YOU'RE IN THE BUILDING WE
EXPECT YOUR PRESENCE IN THE
CHAMBER AND QUITE FRANKLY. RED
RESPECT TO SENATOR BELL THE
FIRST PRESENTER SENATOR
GALGIANI THE SECOND PRESENTER I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY EQUEST THAT
ALL MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE COME TO THE RIVER.
IMMEDIATE I'M AT RESPECT FOR
THE FAR FELLOW CALLING SO WITH
THAT WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
SENATOR. PRESENT AS. EIGHT OH
THREE. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE OUR
PRESENTERS COME UP AND UP IN
THE. WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE. HAVE
A QUORUM SO- LASSEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YOU CAN YOU CAN STILL GO UP
THERE SENATOR BALLOTS BY IT
WILL ONLY TAKE A MINUTE. WHAT
HEAR. WHAT HERE MAYES MAYES
HERE AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW
BIGELOW HERE BONTA BURKE.
CORREO CORREO HERE FLORA FLORA
HERE LET ALONE LIMóN HERE
MCCARTY NAZARIAN MCCARTY HERE
NAZARIAN. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
HERE SANTIAGO. THURMAN WALDRON.
YOU HAVE A QUORUM OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER BELL. GOOD
AFTERNOON. SECOND MEMBERS ARE
PRESENTING- SENATE BILL EIGHT
OH THREE WHICH IS STATUS IS A
STATE WIDE CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM FOR PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST ENABLES THE STATE
COUNTIES TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDING. I WANT PART BY
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND THANK YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL.
THE AMENDMENTS ELIMINATE THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE GENERAL
FUND COST BY PROVIDING COUNTIES
AND ARE IN TO PROVIDE. SERVICES
AFFECTED PRACTICE. USING FORTY
EIGHT OTHER STATES. NOT
CALIFORNIA BUT FORTY EIGHT
OTHER STATES AND IS PROVIDED TO
REDUCE HOSPITALIZATION ALMOST
US INCREASE PARTICIPATION
TREATMENT. AND IMPROVE OVERALL
SERVICE EXPERTS IT'S NEEDED NOW
MORE THAN EVER. AND ALL CUT MY
PRESENTATION SHORTEN TURN OVER
MY WITNESSES I OF. THIS MY
RECORD CHIEF OF THE PIER AND
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONS LOW
SCALE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
LIKE TO POINT OUT SHE'S ONE OF
THE NATIONAL EXPERTS ON THIS.
PIERCE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATTER MODERATE PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINE FOR- THE WITNESS. HI
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT OH THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AFTER THE
TIME. AND FIRST OF ALL THE LINE
NUMBER ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. YOUR MIND IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
MOVING ON THE LINE NUMBER TWO
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THERE'S A LOT
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR NAM THE
SOLANO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO MILEAGE SHOW
ALSO WELL ON THE. TO ADD SEVEN
NINE BE VERY I HELLO THANK YOU
THAT WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT TAKING
OFF IF POINT SO WE'LL ASK YOU
TO GO BACK INTO THE QUEUE. WE
ARE STILL WAITING FOR OUR
WITNESS WHO IS A TO THE ACTUAL
PRIMARY WITNESS HERE SO I
HOPEFUL THAT MY REBEKAH. THERE
PLEASE SOMEWHERE. AND MARK IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU CAN
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AND INFORM
THE OPERATOR THAT YOU ALL RIGHT
TO STAR WITNESS. CHAMBER BONTA
THE NEXT ONE HUNDRED PORTER. IT
HERE. OKAY WELL OVER THE LINE
OF TWO FIFTY SEVEN LINE TO
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY BUT NOT ME FOR APPLICATION.
OKAY HERE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THIS IS THE LA OKAY ARE BUILT
WITH COUNTY BE ABLE HELP
DIRECTORS. ONE OF THE PROUD
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT CALL
TO MY NUMBER THREE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK MAKING
THE MOST ON BRACES AND WHAT. WE
ARE ALL. THANK YOU. SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HER
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TWO NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ALEX OR AS WITH
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON BE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I AM PLEASED
BROKE HRE IN SUPPORT- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF LOS ANGELES
VENTURA AND CLARA COUNTY IS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN.WE'RE BACK AND
SALAS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS HOPE
KAYMER SENATE A FAMILY OF
AGENCIES WE ARE PROUD TO THE
ENTRANCE THAT SEAT A THREE
THANK. FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. ADRIN SO FROM WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THREE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
WHERE THEY ENCOUNTER
REPRESENTING THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES IN SUPPORT.
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ABOUT A WEEK MENTAL
HEALTH ADVOCATE AND YOUR
SPECIAL TRONG. ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. TO RAISE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MIND IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
MOVING ON TO MY NUMBER ONE ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI SHE
WALKER CAL WHITE AND OUT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THREE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I ARRIVING IN
FACT IN MENTAL HEALTH STARTED
STRONG SB YOU KNOW FREE. TWO
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE NOW A-
BASICALLY JUST SAYING. YOUR
THANK. ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. WITH THE CAMP WHEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHT OH
THREE THANK YOU. TWO TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MILEY
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT
OH THREE. TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. LARA READ THE
BOMBING MENTAL HEALTH- P.
PROVIDER INSTALL SUPPORT. THREE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SHE NOT RESPONSIBLE ONE
TWO ONE TWO FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TO ONE NUMBER
TWO SIXTY THREE ONE TWO SIX
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOHN
VAN OVER ON BEHALF OF THE BI
POLAR AND- JOHN VAN OVER ABOUT
FIVE OF THE DEPRESSION BY FULL.
OR ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE TO
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. A STEP. THEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA SO.
OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE RIGHT
WERE ASIA A CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL I AM VERY VERY STRONGLY SO.
THANK YOU. FOR TWO FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN A KELLY
ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NOT IN MY
NUMBER TWO THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. CHAIR MEMBERS FROM
THE HALF THAT SEE A U. L.
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THREE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON BREAK
A. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THREE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MERRY GO CONTRA COSTA PACIFICA
HERE TO REPORT STRONG SUPPORT
FOR. THE APRIL. TWENTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE ONE THIRTY
YOUR MIND IS NOW A. ONE FIVE
SIX YOUR MIND IS OPEN. IF YOUR
MIND IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER THREE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JENNIFER ALI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THEY PUT ME ON YOUR
AMERICA THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANNING
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO SIX
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REPORTER REPRESENTING ME
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NOT TO OPEN LINE THREE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CHEN MEMBERS BENJAMIN
TRYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TWO
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THIS IS FOUND TIENEN OF
YOUR SUPPORT SPECIALIST WITH
SERVICE AT THE END OF THE
HEALTH SYSTEM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. HERE TWO THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I MEAN
VERY WOULD HE BE A CHANGE THE
CAL COUNTS OKAY BE HOW AGENCY
AND SUPPORT. FIND EIGHTY MIND
IS OPEN. THE END GOAL
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I KNOW ONE EIGHT SIX
ZERO ONE IS NOW OPEN. HI LYNN
CAN TELL CRESTWOOD BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INSURER OF SB ADULT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY LINE IS NOW A. WO TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
LADY THE GENTLEMAN F A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHT ZERO THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE A FEW ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE WHO JUST CUED UP TO BE
WITH OPERATOR TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
EIGHTY TWO LINE NUMBER IS TWO
EIGHTY TWO ALL RIGHT. HELLO
THIS IS THE OPERATOR CARRIER
CONFERENCE. ONE TWO EIGHTY TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. COOPER
CALLING FROM BOTTOM CONGRESS
THE RECORD ENJOY BURKE HARDEST
TWENTY MOM AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND WHAT A LINE TO
NINETY THREE LINE IS NOW OPEN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FORENSIC
PIER SPECIALIST. AND I AM
STRONGLY SUPPORT ABOUT. YOUR.
THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO. YOUR MIND
OPENS HER PEOPLE HAD. THERE IS
ALREADY A ROMULAN LOOK AT
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU. ONE
THREE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MARIE CANALS
CONTRACT THE COUNTY FRANTIC
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
STRONG. NINE THREE SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
FIRST WAVE OF CLARK CALLING
FROM THE CRISIS RESPONSE FROM
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND STRONG
SUPPORT DOWN AT FIFTY EIGHT OH
THREE THANK YOU. I'M SITTING A
MODERATE JUST FOR ONE I'D LIKE
TO JUST ASK THAT IF CARICE
MYRICK IS- STILL OUT THERE
LISTENING TO THIS THAT SHE CALL
SHE IS THE PRIMARY WITNESS AND
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE HER AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- SPEAK OF RIGHT
I BELIEVE SHE MAY HAVE BEEN A-
PART BUT I THINK. IN FAIRNESS
AND ABOUT. ON THE WAY SO SHE'S
ABLE TO DO THAT. SO CARE IS MY
RIGHT BACK DIAL ONE ZERO.
IDENTIFIERS TO THE OP THAT ARE
THE- WITNESS FOR THIS BILL AND
WE WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU.
SO PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MATTER MODERATOR. GIVE HER NEXT
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER THREE ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THREE OH ONE IS DROPPED TO OPEN
LINE THREE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS
DEBBIE THOMAS. BURN THE MIDDLE
HELP THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AT THE AGE
OF THREE. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. IF YOUR LINE IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. MOVE
ON TO MY NUMBER THREE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS JAMIE AND THOROUGH. I'M
PLEASE- MYSELF OUT OF THE RING
COME. EVER COULD THROW SB A BE.
SSM FOR THE. YEAH AND IT HAS A
VERY ACTIVE THE BELL ROCK LEDGE
I AM VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
AND AT THE EIGHT OH THREE. I
WITHOUT CENTRAL HEALTH WELLNESS
ADVOCATE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO TO ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSIBLE
ONE TO MY NUMBER SIXTY YOUR
MIND OPEN. IN THINKING WITH THE
EXECUTION OF CALIFORNIA HELP
YOU DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. LINE
TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GET
ALL YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THREE SEVEN EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT NO
RESPONSE WILL OPEN MIND ONE
FIVE THREE YEAR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MY NAME IS STEPHEN LLOYD
I'M WITH THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY OFFICE FOR CONSUMER
APARTMENT AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THAT THE EIGHT OH
THREE. IF YOU. LINE ONE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI BARBARA
WEAVER FROM THE FINAL GAME WITH
YOU ONE OF THE CROWD CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL WERE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE FIVE SIX
ZERO LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE ONE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
REMINDER WE ARE STILL LOOKING
FOR TERRACE MYRICK PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT ZERO THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OPEN MY NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS THERESA COMSTOCK WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS ON BEHALF OF CAL
THE HBC WE SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YEAH NINE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE SEVEN
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOT
RESPONSIBLE BONTA LIE NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS CYNICAL KENNEWICK
OUT VOICES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE. TWO TWO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT MRI
DEPARTMENT OF COLLECTING IS
PARKING EVERY. THE CREDIT OF
FABULOUS. THANK YOU. AT THAT
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT THAT BEING THE CASE
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION I DO
NOT HAVE ANY LISTED- OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. OUR WHAT ASKED THE-
IS ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY. THE READY IN THE
WITNESS- IN THE WITNESS ROOM.
SCREEN BLANK SO I'M- SURE.
MAYBE IT'S JUST DARK IN THERE.
NO WITNESSES IN THE ROOM OKAY
THAT BEING THECASE LESS-
MADAME MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE AND ASK
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
THE NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
GLAD YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB EIGHT
ZERO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
AND IN VERO AT THIS TIME. TO
GET A SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR. MISS WALDRON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIRST I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR VAL FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD ON THIS IS BEEN A MULTI
YEAR EFFORT OF COURSE AND I'M
PROUD TO JOIN THE SENATOR AS
PRINCIPAL CALL AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL AS EIGHT OH THREE IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN ADDRESSING
THE VAST BEHAVIORAL NEEDS IN
OUR STATE AND IT WOULD LEVERAGE
THE EXPERIENCE OF THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN TREATED. FOR BE A
ISSUES TO HELP THOSE CURRENTLY
IN NEED WHILE ALSO CREATING
BLOOM I'M AN OPPORTUNE IS I
BELIEVE STRONGLY IN THE F. BILL
AND TO MY CAR. TO SUPPORT THANK.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER MEMBERS CO
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE THE BILL
DOES OF DECEIT THE BILL DOES
ENJOY MOTION- BY SEN- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAY SIMPLY THE SECOND
WAVE WAS BY WAS MISTER BIGELOW-
THE MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER BELL
WHICH LIKE I DID ABOUT WHICH I
CLOSE. YEAH I'M SORRY WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET MY- AS ALL
OF READ. A LOT OF CAR FROM YOUR
CAN I CAN TELL YOU ONE TODAY I
HAD. WHERE STORY OF A MOTHER
WHO. LOST DAUGHTER THREE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER. AND COUPLE YEARS
LATER LOST THE SIX YEAR OLD SON.
THEN A YEAR LATER LOST HER
HUSBAND. THEN RECENTLY. ARE NOT
RECENTLY BUT SHE WAS THEN
ENGAGED HE GOT ENGAGED. AND
THEN TWO YEARS LATER SHE LOST
THE PERSON SHE WAS ENGAGED TO.
AND THE ONLY WAY SHE SURVIVED
WAS BY HAVING SOMEBODY TO TALK
TO. AND THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
WE CAN DO IN GOVERNMENT. AND
PERSONALLY IN OUR SPIRITUALITY
AND OUR EMPATHY. THAT DOESN'T
REALLY COST THAT MUCH AND THIS
IS A BILL THAT DOES THAT. WELL
THE PERSON HAD THIS PERSON TO
REACH OUT AND RESCUE HER THEY
OFFER. AND THAT PERSON. THAT
WOMAN REMARRIAGE. AND SHE HAD A
FOR KIDS. AND THE YOUNGEST OF
THE FOUR WAS MY MOTHER. SO IS A
STORY OF WHY I'M HERE. THE HELP
MY GRANDMOTHER. SO WITH THAT I
REGION I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR FELL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. SB EIGHT OH THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MADE MAYES I ARGUE ARE CURRY.
ACURA CURRY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I BONTA. BURKE BURKE I
RIO CARILLO I'D FLORA FLORA ICE
LIMóN LIMóN AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I ATE NAZARIAN. RAMOS
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
HAS TROUBLES THAT ARE VALUABLE
HAS TWELVE BOTH BELIEVE THE
ROLLOVER FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON.
ALSO JUST TO. ALSO JUST ONCE
AGAIN- SO MANY MEMBERS WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MISSING WE WILL NOT BE STARTING
ON SB SEVEN NINETY THREE UNTIL
ALL FIFTEEN MEMBERS ARE IN OUR
PRESENT- AND THE SOONER. I
THINK- CENTER GOT JOHNNY WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT WELL SO BUT
JUST SO YOU KNOW WE WON'T BE
STARTING SB SEVEN NINETY THREE.
UNTIL OFFICE MEMBERS SENT
HOUSING. THANK MEMBERS ON THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBERS CURRENT
ALLOWS CHANTREY CALIFORNIANS TO
PETITION THE COURTS TO CHANGE
THEIR NAME AND STANDARD CONFORM
TO THEIR GENDER IDENTITY THE
LAW THEN ALLOWS THAT PERSON'S
OLD BIRTH CERTIFICATE TO BE
SEALED AND A NEW SHOOT AS AN
ORIGINAL TO BOTH PROTECT THAT
PERSON'S PRIVACY AND RESPECT
THEIR IDENTITY HOWEVER THERE'S
NO PROVISION IN THE LAW AS TO
THE TREATMENT OF TRANS PEOPLE'S
CERTIFICATE. THEIR CHILDREN. HE
SAID FOR ONE WITH A THE PROCESS
FOR UPDATING TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE'S MERIT CERTIFICATES AND
THE BIRTH CERTIFICATES OF THEIR
CHILDREN WITH THE PROCESS FOR
UPDATING THEIR OWN BIRTH
CERTIFICATE THIS WILL HELP TO
PROTECT THE CITY OF TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE AND PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION WHEN AND ROLL
THEIR CHILD COOL APPLY FOR A
LOAN OR SEEK TO MAKE MEDICAL
DECISIONS ON BEHALF OF IN STATE.
I WANT TO THANK THE SPONSORS
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED FOR THEIR LONG
STANDING DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
BILL. AS A RESULT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I AM COMMITTED TO
GRANTING THEM DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION TO ALLOW FOR
ENOUGH TIME FOR THE COUNCIL TO
PREPARE ANY NECESSARY FORMS AND
TO COMPLY WITH THE BILL.
TESTIFYING BY TELEPHONE TâM
MARTIN WITH THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND AMERICA HOUSE
AND BUSH FROM THE LAW OFFICE OF
THE MAYOR HAS AND BUSH. THEY
ARE ON THE- THE SECONDARY LINE
AS THEY WERE TRYING TO GET ONTO
THE MAIN WITNESS LINE AND WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO DO SO. I ACTUALLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
GET A SENATOR GALGIANI- THAT
MODERATOR CAN WE FIND OUR
WITNESSES. ON THE SECONDARY
LINE. AGAIN IF YOU'RE WHAT
EFFORT A CONFERENCE CALL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO WILL OPEN UP
YOUR MIND YOU CAN PROVIDE YOUR
WITNESS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
DO HAVE A FEW WOULD HAVE CUED
UP ARE WE LOOKING FOR ANYONE IS
THE PERFECT AT THE TIME WE WERE
LOOKING FOR TAMMY MARTIN AND
AMIRA HASS AND BUSH. GREAT
THANK YOU OPEN ANA TAMMY MARTIN
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. BUT MORE IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS CANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA ONE THIRTY SEVEN
FOUR ONE- MY CO WITNESS AND
YOUR HAVEN BUSH ALSO ON THE
LINE HAVING TROUBLE. FINALLY
HER Q. AND SHE HAS A HAVE A
GREAT ABOUT THE VERY REAL. OF
THE FALL HAVE ON PEOPLE CLIMB
AND DIE IN OF BORN OUT BY THE
DATA AS WELL FOR EXAMPLE A
RECENT NATIONAL SURVEY REVEALED
OVER ONE THIRD OF TRANSGENDER
ON. BAND AROUND THE BALTIC THAT
MIGHT SERVICE BETTER OUT SIMPLY
FOR PREVENTING IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS THAT LISTS THE
NEIGHBOR GENDER THAT DIDN'T
MATCH THEIR GENDER PRESENTATION
AND ON 11% OF TRANSGENDER ON
AND REPORTED THAT THE CORRECT
NAME AND GENDER. LET'S ON ALL
RIGHT NINETY WE HAVE A MORE
WORK TO. THE BILL ANOTHER
IMPORTANT. WHAT I WON'T BE.
THOUSAND SEVEN P. AUTHORED BY
SENATOR NOW AND TONI ATKINS
AMONG OTHER ALIVE THAT WE THE
FOUNDATION FOR OUR AND BURNING
I DA FOR ALL. WHO WORK VERY TO
CENTER FOR HER ATTENTION THE
ISSUE AND WE ARE FOR THE MANY
MANY HOURS IN QUITE THE WE
RECEIVED THE PAST YEAR FROM THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S AND JUDICIAL
TO ENSURE THAT THE BILLY THE
BILL IS READY EMPLOYMENT I'M
NOT EXACTLY. SUPPORT I THINK
SEVEN FORTY TODAY AS WELL AND
HOPEFULLY MICHAEL ME IT ALSO
NO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND
BY MISS LAMONT WE'RE STILL
LOOKING FOR OUR- MIRACLE EAR
HOUSE OF US HOUSE IN WHICH- CAN
YOU HEAR ME HELLO YES. HELLO
HELLO. YOU CAN GET THE CAN HAVE
A GREAT. OKAY I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD I'M GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS AMERICAN BUSH
I'M LOCKED UP WITH AMERICAN
CULTURE ALONG WITH SO A LOT OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE FOCUS ON
HOW TO BE TAKEN TO VISUAL.
FAMILY PRACTICE AT THE
TRANSGENDER. AND LEGAL NAME
GENDER CHIU. ALPHABET AND HALF
YEARS WORKING THE WILLIAM OF
DUTY LGBT RICHTER CENTER YOU
FEEL LIKE ALL OF LAW. FOUR I
GOT NUMBER TECHNICAL. THE BILL
ON MODEL BUT IMPACT APPEALED.
COMMUNITY. OPENING IDEA THE
BILL I WORK FOR THE CLIENT
GOING TO AN AMICABLE. SHOULD TO
TAKE BACK NAY NAY. AND BOTH
SHARE. THE GREAT. THEIR
CHILDREN BLACK NAME AS A RESULT.
HOWEVER WHEN SHE ASKED IF SHE
COULD NOT OLDER CHILD RICHARD.
TO REFLECT YOUR HUSBAND GENDER
HE HAD TRANSIT TO MAIL BETWEEN
THE BIRTH OF THEIR FIRST SECOND
CHILD. ALL OF THEIR BUT IT
WOULD. MONEY AND I CAN
GUARANTEE OUTCOME. WHICH DOES
NOT MAKE THE CHANGE AT ALL. THE
LOOK OF THE CHIU MOTHER. ON
BIRTH CERTIFICATE. I CAN THE
NAME AND GENDER TO FOR ANOTHER
CLIENT ABOUT YEAR AGO. SHE
RECEIVED HER COURT ORDER NAMING
CHEN CHANGE EIGHT WEEKS APPLE
ABOUT THE PROFESSION WITH THE-
BUT IT TOOK A EIGHT. TO
AMERICAN GET. IN ORDER TO GET
FROM YOU MAY CERTIFICATE WITH
THE ONE FIELD AND WITHOUT.
REFORM NAME DROPPED OPEN THE
ILLEGAL MUCH OF THE COURT HOW
TO PROMOTE YOUR- JUDGE BOB
MOTION. THAT WOULD PROVED THAT
THIRTY EMAIL BACK IN FORTH I
DON'T RECORD YEAH I COUNTED.
MAKE PHONE CALLS UNTIL THE VERY
I BETWEEN THE- THANK. NUMBER OF
NOT. SHE HER FINE A FLAT FEE
PAYMENT WITH ME THE ONLY HER
FOR ONE HOUR OF MY TIME TO MY
AMERICAN. BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
TRANSIENT PEOPLE TO HAVE THE
FINANCIAL POOREST HARPER COUNTY
TO COMPLETE THEIR NAME AND
CHANGE PEOPLE ARE AND I DON'T
THINK OUR MARRIAGE ON MY COULD
BEEN COMPLETE A WITHOUT THE OF
A LAWYER FRANKLY I WASN'T EVEN
SURE THAT I COULD DO IT I'M NOT
SURE THAT EVERY WILL GET THE
SAME OUT. UNDER THE NEW NORMAL
EVERYONE THE- I AM. AND I. THE
CLOCK ONE HAVE BECOME A
PRIVILEGE NOT A RIGHT NO ONE
WANTS TO BE DENIED WITH THEIR
ABOUT WHEN THEY'RE GONNA.
ADDING EXTRA COMPANY OF A FUNNY
LOOK BIRDS ARE PARTNERSHIP
AMENDMENT TO COULD LEAD TO
CONFUSION AND THE COMPANY OUR
THE BILL WOULD REDUCE IT BY ONE
VERY BY LAW SUCH TALKING
ACCURATE REFLECT TRENDS OF
PEOPLE AND. CONFUSION CAN
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HOW THEY LIVE
NAME AND BUT COULD OCCUR ON
CALL MANAGER DOCKING NOT JUST
ABOUT CERTIFICATE THE BILL
WOULD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM PLEASE OPEN THE KEY FOR
OTHER MEMBER OTHER OTHER OTHERS
IN SUPPORT WE'RE JUST ASKING
FOR NAME AND ORGANIZATION ONLY
PLEASE. TELEMEDICINE PORT FOR
SB SEVEN FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ORDER
TO OPEN LINE NUMBER ONE ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS CASH SHE WALKED. I'M WITH
CARD OUT FROM HEALTH L. G. B.
Q. AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT TO OPEN MY NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TO WAIT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOR THE WHOLE THIS IS FOUND
TWENTY NINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FOUR ONE THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M BY THE HEAT AND THE TRIED
IN. A SEVEN FOUR ONE. THANK YOU.
POST. NINE THREE ZERO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TO MAKE A LIVING
CHARD REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT Q. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS TOM HARKIN AND I
AM THE PARENT OF A TRANSGENDER
TWEEN I GUESS YOU COULD CALL
HIM DOCTOR AND I AM OR AT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GENTLEMAN AND A REMINDER
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN
FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
BEEN ZERO AT THE TIME. LINE ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE OFTEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PEOPLE HAD. NO RESPONSE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE ON THE PART
CRITICAL HAD HER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO
RECORDED- NO- THAN A RECORDED
WITNESSES OPPOSITION SO IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION
WILL ASK THEM TO COME ON IN TO
STATE THEIR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. SO YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINES MADAM OPERATOR
TO- PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION OR
WITNESSES AND OPERATE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVEN FOUR
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO
HAVE A FEW PEOPLE QUEUED UP
THERE CURRENTLY WITH OPERATOR.
THANK YOU. HE SAID I'M SORRY TO
MISS IT YOU SAID YOU HAD NO
MORE PEOPLE QUEUED UP. YOU HAVE
TO PEOPLE THERE WITH OPERATOR
THAT MOMENT.TO PEOPLE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR YES MY
PLEASURE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LINE THREE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR MIND IS MUTED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER FOUR THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MERE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
I'M ACCORDING TO BILL. PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. RTL NOW. IT. AND
THAT TIME WE HAVE NO ONE UP ONE
MORE PERSON LINE THREE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ANOTHER REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. LITTLE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO TWO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. TWO TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSE
HER FIVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. SEE
NONE- WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE- AUTHOR FOR CLOSING
STATEMENT THE BILL DOESN'T
ENJOY IT DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAD A MOTION BY US
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAMONT.
CENTER GOES TO YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS DO PASS. IS ME WE
MIGHT SHE- TO OF.
APPROPRIATIONS SB SEVEN FOUR
ONE DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOOD I WOULD I MADE. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW BIGELOW
NO BONTA AND I BURKE BURKE I TO
RIO. FLORA. FLORA NOT VOTING
LIMóN LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
EIGHT I WON NO THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY BILL PASSES WE WILL
LEAVE THE A ROLL OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER GALGIANI. THANK
YOU. WE DO HAVE ONE ITEM ON
CONSENT- SP ONE SIXTY TWO IS
OUR MOTION. THE MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISS
LOW MOAN- AND- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB ONE SIXTY TWO SB ONE
SIXTY TWO MOTION IS CONSENT TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I
WOULD I MAYES. MAYES I ADD YOUR
CURRY. BIGELOW BIGELOW I'D
BONTA WANT TO I'D BURKE. BURKE
I RIO. FLORA FLORA I LIMóN
LIMóN I AM A PARTY. NAZARIAN
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ ICE SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON AYE. TEN ICE NO ZERO
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY. WE
ARE GOING TO WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE
FIFTEEN MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVE
ON SB SEVEN NINETY THREE SO
MEMBERS THAT ARE MISSING FROM
THE CHAMBER PLEASE COME TO THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE
OVER TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE FOR WITNESSES. ON THIS
BILL. MET MEMBERS PLEASE COME
TO THE CHAMBER. HELLO TO THE
OPERATOR ARE YOU WITH US ON
TODAY'S CALL. WE ARE- MISTER
I'M SERVICE RUN WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO START FROM INTO WE
HAVE ALL OF OUR MEMBERS HERE SO
YOU CAN. JUST KIND OF HANG OUT
OF IT YOU KNOW.
IF SENATOR
JACKSON WOULD LIKE TO COME AND
HAVE HER BILL PRESENTED WERE
HAPPY TO DO THAT. MISTER
MONNING MISTER NIELSEN DR PAN
MR PORTANTINO ANYBODY WANT TO
COME PRESENT THEIR BILL. HAPPY
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT.
THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON WILL GO
AHEAD AND HEAR YOUR BILL. WHERE
WE'D LIKE GOING TO THAT THERE
IS FINE WITH ME. WHATEVER YOUR
PLEASURE IS MA'AM. OKAY CATCH
YOUR BREATH IS FINE. SURE YOU
CAN DO THIRTY LIKE NO. OKAY
NEVER MIND CURRENTLY BACK SORRY.
ONE OF THE WORD YEAH THE WHOLE
NUMBER OF. NO NOT. OKAY BUT THE-
OKAY I USED TO BURKE. RIGHT OF
SIX PEOPLE WELL SENATOR JEFF.
HE WILL. OKAY. YOU MAY PROCEED
IF YOU'RE READY- SENATOR
JACKSON THANK. YOU A MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS INTERESTING.
ACCOMMODATIONS AND I APPRECIATE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL. BEFORE WE START I'VE BEEN
ADVISED THAT. GIVEN THE
TELEPHONE SITUATION I DO HAVE
WITNESSES BUT WOULD REQUEST
THAT EFFORTS SHOULD BE MADE I
THINK ON THE PUBLIC LINES I'M
NOT TOTALLY SURE. HOW THIS IS
OR ISN'T WORKING BUT- IT'S MY
HOPE THAT MY WITNESSES WILL BE
ON THE CALL- AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME SO WITH THAT. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THOSE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THE LANGUAGE OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. WHICH CLARIFIES THE
FLEXIBILITY AVAILABLE TO
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
AROUND SAFE STORAGE OF FUEL FOR
BACKUP GENERATORS. AND
PRESERVES THE NINETY SIX HOUR
BACKUP POWER REQUIREMENT AS A
STANDARD. I WOULD- TO STAR LIKE
TO THANK OUR YOUR EFFORTS AND
THAT IF YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US- THOUGHTFULLY AND
COLLABORATIVELY- TO GET THIS
BILL I THINK IN A CONDITION
THAT'S GOING TO SERVE PURPOSES
OF PROTECTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE. IN THESE
NURSING HOME FACILITIES SO THIS
BILL IS A SIMPLE IN THAT IF
YOU. SOLVES A BIG PROBLEM OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE TO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT BACKUP POWER TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THEIR RESIDENTS WHEN THE POWER
GOES. WE HAVE SEEN THAT ALL TOO
OFTEN I THINK MANY OF US AS I
LOOK AROUND THIS ROOM IN OUR
DISTRICTS DURING FIRES. AND
DURING PS PS EVENTS. THE BILL.
ARE EXCHANGED COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE THESE FACILITIES OR WERE
THESE FACILITIES ARE LOCATED
THAT THE FACILITIES MUST HAVE
UP TO NINE OR AT LEAST NINETY
SIX HOURS OF BACKUP GENERATION.
I IN CASE OF AN OUTAGE WHETHER
CAUSED BY A NATURAL DISASTER OR
PS PS AMOUNT. CURRENT
REGULATIONS IN THE STATE ONLY
REQUIRE NURSING HOMES TO
PROVIDE VERY LIMITED BACKUP
POWER FOR UP TO SIX HOURS. NOW
THIS IS SIMPLY INSUFFICIENT AND
A WEAK STANDARD THAT IS TRULY A
RECIPE FOR DISASTER IN
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT CLIMATE OF
EXTREME WEATHER. THIS MEASURE
SEEKS TO CODIFY ALREADY
EXISTING FEDERAL STANDARDS THAT
ARE REQUIRED UNDER FEDERAL LAW
BUT NOT UNDER STATE LAW. THE
REQUIRED NURSING HOMES TO HAVE
ALTERNATIVE SOURCES OF POWER TO
PROTECT RESIDENTS HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND MAINTAIN SAFE
TEMPERATURES I THINK THIS IS
CRITICAL O NOTE. FOR OUR
SENSITIVE SENIOR POPULATION YOU
CAN GET EXTREMELY HOT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR SOME SENIORS TO
BE ABLE TO ADJUST TO THAT HE'D-
IT ALSO PROVIDES BACKUP POWER.
FOR PARKS ENGINE AND FOR
MEDICINE THAT NEED TO BE CAP AT
AN APPROPRIATE TEMPERATURE. SO
THESE ARE ALREADY EXISTING
FEDERAL STANDARDS TO WHICH
ALMOST ALL OF CALIFORNIA
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES ARE
SUBJECTED TO. BUT FOR THOSE MET
THOSE ARE NURSING HOMES TO COME
UNDER STATE REGULATION. THEY
ONLY NOW ARE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN SIX HOURS. THIS AGAIN
MERELY CODIFIES THE FEDERAL
STANDARD INTO STATE LAW AND
ADDRESSES A SMALL NUMBER OF
THESE HOMES HOWEVER THIS BILL
THANKS TO AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE
WORKED ON WITH YOU SHOULD FOR
SOME REASON FEDERAL REGULATIONS
BE CHANGED OR ELIMINATED. THOSE
STANDARDS WILL BECOME THE LAW
OF CALIFORNIA YOUR RESPECTIVE
OF WHETHER THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTS TO REMOVE THEM
OR NOT. OF HI I DON'T NEED I
THINK TO EXPLAIN ANY FURTHER
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS IN AN ERA
OF COVERT WHEN OUR SENIORS ARE
UNDER SUCH STRESS IN PARTICULAR
NURSING HOMES PEOPLE IN THOSE
HOMES ARE SUBJECT. TO THESE
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS NOW THE
FIRE SEASON IS HERE. TO ADD
THAT ON WE'RE PROBABLY OR MOST
LIKELY WE WILL SEE. TRY TO STAY
IN PLACE DURING THESE PSP ****
OR DURING WILDFIRES BECAUSE OF
THE DIFFICULTIES ASSOCIATE WITH
MOVING HESE FOLKS AND THE
ISSUES OF CONGREGATE CARE SO IT
BECOMES EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
THAT WE PASS THIS MEASURE.
PROVIDING TESTING OUR OVER THE
PHONE AND I HOPE THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO ACCESS THIS ARE KAREN
JONES THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
SERVICES. OF SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY AND KRISTA BARNETT
NELSON FOR COUNTERPART IN
SONOMA COUNTY AT. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR- WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTAKE OR CURRY A
SECONDBY MISSILE MON- YOUR
WITNESSES- MISSED THE MODERATOR
PLEASE WE'RE LOOKING FOR KAREN
JONES. LONG TERM CARE- BUT THEN
IF YOU GOT A SECONDARY LINE OR
SOMETHING I KNOW THE LINES ARE
FULL. AND KRISTA BARNETT
NELSON- LOOKING FOR. THOSE TWO
WITNESSES ARE PRIMARY WITNESSES.
AND JOHN BURNETT NELSON PLEASE
PRESS ONE IN EUROPE WE CAN OPEN
UP YOUR MIND. I DON'T HAVE
ANYONE SHOWING UP INDICATING
THAT THE OR THE WITNESSES. OKAY
WELL OF JUST PUT THE WORD OUT
KAREN JONES- KRISTA BARNETT
NELSON PLEASE- PLEASE DO YOUR
BEST TO CALL AND WE'RE TRYING
TO TRYING TO GET YOU ON THE
LINE. UNTIL WE FIND THEM WILL
ASK THAT OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT WILL JUST ASK FOR THEIR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION ONLY SO
IF THE PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE
ANNOUNCED THEMSELVES WE WILL
ASK THEM TO BREAK AN- ASSET
HAVE THE MODERATOR BREAK THEM
AND SO. SOURCE ASKING FOR UP
WITH OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- NAME AND- ORGANIZATION
ONLY. NEVER MIND RELATED
GENTLEMAN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO FOR
TO OPEN MY NUMBER ONE FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS LYDIA LEASING FROM KINFOLK
PROJECT MINISTRIES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE
THREE OF THESE WITH NO
EXEMPTIONS FOR MENTAL CIGARETTE
SIMPLY RICH THE CARS THANK YOU.
ON THE A TEMPLATE THAT'S THE
RIGHT BUILT- WE'RE LOOKING AT
SB TWELVE ZERO SEVEN BY SENATOR
JACKSON'S. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE TWO ZERO
FIVE AND YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE.
YOURSELF FROM QUEUE BY PRESSING
THE SAME PROP ONE IN ZERO. NEXT
TO OPEN MY NUMBER ONE EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
REMOVED HIMSELF MAKOTO LINE
NUMBER THREE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE THIRTEEN IF
YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE THREE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REBEKAH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE AU SEVEN. THANK
YOU. LINE THREE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KELLY BROOK
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE OF THAT.
THANK YOU. ONE FOR FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
JULIE NOW AFTER BALL ON BEHALF
OF CAPT STONE TURBINES A
CALIFORNIA COMPANY
MANUFACTURING THE GREAT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THE FORTY
SIX. THANK YOU. MY NINETY TWO
YEAR LINE IS. MY NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DANIEL TERRACE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE TO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
CHAU DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVE ON TO
MY NUMBER TWO ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AND EIGHTY
S. ON BEHALF OF SCA CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
TWELVE AU SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
WANTED ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
NEXT OPEN LINE FOR SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE FOR SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIRTY KNOW BORROW BUT
BEEN PRESENTED COULD TELL ME I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOUR WITNESS
FOR SUPPORT KAREN JONES-
ENCRYPTED BARNETT NELSON PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO WE CAN OPEN YOUR
LINES. AND WE DO HAVE A CHRISTA
BARNETT NELSON ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN AS
PART AT ALL NOTHING. I THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY APOLOGIES
FOR THE DELAY- MY NAME IS
KRISTA BARNETT NELSON AND I'M
HONORED TO SERVE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SENIOR
ACTIVITY SERVICES. THE LONG
TERM CARE- BUT THE PROGRAM
FRESNO COUNTY AND ALSO AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL FOR THE CATTLE
IN THE HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
AFTER EVERYTHING MEDIA PAST
PRESIDENT FOR CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN. AND THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR A LARGE
BUT- HAPPY FOR THE LAST.
WITNESS SONOMA COUNTY INDOOR
TWO MAJOR CATASTROPHIC FIRES
APPLIED OUR SHUTTLE AND NOW AND
THEN IT. YOU KNOW I OFTEN ASK
MYSELF WHAT'S NEXT. OKAY. ROLL
THAT. ELECTION IT REMAINS HAVE
IT HOW THE HOW INTO THE STATE
THE OF OUR MULCH READ THE- WHO
WERE. GOVERNOR ANYTHING A
PICTURE FOR YOU. THANK YOU FROM
A NURSE HOME OR CHECK OF ALL
THE- SCENARIOS AND- PLAN CAN.
FOR ALL PATIENTS CHECK LIKE ANY
WHAT CHECK CRITICAL MEDICATION
CHECK. I TO FALL UNDER.
DIMENSION JACK THIRTY TO FIFTY
STAFF AB ONE SINCE CHECK. IT
REQUIRES. THREE OF THE WOULD
MAKE COUPLE BUT I TRIED
LOCATION. WHICH YOU AND FOR
WHICH WILL. PUT TO RECEIVE
MEDICALLY FOR ALL PEOPLE. NOW
AT WHAT AT THE- SITUATION. THE
OVER FORTY. YEAH HAVE RESIDENTS
KOBE NAY AND FACILITIES THE
COVERED PARKING GARAGE REQUIRED
TO BE I FROM A RESIDENTS SHE IF
WE HAVE A POWER OUTAGE WHY
HAPPENS WHEN GO BECAUSE OF THE
PEOPLE OR VACUUM TO OTHER
FACILITIES THE FOR RESPONSE.
EIGHT SIX INFECTION SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE INTAKE THAT.
PEOPLE AT THE WERE. SB FOLLOW
SEVEN IT'S CALL NOW MORE THAN
EVER PLEASE HELP WHICH MAKE
SURE THAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS ARE NOT NEEDLESSLY
IMPACTED BY A POWER OUTAGE WHEN
HE SIMPLE SOLUTION IS RATTLING
AROUND. THANK YOU YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOODBYE
KEPT NODDING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. STILL HOPING FOR KAREN
JONES OF KAREN JONES IS OUT
THERE. IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO SO WE
CAN OPEN YOUR LINE. AND I DO
NOT HAVE HER CUED UP THERE. BUT
I DO SHOW A FEW INDIVIDUAL
SOCIAL SUPPORT. OKAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ONE FOR SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL THAT
WAS NICE WHAT. ONE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR MIND IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. LINE FOR SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GREAT
THE FIFTEENTH TIME WITH THE
TERM IF IT CAME DOWN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR STORAGE
OF THIRTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND FOUR EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE FOUR SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DELIGHTED
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
WITH NO RESPONSIBLE ONE TO ONE
NUMBER FOUR NINETY FIVE PER
LINE IS NOW OPEN. CHRISTINA
GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE OTHER
PERSON THAT JUST CUTE AFTER
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WILL OPEN LINE NUMBER
FIVE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON IN
A ONE OF A ALTHOUGH. HE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE OF THEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND AT THE
TIME I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE FOR SHOWING SUPPORT OKAY
THIS POINT THEN WE WILL MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY LOOKING FOR SUPPORT.
THERE'S NO ONE IN. THE ROOM SO
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION WE
DO HAVE OUR- OPPOSITION LISTED.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ALEXANDRIA
SMITH DAVIS. IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE MA'AM PLEASE. ALERT THE
OPERATOR SO WE CAN HAVE YOU
GIVE TESTIMONY.
AND WHAT DO YOU
DO UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK
YOU.
HOW DARE THEY ARE NOT A
WITNESS YOU'RE LOOKING FOR OKAY.
TO INDIVIDUAL SOCIAL POINT I
BELIEVE. OKAY WELL IF THEY LIKE
TO VOICE HER SUPPORT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT.
NINE FIVE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
LISA COLEMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE- BUT
MINISTER. AND IT FOR. ACTED
MEETING AREN'T ABLE TO GET
THROUGH ON THE CALL I'LL BUT I
WOULD SAY DAD KAREN JONES IF I
HAD HER TESTIMONY IN FRONT OF
ME IT WOULD BE AS AN ARM BUT
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SIX CHANNEL TO DISPEL
OR- AT LEAST TWO DECADES. THE
IS A BILL THAT. YOU KNOW SHE
WANTED YEARS AGO THAT.
RELOCATING OLDER ADULTS IN THE
BEST A SITUATION IS FRAUGHT
WITH- CHALLENGES BUT DURING
CALVET THIS IS NOT THE TIME
WHEN WE WANT TO BE LOOKING AT
RELOCATING A RESIDENT THE
SHELTERING IN PLACE IT'S OUR
BEST APPROACH AND THIS BILL
ALLOWS FACILITIES THAT HOTLINE.
IT BEST PRACTICES A WHEN THEY
WERE IN THE ACT- IT TOOK MORE
THAN SIX HOURS TO EVACUATE SO.
THAT I HAVE STILL HAVING SIX
HOURS OF A BACKUP POWER RIGHT
NOW IS INSUFFICIENT AND THIS
BILL ALLOWS US TO SAVE LIVES BY
GIVING FACILITY PINE. IF THEY
HAVE TO WAIT THE TIME TO DO IT
THOUGHTFULLY AND CAREFULLY. AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MS COLEMAN. SO IS THERE
MADAME MODERATOR ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT OR ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION. I DO HAVE SOMEONE-
SHOWING SUPPORT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FIND FIVE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIVE THIRTEEN
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HEY THIS IS
JENNIFER SLATER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION TO HELP
FACILITIES WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN
OPPOSING LET THEM AT THE
POSITION IS THAT OKAY TO GO
AHEAD AT THIS POINT. YES THAT'S
FINE THANK YOU. OKAY GREAT AND-
I BELIEVE THAT ALEX- WITH
LEADING AGE OF HAVING. A
PROBLEM GETTING ON THE LINE SO
IT'S- OKAY FOR ME TO SAY A FEW
MORE. AND STAND UP AS MUCH AND
I DIDN'T HAVE THE FINE. OKAY
WOULD I'M JUST MAKING JUST A
FEW COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF- OF
THOSE THAT CALIFORNIA
SUFFICIENT HOPEFULLY THE
LEADING AGE WHICH REPRESENT
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES IN THE STATE
NOTHING GEN I WE HAVE A MUCH
BETTER POSITION VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE OFFERING THE
SPONSORS WORKING WITH US ON A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS SPECIALLY
IMAGE AT ONE THE CENTER JACKSON
IS TAKING A WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CLARITY ON DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITY TO SLEEP HERE
THEY'RE NOT OURS THAT GO BACK
UP OKAY. THE THAT. DURING THE
WHAT FIRST IS THAT WE STILL THE
BILL LACKS ON WHAT WE TALKED
MAIN A SAFE HAVE EVERYBODY'S
EVERY POLICE ARE DE FACILITIES
ON THE COAST REGIONS HAVE
DIFFERENT WE THROW YOU H. BACK
SYSTEM. BECAUSE THE- LAKE. MY
UNDERSTOOD YOU KNOW I COMMITTEE
STAFF UP THE CAL TO SEE HOPE
THE AUTHOR HAVE BEEN ASKED FOR
SOME CLEAR CASE OF THE HEALTH
BUT WE HAVE STILL HEARD
ANYTHING BACK AT POINT SO
FORTUNATELY IN WE'RE STILL
HOPING TO GET SOME. OF CLARITY
ON THAT AND- HOPE TO HEAR BACK
FROM- THAT APARTMENT AT THE WE
CAN GET BETTER CLARITY I THINK
EVERY FISCALLY IN THE STATE. IS
REQUIRED TO BUT WOULD BE. BY
THE BY EIGHT TRACK THEM BUT
THAT WOULD HOOK UP TO THE
NINETY ARE PEOPLE GENERATORS
AND SO. THAT COULD BE
EXPENSIVE- ACOSTA STATED WITH
THAT REQUIREMENT. SECOND
LASTLY- DUE TO THE LACK OF
CLARITY BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WE'VE GOT
THE RECALL. WILL BE DELAYED
UNTIL WE CAN PROPERLY ADDRESS
THE STATE'S INTERPRETATION. AND
EVEN THOUGH ELEMENT TO THE BILL
OR THREE FOOT FEDERAL LAW THESE
REQUIREMENTS YET. CLEARLY
OUTLINED FOR NURSING HELP
PROVIDE FIRST OF WE DO CONTINUE
TO WORK THE AUBURN THE
COMMITTEE. MEETING DRESS CREATE
YOU. THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MADAME MODERATOR
THERE ANY FOR WITNESSES EITHER
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL IN THE
QUEUE. AFTER A LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN ALIGN IS OPEN. ONE
ONE SEVENTEEN ALIGN IT OPEN.
EMBEDDED BUT HE ARE CONCERNED
FAMILY MEMBER WITH SOMEONE IN
THAT NURSING HOME IN FACT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT TO MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
ONE THIRTY EIGHT ONE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU- I ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN NINETY THREE I AM A
MAIN WITNESS. OKAY YOU HAVE THE
ROAD AND I WAS TOLD TO DO THAT
SO THAT THEY KNOW WHERE I AM
PERFECT THANK YOU YOU HAVE YOU
YOU YOU'RE YOU HAVE SOMEONE TO
FILL IN TOOK ABOUT THREE
MINUTES YOU'VE GOT THREE
MINUTES YOU'VE OF THE FLOOR.
YEAH OKAY FIRST OF ALL RESPECT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JACKIE AREAS AND I'M THE
OWNER OF ONE CHESTERFIELD HERE
INTO MACULA. CALIFORNIA AND
I'VE BEEN IN A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER FOR. THIRTY PLUS YEARS
EIGHTEEN AT MY CURRENT LOCATION
AND I HAVE NINE EMPLOYEES. I
THESE EMPLOYEES ARE MEMBERS OF
MY FAMILY AND I HANG ON HANG ON
JUST A SECOND YOU SAID SEVEN
NINETY. THAT'S ON CAN BE. A TO
AU SEVEN. YEAH SO THIS IS YOUR
THE BILL THIS IS A DIFFERENT
BILL I KNOW IT IS. I THE
PROBLEM IS LIKE SOME WORK OUT
WHAT'S IN THE QUEUE AND I WAS
ASKED TO CALL IN SO THAT WE
COULD- DOES YOUR MODERATORS
COULD FIND ME FOR THAT
PARTICULAR BILL WHEN THE TIME
CAME I SEE SO WE'RE NOT READY
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY YET BUT- SO.
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN. KEEP
TRACK OF THIS NUMBER THIS IS
THIS IS A MAIN- WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. TO S. B. SEVEN
NINETY THREE WHICH WE HOPE WE
WILL HEAR IN JUST A FEW
MINUTES. SO YES OF COURSE OF
COURSE- SO I'M LOOKING FOR. ONE
FINAL TIME ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR S. B.
TWELVE ZERO SEVEN BY SENATOR
HANNAH BETH JACKSON. ONE THREE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS RAY BILL AND I'M
CALLING TO A POST SB SEVEN NINE
THREE. RESTART THE. ANYONE ELSE
SHOWING OPPOSITION FOR SB ONE
TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT SIR WE JUST HAVE A FEW
PEOPLE QUEUED UP. JUST A
REMINDER THIS IS FOR S. B.
TWELVE- AU SEVEN SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON. SORRY FOR THE
DELAY THE PROBLEM. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TO OPEN MY
NUMBER FIVE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CREATE UP
TO AN ARTICLE. AND NEXT TO OPEN
MY NUMBER THREE TWENTY TWO
STREAMLINED OPEN LINE THREE
TWENTY TWO. ONE THREE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE SHOWED UP POSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU MADAM
MADAM MODERATOR WILL GO AHEAD
AND BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE FOR SENATOR
JACKSON'S. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU CENTER FOR
OUR BRING IS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL FOR DOES YOU KNOW WORKING
AND EMS INDUSTRY COME ACROSS A
LOT OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES THOSE ARE A ONE-
FACILITIES AREN'T REALLY WELL
PREPARED FOR BIRD SHE'S ARE
DISASTERS WE'VE HERE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WHETHER IT'S THE
FIRES ARE THE FLOODS.
EARTHQUAKES THAT THEY WEREN'T
READY PREPARE ADDRESS THESE
EMERGENCY BUT I LIKE THIS BILL
AS IF LOOKING TO ONE WAY TO
CONTINUE I GIVE THEM UP TO NOW
OPERATE WITH THE EMERGENCY
BACKUP SYSTEM SO I WANT TO
BRING FORWARD NUMBER FOUR
DESPORTIVO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ ANYBODY
ELSE. I'M SORRY I MISTER
SANTIAGO. AND I WANT THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS AWFUL
BILL FORD BUT JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE AS WE'VE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT A TIME LINE
IN IF IT'S STILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION ARE WE
GONNA TIMELINE THAT MAKES SENSE
AND IS STILL RESPONSIBLE TO
ADDRESS. THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING. PUBLISHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR OUR
OBJECTION BRING IT BACK. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- LOW MOAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THIS ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR MADAM- MADAM SENATOR YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. VERY MUCH VERY
BRIEFLY THIS IS THERE IS AN
URGENCY TO THIS ISSUE MOST OF
THE NURSING FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ALREADY A BITE BY
ARE REQUIRED TO BUY BY THE
NINETY SIX HOUR OF REQUIREMENTS
THIS ASSEMBLY AND THE REST OF
THOSE OF FACILITY WE'RE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO KEEP WORKING
WITH THEM BUT WE ARE IN FIRE
SEASON WE'RE IN COVERT SEE AN
AD. OUT THERE THAT. THE TEXT.
AND I RISK ASK VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR JACKSON WITH
THAT ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE SB TWELVE AU SEVEN
MOTION IS DUE PROCESS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WOOD I WOULD
BUY MAYES. MASON VOTING ARE
THERE CURRY. AGUILAR CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
BONTA. BURKE BURKE I CORREO
THREE OH AYE FLORA. FLORA NOT
VOTING LIMóN ON. LIMóN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I IT NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I'D WALDRON. WALDRON AYE. CAN I
ZERO NOW. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECOND MA'AM SECRETARY THE BILL
IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHER STAT ON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR JACKSON'S.
MEMBERS THANK YOU. AT THIS
POINT WE HAD FIFTEEN MEMBERS WE
LOST ONE- TO. PLEASE THE YEAH
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
START SENATOR HILL AND ASK THE
MEMBERS TO PLEASE UNLESS YOU
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO LEAVE THE
CHAMBER TO PLEASE STAY OR FOR
THE ENTIRE TESTIMONY. SENATOR
HILL PLEASE PRESS. SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
2% AS BE SEVEN NINETY THREE.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF KIDS
IN CALIFORNIA WILL DIE A
PREMATURE DEATH AT THE HANDS OF
BIG TOBACCO. WE ARE ALLOWING
THEM TO HER AND KILL OUR KIDS
WITH. MEN MEN. CANDY FLAVORED
POISON. BE EASY. THIS BILL. TO
THAT WOULD BE THE EASY WAY OUT
THE WEEK EASY WAY OUT. END THAT
IS WHAT BIG TOBACCO WILL TELL
YOU SOLVE THE PROBLEM. A BABY
IN BILLING NOR BIG TOBACCO'S
HISTORY OF DESTROYING AND
DEVASTATING OUR COMMUNITIES.
BABY ONLY IS A REGRESSIVE
APPROACH THAT HURTS KIDS MORE
THAN IT HELPED THEM IN
UNDERCUTS POLICYMAKERS. AND
KIDS IN ALL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED OR WILL
SOON IN STRONG LOCAL RULES.THE
RABBANI CIGARETTE USE BY YOUNG
PEOPLE IS WHAT PHONE IT IS
WHITE YEARS OF KLEINIAN USE.
ALL FOR. THE YOUNG. TEEN ENSURE.
I AM DISGUSTED AND TROUBLED BY
THIS BUT NOT SURPRISED. BIG
TOBACCO HAS PRAYED ON YOUTH FOR
GENERATIONS LORRAINE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WITH
AGGRESSIVE MARKETING FALSE
PROMISES OF SAFETY AND KID
FRIENDLY FLAVOR. WE MUST BREAK
TOBACCO BIG TOBACCO'S DEATH
GRIP ON OUR CHILDREN. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE THE
EXPLOSIVE POPULARITY FLAVORED
NICOTINE PRODUCTS AND THE ROLE
THAT THEY PLAY IN A NEW YOU. 8%
80% OF YOUTH WHO USE TOBACCO IN
ANY FORM SAY THEY STARTED WITH
A FLAVORED PRODUCT. WHAT DREW
THEM AND CONTINUE TO HOLD THEM
WELL THE OVERALL OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF TEENS THAT USED
TOBACCO REPORT THAT ITS FRUIT
MENTHOL AND MINT FLAVOR. BIG
TOBACCO SAYS FLAVORS LIKE
HAWAIIAN PUNCH CATER TO ADULT
CASES BUT THE DATA SHOWS THE
FLAVOR TOBACCO USE IS STAND
AMONG YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULT.
MENTAL RICH TO GUARD IN THE-
ANOTHER FLAVOR TO PRODUCTS THE
HARSHNESS OF TOBACCO IN HOPE
USERS INTO A LIFE THREATENING
ADDICTION. FOR I GO FURTHER I
WANT TO EXPLAIN WHY I'M
PRESSING FORWARD WITH THIS BE
SEVEN NINETY THREE GIVEN
EVERYTHING WE FACE DUE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I
KNOW WE'VE ALL HAD TO WOULD
REASSESS OUR PRIORITIES
EMERGING EVIDENCE ABOUT SMOKING
AND CORPORATE NINETEEN SHOT THE
STOCKING CAN PUT PEOPLE AT
GREATER RISK THE WORLD ORGAN
DIVISION THIS. THE P. H. WORN
TOBACCO USE CAN IN THE RISK OF
SUFFERING THE MOST SEVERE
SYMPTOMS OF COVERT NINETEEN. WE
KNOW CONCLUSIVELY THAT SMOKING
INCREASES RISK OF RESPIRATORY
INFECTION. WEAKENS THE IMMUNE
SYSTEM AND IS A MAJOR
UNDERLYING CALL OF LUNG DISEASE
HEART DISEASE AND DIE. THIS
PANDEMIC COMPELS US TO URGE
SMOKERS TO QUIT AND ESTABLISH
POLICIES THAT INSURE NEVER PICK
UP THE HABIT. IN THE FIRST
PLACE. BECAUSE OF THE-
INDUSTRIES TACTICS LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY THE TEAM IS AN
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED. BY
THE RELATED ENTITY AND DEATH.
OPPONENTS OF SB NINETY CLICK
MENTHOL THE- CIGARS ARE NOT
HURTING OR YOU. WE KNOW THAT IS
NOT TRUE AND SO DOES BIG
TOBACCO WANTED PRAISE OUR KIDS
WITH MENTHOL AND FLAVORED
CIGARS. IT WOULD BE A FAILURE
ON OUR PART WE COWER TO BIG
TOBACCO WILL GUARD TO THESE
DANGEROUS PRODUCT. MEANT THE
ORIGINAL CANDY FLAVOR IS
DRIVING TOBACCO CAUSED DEATHS
IN DISEASE'S NATIONWIDE. THE
COOL REFRESHING TASTE OF MEN
ALL TOUTED BY BIG TOBACCO
MARKETING MARKETING MAKES IT
EASIER TO SMOKE AND GET
ADDICTED. YOUTH SMOKERS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO USE MENTHOL
CIGARETTES THAN ANY OTHER AGE
GROUP 57% OF HIGH SCHOOL
SMOKERS USE MENTHOL CIGARETTES
COMPARED TO LESS THAN ONE THIRD
OF. HIS AGES EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
AND OLDER. BECAUSE THE
PREDATORY MARKETING TO THE
BLACK COMMUNITY 85% OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN ADULTS AND 94% 94% OF
LACKEY. WHO SMOKE USE MENTAL
PRODUCTS. FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
AFRICAN AMERICANS DIE FROM A
SMOKING CAUSED ILLNESS EACH
YEAR. AND IT MADE A ONE POINT
SIX MILLION AFRICAN AMERICANS
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. WILL
BECOME REGULAR SMOKERS AND
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WILL DIE PREMATURELY A TO BACK
REALLY THE- THAT MEANT
CIGARETTES ARE ALL CHEAPER IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS CLEAR
EVIDENCE. OF BIG TOBACCO'S
HEARTLESS IN THIS. CIGARS ARE
THE SECOND MOST POPULAR TOBACCO
PRODUCT AMONG YOUTH SMOKERS.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
YOUTH CIGAR SMOKERS 72% REPORT
USING A FLAVORED PRODUCT. SMALL
PACK SIZES PRICES AS LOW AS
NINETY NINE CENTS AND FLAVORS
LIKE BANANAS MASHED TROPICAL
ICE AND BOOZY WATERMELON MAKE
CIGARS PARTICULARLY ATTRACTIVE
TO KIDS. IN THEIR OWN LOBBYING
MATERIALS PREMIUM CIGAR
MANUFACTURERS STATE THAT THEIR
PRODUCTS DO NOT CONTAIN
FLAVORINGS OR OTHER ADDITIVES
THAT ARE FOUND IN OTHER TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. IF THAT IS THE CASE
PREMIUM CIGARS NOT BANNED BY SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE. THE BILL
BANS CHARACTERIZING FOR VERSION
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. BUT ONLY
THOSE THAT RESULT FROM THE
ADDITION OF AN AGREED
INGREDIENTS OTHER THAN TOBACCO.
ANOTHER ARGUMENT OPPONENTS OF
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE ARE
MAKING IS THAT FLAVOR TOBACCO
BANDS THAT INCLUDE MENTHOL
CIGARETTES WILL ANALYZE TOBACCO
POSSESSION AND GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AN EXCUSE TO HARASS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
COLLEAGUES THIS IS SIMPLY NOT
TRUE. IF IT WERE MY NAME WOULD
NOT BE ON THIS BILL. SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE DOES NOT PENALIZE
POSSESSION OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS
AND DOES NOT CREATE ANY
CRIMINAL PENALTIES WHAT SO EVER.
I WAS PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
HISTORIC TOBACCO REFORMS WE
ENACTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH
REMOVE PENALTIES. FOR
POSSESSION AND MADE OUR TOBACCO
CONTROL LAWS MORE EQUITABLE. IN
REALITY THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
KNOWING THIS IS A WEDGE ISSUE
HAS URGED ME TO GET TOUGH ON
KIDS WHO USED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
BY REESTABLISHING WRECK CONEY
PENALTIES. I'VE DRAWN A CLEAR
LINE IN. IN FORCE SHOULD BE ON
THE TO BACK. NOT THEIR VICTIMS
OPPONENTS ARE ALSO USING THAT
AT BEST INFLATED AND AT WORST
MADE UP ECONOMIC ESTIMATES TO
UNDERMINE SB SEVEN NINE THREE.
THE TOBACCO IS PUT A PRICE ON
OUR KIDS LIVES BUT I REFUSE TO
DO SO. SB SEVEN NINETY THREE A
PUBLIC HEALTH VICTORY FOR
CALIFORNIA WE WILL PROTECT
GROUP WE WILL PROTECT. AGAINST
ANOTHER GENERATION GETTING
ADDICTED TO THESE DEADLY
PRODUCT WHICH IS PRICELESS ARE
HARD FACTS. ABOUT BIG TOBACCO'S
IMPACT ON OUR ECONOMY AND ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE ANNUAL CARE
COSTS CAUSED BY SMOKING IN
CALIFORNIA. IS THIRTY. I'M
SORRY. NO UP HERE THE HARD
FACTS ABOUT BIG TOBACCO'S
IMPACT ON OUR ECONOMY AND ON
PUBLIC HEALTH THE ANNUAL HEALTH
CARE COSTS CAUSED BY SMOKING IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE IS THIRTY NINE
POINT TWO NINE BILL DOLLAR.
MEDI COSTS DUE TO SMOKING
AMOUNT TO THREE POINT FIVE
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
LOST PRODUCTIVITY DUE TO
SMOKING COST TEN POINT THREE
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND
HERE'S THE HUMAN TOLL CALL.
OVER 25% OF CANCER DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ATTRIBUTABLE TO
SMOKING. FORTY THOUSAND ADULTS
DIE EACH YEAR FROM THEIR OWN
SMOKING IN OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND KIDS NOW
UNDER EIGHTEEN. WILL DIE
PREMATURELY FROM SMOKING. AND
WHAT SCARES BIG TOBACCO THE
MOST ABOUT SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THE ACT THAT RESTRICTING
THE SALE OF MENTHOL AND CANDY
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS IS AN
EFFECTIVE MEANS TO REVIEWS FROM
OAK IN AND PROMOTE. SENSATION
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE TAKE
SWIFT ACTION TO PUT YOUTH AND
POPULATIONS BY PROHIBITING THE
RETAIL SALE OF FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
HAS A TARGET OUR AUDIENCE OVER
90% OF SMOKERS 90% OF SMOKERS
COLLEAGUES START BEFORE THE AGE
OF A TEAM. AND THE AVERAGE AGE
A NEW SMOKER. IS THIRTEEN.
ENTICING FLAVORS ENTICING
FLAVORS COLORFUL PACKAGING AND
NAMES AND LOGOS SIMILAR TO
POPULAR TYPES OF CANDY HAVE
BEEN USED SINCE I WAS A CHILD
TO GET GET KIDS HOOKED BIG
TOBACCO WEAPONIZED DECADES OF
TREACHERY TO LURE A NEW
GENERATION TO NICOTINE
ADDICTION IT IS TIME WE BREAK
THAT CYCLE. MEMBERS I KNOW IT
IS EASY TO SAY THIS IS ABOUT
BABY SO LET'S TACKLE PEIPING
ONLY. OVER EIGHTY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE PASSED
FLAVOR BANDS THAT GO BEYOND BAY
BEING. AN EVERYDAY MORE CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE TAKING ON THE
FIGHT AGAINST BIG TOBACCO.
PASSING THE STATE BILL THAT IS
BEEPING ONLY ORDER MAKES
DANGEROUS EXEMPTIONS ACTUALLY
DOES LESS TO PROTECT KIDS THAN
THE STATUS QUO. DOING SO
UNDERMINES THE HARD WORK OF OURCITIES AND COUNTIES EMPOWERS
BIG TOBACCO TO UNDO STRONGER
LOCAL PROTECTIONS CITING THE
STATE'S ACTIONS. PUT
DIFFERENTLY PASSING A BABY AN
ONLY BILL. A PROTECT SOME KIDS
IN THE SUBURBS BUT IS IT DOES
NOTHING TO PROTECT KIDS IN THE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
THAT BIG TOBACCO HAS TARGETING
FOR GENERATIONS. I SIMPLY WILL
NOT SELL OUT ARE YOU. CALLING
TO HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR. ONE
DOCTOR PHILIP GARDNER CO CHAIR
OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN TOBACCO
CONTROL NETWORK. IN THE SECOND
WITNESS THE REVEREND JOHN CAGER
THE THIRD PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNCIL OF RELIGIOUS
LEADERS PASTOR OF WARD AFRICAN
METHODIST EPISCOPAL CHURCH IN
LOS ANGELES. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR HILL-
ACOSTA MODERATOR TO- HOPEFULLY
FIND OUT THERE IN THE QUEUE DR
PHILIP GARDNER AND THE REVEREND
JOHN CAGER. YOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M HERE GREAT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES TOTAL WILL HAVE A TO
WITNESSES FOR WILL HAVE A TOTAL
OF SIX MINUTES WITNESSES OPPOSE
WILL HAVE A TOTAL SIX MINUTES
AND WILL BE HOLDING TO THAT
VERY STRICTLY. SO PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
REVEREND. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I MY NAME IS RIVER
JOHNNY K. TO THE THIRD I'M THE
SENIOR PASTOR AT. WARD AFRICAN
METHODIST EPISCOPAL CHURCH.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING THE TIME
TO SPEAK TODAY ON THE SUPPORT
BILL THAT WILL SAVE LIVES.
SENATOR HILL ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF NEED FOR SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE. LET ME ASSURE YOU WISH
YOU WHAT I SEE IN THE COMMUNITY
AND WHY WE NEED TO BAN THE SALE
OF ALL FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. LOW BACKGROUND ON ME
I BEGAN MY CAREER IN MINISTRY
AT FIRST DAY IN THE CHURCH AND
LOS ANGELES WEST DIRECTOR OF
THE YOUTH MINISTRY. I FELT MANY
LEADERSHIP ROLES OF THE CHURCH
OF THE COMMUNITY. AND AS THE
PERSONAL LOS ANGELES COUNCIL OF
RELIGIOUS LEADERS I AM VERY
CONVINCED THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE ISSUE. OF AND WILL BEING.
I OWN FAMILY HISTORY- MY DAD
GREW UP PICKING TOBACCO IN
VIRGINIA AND WHAT HE TOLD ME
ABOUT. BACK THAT TOBACCO IS
VERY SLOW AND SPEAK. BOB
EVERYTHING THAT IT TOUCHES.
THAT'S THE SAME THING WITH THIS
DEBATE. TOBACCO FILES
EVERYTHING IT TOUCHES INCLUDING
THE ARGUMENTS THAT WE DEAL
WITH- ON THIS ISSUE SOME WILL
SAY THAT- BANNING MYTHOLOGY
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUE WOULD NOT
BRING UP THE ERIC GARNER
SITUATION. I CAN'T SAY THAT
THERE WILL BE A SITUATION WHERE
PERHAPS ONE PERSON HAS A
NEGATIVE ENCOUNTER WITH POLICE
OVER A MYTH OUT THERE BUT I CAN
SEE THAT HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WILL DIE. BEEN
GOING. ON CANCER HUNDREDS OF
BLACK CALIFORNIANS WILL DIE.
SOME WILL SAY THAT IT'S A
BUDGETARY ISSUE PEOPLE JUST GOT
AIRS ON OUR TO GAMING
RESERVATIONS TO GET- MITTAL
CIGARETTES AND THE STATE WILL
LOSE OUT ON REVENUE. I'M SORRY
I DON'T WANT THE STATE TO
COLLECT BLOOD MONEY ON THE
BACKS OF DEAD AFRICAN
AMERICANS. ARE REJECT THAT
OFFER THAT THAT THAT ARGUMENT.
UP TO THAT THE CHOICE IS. THEY
SHOULD LET BLACK PEOPLE CHOOSE
TO SMOKE- METHYLATED CIGARETTES
IF THEY WANT I WOULD JUST SAY.
OPIOIDS ARE CHOICE ISSUE AS
WELL BUT I WOULD BE THROWN OUT
OF YOUR CHAMBER IF I SUGGESTED
THAT WE ALLOW WHITE PEOPLE TO
USE OPIOIDS BECAUSE THAT SEEMS
TO BE THEIR DRUG OF CHOICE.
THAT COMPLETELY RACIST TO SAY
THE BLACK PEOPLE LACK THE SELF
DISCIPLINE TO AVOID SMOKING-
METHYLATED PRODUCTS. IF THEY
HAVE TO GO ON THE BLACK MARKET
MY DENOMINATION AMY CHURCH SIX
THOUSAND CHURCHES THREE MILLION
MEMBERS WELL WORLDWIDE
INCLUDING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED AN INTERNATIONAL BAN
ON MEANT DAHLE FLAVOR TOBACCO I
URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO DO AS
WELL. THANK YOU DO THE RIGHT
THING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REVEREND. THE NEXT WITNESS
DOCTOR PHILIP GARDNER IF YOU'RE
OUT THERE. YEAH HELLO PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIR. YEAH THE- ALL WANT
MONEY MISSION I PULL OUT I'M
CALLING FROM IS A BIT I MEAN
I'M SORRY YOU WERE LOOKING FOR-
PHILIP GARDNER WERE NOT I'M
SORRY YOUR YOU'RE NOT IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS POINT. THERE ONE
SORRY. ARE YOU IN THE OKAY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW DO WE GET
HIS. HOW DO WE GET HIM. TURN ON.
WHO WAS ALWAYS IN CONTENTION.
HAVE DOCTOR GARDNER SURE THE
LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND I DON'T SEE
DOCTOR GARDNER QUEUING UP. IS
THERE ANY IS DOCTOR GARDNER IN
ANY OF THE OTHER WITNESS ROOMS.
OR JUST ON THE PHONE. AFTER
GARDENERS NOT IN THE CHAMBER.
WE JUST ANOTHER MINUTE. ANOTHER
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE SO
THIS IS A CHALLENGE SAID DR
PHIL GARDNER IF THERE'S A WAY
TO THERE'S A WAY FOR THE
MODERATOR TO FIND IDENTIFIED DR
PHIL GARDNER WE- LOVE TO HEAR
THAT. ONCE AGAIN DOCTOR GARDNER
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE
THEM ON THE LINE. OKAY DR PHIL
GARDNER IF YOU'RE STILL OUT
THERE AT SOME POINT PLEASE KEEP
TRYING AT THIS POINT WE WILL
ACTUALLY GO TO OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT WILL JUST YOUR NAME.
AND ORGANIZATION ONLY SO-
MATTER MODERATOR YOU CAN OPEN
THE LINE FOR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION
ONLY AND IF DOCTOR PHILIP
GARDNER IS ABLE. FIND WAY BACK
ON WE WILL GLADLY- STOP- THAT
TESTIMONY AND ALLOW DR PHIL
GARNER TO SPEAK SO PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH. THIS IS IT SUPPORT
NAME AND ORGANIZATIONAL. ON
ANOTHER REMIND TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS AT THE SB SEVEN
NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
WATCH THIS TIME. TO GO TO SO
WHAT. A LITTLE BIT. THREE ND A
CROWD CALL FROM TOP FORTY MAIN
SHOW INTO OF AT SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY THIS IS BREANNA PAYMENT
CENTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WITHOUT
ANY EXEMPTIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FOUR FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JENNER THE MAKE UP ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
HABIA BUT THAT SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. BETWEEN PORT. OKAY
SO I'LL TAKE MY FOOT OFF THE
QUEUE THANK YOU. ONE THREE
FIFTY NINE LINE OPEN. WELL CHEN
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TREND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNICHEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE FOR TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE COLD WAR LIMóN ON BEHALF
OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY IN
COURT THANK YOU. LINE THREE
FIFTY SIX THEIR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MATT
ROBINSON WITH KAISER PERMANENTE
AND SHOCK SUPPORT WITH THE BILL
AS THIS WITHOUT FURTHER
EXEMPTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE FIVE ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS MARTIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
FIVE ELEVEN YOUR LIGHT IS OPEN.
IN MADDEN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
IN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
THE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS KATHY MCDONALD'S FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE TO TREAT
THEM WITH THE COURT SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE BUT WOULD WITHDRAW
SUPPORT AMENDED TO UPDATING
ONLY BILL THANK YOU JUST YOUR
NAME AND POSITION ON THE OF. AS
IT'S WRITTEN THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR NINETY FOUR AIRLINE AND AN-
GOOD AFTERNOON TO CHAIR MEMBERS
CON EL GATO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. EVERY YEAR AMERICA WITH
THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TWO ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO ZERO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO ENGAGE
VI<c.cyan> HERE ON BEHALF OF YEAH</c>
YOU CALIFORNIA AND ARE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT AN APOLOGY FOR
THE LAKE. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER SIX SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ERICA HOPPING ON
THE AT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION INTO COURT
THANK YOU. NEXT TO ONLY OPEN MY
NUMBER SIXTY YEAR LINE IS SIX
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
BREAKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT FOR THE COURT THANK
YOU. LINE FIVE EIGHT FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU DON'T
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN PORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI ELIZABETH MILTON
ALAMEDA COUNTY TOBACCO CONTROL
COALITION MEMBER AND MOTHER IN
SUPPORT SEVEN NINETY THREE IT'S
NOT AMENDED. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SEVEN NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS TRICIA
BAR I AM A MEMBER OF THE PARENT
TEACHER ASSOCIATION THE PTA I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
SEVEN NINETY THREE I HAVE THE
NAMES OF OTHERS WHO WOULD TRY
TO GET ON AND- WERE ABLE TO.
THEIR NAME AND- YES OF THE
ALLOW THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GREAT MAR SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION TRUSTEE JOHN
LAMBERT FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER ANDREA LUSKIN SCHOOL
SITE COUNCIL ONE OVER MOLLY
PEDIATRICIAN JUDITH ALL
CALAVERAS PARENTS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE FOR
SEVENTEEN LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YOUR MIND IS OPEN. YEAH BUT I
WOULD NOT ON THE ONE TO BE
SUPPORTING I'M ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE WITHOUT BURNING
DIDN'T GET NUMBER FOUR
SEVENTEEN. HOW DO I GET ME BACK
CONNECTED. FIX THE MESS WHEN WE
DO OPPOSITION YOU CAN SEE WHAT
BY PRESSING ONE ZERO. OKAY
THANK. MEXICO TO LINE ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT LIKE
YOUNG AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION PHONE SUPPORT
WITHOUT EXEMPTION THANK YOU.
LINE THREE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DIANA DOUGLAS WITH
HEALTH ACT THE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE TO SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHORT ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POLITICS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
IN A RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE
NUMBER SIX FIFTY SIX THEIR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO. HELLO HELLO YES
ARE YOU SPEAKING AND WALDRON.
I'M ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MAT WELL YOU CAN PRESS ONE
ZERO AND YOU'LL BE PLACED BACK
IN THE QUEUE AND THEN YOU WHEN
WE CALL PROPOSITION YOU'LL BE
ALLOWED TO I CAN HEAR. LINE
THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE
FIVE THIRTY SIX THEIR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I. I'M LOOKING YOU'RE
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND PART OF THE
STANFORD TOBACCO TO OKAY YOU BY
PEOPLE AREN'T IN TRANSPORT.
THANK YOU. AND WE'VE LOCATED
DOCTOR GARDNER MAIL PREMIER
PRETTY BY OPENING IT LINE. THE.
YOUR MIND ON YOUR EYES OPEN.
IT'S NOT ALLOWING ME TO OPEN WE
CAN AREA. UNDER GARTNER WE CAN
HEAR YOU HELLO. I CAN'T HEAR
YOU. YOU CANNOT HEAR US WE CAN
HEAR YOU. YOU CAN HEAR ME NOW
WE SURE CAN. OKAY I'M VERY
SORRY WHATEVER THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DOCTOR PHILIP GARDNER YOU
CO CHAIR OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN TOBACCO CONTROL
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. WRONGLY
ENCOURAGES- SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINE THREE LET'S BE QUITE CLEAR
IN THE BEGINNING. PAUL
CIGARETTES UNFLAVORED LITTLE
CIGARS HAVE BEEN AND ARE THE
MAIN FACTORS OF DEATH AND
DISEASE IN THE BLACK BROWN
ANOTHER POOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. CALL NINETEEN PANDEMIC
IS JUST UNDER SCORE THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN AN EQUAL
TREATMENT BY POOR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS
IN THE UNITED STATES. AT THE
TIME NOTHING COULD BE MORE
HELPFUL IN SAVING BLACK LIVES
IN ENSURING THAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER THE GETTING MENTAL OPEN
LAYERS OUT OF CALIFORNIA. SOME
BLACK GROUPS BIRD ON BY THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY HAVE BEEN
SPREADING FALSE IS STATING THAT
PROHIBITING THE SALE. OF MEN
FALLEN FLAVOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS
INCLUDING PLAGUE OF THE JEWS
WILL LEAD TO THE
CRIMINALIZATION PARTICULARLY OF
YOUNG BLACK MEN. NOTHING COULD
BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH SB
SEVEN NINE THREE WOULD PROHIBIT
THE SALE OF FLAVORED PRODUCTS
THE BILL WOULD NOT PROHIBIT THE
POSSESSION OF THESE PRODUCTS.
THE FIRST GROUP RAIL ABOUT THE
UNINTENDED. I WANT THE
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
AND THE CONSEQUENCES. BUT BOOK
BY JUST. FROM TOBACCO RELATED
DISEASE THE PARK. WELL. STROKE
ANOTHER REYES AND THAT GROUP.
THE OTHER RACIAL AND AT GROUPS
TEMPLE CIGARETTE AND PLAY FOR
LITTLE WITH A OF STRAW. STILL
OTHER GROUPS ON THE BY THE BACK
INDUSTRY YOU ARGUED EVERY MOVIE
MENTHOL CIGARETTE SOMEPLACE
LITTLE SEVERITY TAKE AWAY QUOTE
UNQUOTE OUR CIGARETTES WE BE
DISCRIMINATORY THIS LINE OF
ARGUMENTATION STANCE HISTORY ON
ITS HEAD AND IT WAS IN THE
BACK- INDUSTRY THAT PREDATORY
REALLY MARKET THESE PRODUCTS TO
THE BLACK COMMUNITY THE FACTS
ARE THESE. THERE ARE MORE
ADVERTISEMENTS MORE LUCRATIVE
PROMOTION AND MENTHOL
CIGARETTES ARE CHEAPER IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY COMPARED TO
OTHER COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE
LOADS OF DATA ON THIS BUSINESS
HOW FLAVOR DEATH STICKS BECAME
OUR CIGARETTES. JUNE FIRST
MASSACHUSETTS BECAME THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION FORGET THE
FLOW OF ALL PLAY WITH THE BACK
OF PRODUCTS THERE ARE READY
SIXTY THREE THE LETTER. ROSS
NATION. MARK LEAVE AT THE
COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA'S READ THE-IN THE OF THOUGHTS NOT THE
INTEREST IN THE PROPERTY TO THE
BACK TO INSTRUCT THIS IS NOT
THE TIME PERHAPS STEPS RATHER
AT THE TIME TO TAKE A STAND FOR
THE PUBLIC FELT AND DECLARE
THAT IN THE MIDST SO CALLED
WITH MY TEEN PANDEMIC THERE NO
BETTER WAY TO PLAY BLACK WIVES
MAY ALL CALIFORNIANS. DIDN'T.
THE MAIN. THEIR TO THE AND
CORONAVIRUS OUT OF CALIFORNIA
PLEASE PASS. SEVEN BY THREE
WITH KNOWING THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR GARDNER IN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PERSEVERANCE AND IN GETTING
THROUGH AND BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY. MUCH
APPRECIATED. A MODERATE MADAM
MADAM MODERATOR YOU MAY GO BACK
TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT WE'RE JUST
LOOKING FOR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION ONLY SO- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GIVE HER THANK YOU BACK
TO OPEN MY NUMBER FOUR THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAIR
NUMBERS CAPPING OFF BURKE
REPRESENTING BOTH THE FIRST
PRIVATIZATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
BOTH IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINE THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS HE DID
GET IN BLOOD AND I AM A JUNIOR
IN THE BALLOT IN COLLEGE PREP
HIGH SCHOOL AND- I'M ALSO AN
AMBASSADOR FOR THE CAMPAIGN FOR
TOBACCO FREE KIDS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT BETTING ON
PLAYERS FROM. ALL TOBACCO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FIND FIVE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS LISA LU THAT'S AND
WEBER INTERNATIONAL THE BACK OF
CONTROL AND CAMPAIGN FOR
TOBACCO FREE KIDS STRONGLY AT
THE NOT BE ADDED. I'M SURE.
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN
MEYER AND I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
DANVILLE AND I'M IN THE
ELEVENTH GRADE I SUPPORT
BANNING ALL FLAVORS FROM ALL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY TWENTY EIGHT
AIRLINE IS OPEN. YEAH HELLO
THIS IS THE FAB WAY TO WITH THE
LOOK AT CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. ONE
SIX ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU YOUR MESSAGE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU. LINE SIX FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI LARRY
HALL CHAIR OF THE NICOTINE
ACTION ALLIANCE YOU COUNTY NOT
THE CAN YEAH RICH CORNY DIFFER
IN THE MEDICAL CENTER BOTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT THE
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND IT IS AND
GIVES WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
TOBACCO FREE KIDS PRO COAST
BONTA WITH NO EXEMPTIONS AND
MISTER TRICKERY FOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COULD GET
ON. ADDITIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
AND SUPPORT YES. YES PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE FOR FONTANA STUDENTS.
WELLNESS AND PREVENTION CENTER
AND NOT PROMISED RESEARCH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER REPRESENTED
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEDIATRICIANS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS IT IS WITHOUT A MAN
EXEMPTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU AND WE LISTS
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
VOLUNTEER ON BEHALF OF MONTEREY
COUNTY COLLABORATE. URGING
SUPPORT STRONGSUPPORTER OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE AS PRESENTED
BY SENATOR HILL THANK YOU YOU.
ONE ONE ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHELSEA I'M PART OF THE
STUDENT LED NONPROFIT
INTERNATIONAL. USED TOBACCO
CONTROL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT THE SEVEN NINETY I WITH WITH
EXEMPTION THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHANE SOBRE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN NINE THREE. ONE
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON FRANKLIN
CHANG SENIOR LOOK HIGH SCHOOL
IN PART OF THE STUDENT
NONPROFITINTERNATIONAL YOUTH
DIRECTLY CONTROLLED WE PUT THE
PUT IT SB OF NINETY THREE
WITHOUT EXCEPTION. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JILL
WELL I AM A PARENT AND BY TECH
PROFESSIONALS FROM THE NUMBER
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS DâN HUTCHINGS
REPRESENTING THE CITIES OF
BELMONT AND REDWOOD CITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE. NAME
PRESS THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LIKE MY FOR TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LAURIE
BRUNNER THE PARENTS AGAINST A.
B. CALIFORNIA AND I TO BE
STRONG FOR. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIFTY
NINE IN THE BED NOW. INDEED
SAID NO I AM A PARENT OF TWO
TEENS IN CALIFORNIA I ALSO
SUPPORT- LATER ADDICT CAN'T
FROM LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA AND I
AM AND STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVEN
NINE THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE BIRD
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. LINE SIX THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS LEGAL
TO LUKE- ON GAP IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND BERKELEY SAN LEANDRO
HELLO OUT THOUGH ON PABLO
STRONG SUPPORT AS A BILL
CURRENTLY WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IMMEDIATELY
APPARENT WHAT THE ANTI VAPING
ALLIANCE WARRANT STRONG
SUPPORTER SB SEVEN NINE THREE
THANK YOU. LINE FIVE ZERO TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AARON
TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF ALAMEDA AND SAN MATTEO.
THANK YOU. LINE FOR SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MY NAME WITH EACH
BERMAN I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND I'M IN TENTH
GRADE I THINK FOR BANG ALL
FLAVORS FROM ALL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE SIX FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE SHOULD CARE MEMBERS
PRICE DOUGHERTY WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE SIX TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
EMERGENCY I WOULD LOVE TO DO IT
IN A DAY AND I SUPPORT GETTING
ALL FLAVORS FROM ALL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER FOUR FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THEY REMOVE
THEMSELVES FROM QUEUE LINE FOR
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RAJ DILLON
REPRESENTING ME THAT LATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SD SEVEN
NINETY THREE WITHOUT FURTHER
EXEMPTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ROBIN GLENN
AND I WORKED IN HEALTH
MANAGEMENT IN LINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LINDA
EVANS AND I'D GLADLY AND THREE
LITTLE CHILDREN I LIVE IN THE
CITY OF EL CAJON AND I SUPPORT
BANNING ALL FLAVORS FROM
TOBACCO PRODUCTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
ONE FIVE FIVE YEAR LINE IT'LL
BUT- GOOD EVENING MY APOLOGIES
FOR PREVIOUSLY SPEAKING ON THE
INCORRECT Q. DISABILITY
ANYTHING REPRESENTING CAN CALL
PROJECT MINISTRIES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SIX SIX ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT NO RESPONSE-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS LINDA
SHARE FROM IMPERIAL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT BANNING ALL
PAPERS FROM ALL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS REMA
CORY THIS IS A GOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINE THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR TWO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MEREDITH BURKE MAN I REPRESENT
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF
PARENTS AGAIN FACING CIGARETTE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT. NINETY THREE THAT IS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I BELIEVE
THAT ARE MONTHLY MANGA OF THE
PRESIDENT I'M A BIT END OF DUTY
I AM VERY TRUMP THE FOR THE.
FIFTY SEVEN NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
FOUR SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS BECKY RAP
AND THE MOTHER AND YOUTH GROUP
MENTOR AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS BRIAN DAVIS RESIDENT
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN STRONG
SUPPORT WITHOUT EXEMPTIONS
THANK YOU. MY NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS CAN CALL BACK
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINE THREE. THANK YOU.
FIND FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KAREN DATE PARENT AND MEMBER OF
THE ANTI BEEPING ALLIANCE I
GIVE MY FULL SUPPORT SB SVEN
NINE THREE AS IS WITHOUT
EXEMPTION. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH MY NAME'S CATHY FLIRTY I'M
A PARENT OF THREE YOUR
GRANDPARENTS OF STICKS AND I
LIVE IN THE CITY OF ATWATER AND
I SUPPORT BANNING ALL FLAVORS
FROM ALL TOBACCO PRODUCTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE SIX TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICK WRONGLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LINES OF YMCA THE
CALIFORNIA LINE OF BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUBS SAN BERNADINO
COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION ALL
THE SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMANDA
TRUMBULL RESIDENT OF LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN STRONG
CORE AND SB THIRTY NINETY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FIVE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WITH NO RESPONSIBLE BONTA MY
NUMBER FIVE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SAM HAD AN
WITH A WHO COULD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS ADAM RECORD I'M A JUNIOR
DIRTY VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT BILL SEVEN
NINETY THREE AS IS WITH NO
CONNECTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS PAUL REVIEW
AND I'M WITH THE HOOK A CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE I SUPPORT AT THE
SEVEN NINE THREE PLEASE
PLACERVILLE AND PRODUCTIVE GOT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
BUT CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMONG
THEM TO GET THE FULL MEMBER OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
COMMUNITY PENSION AND
POPULATION HEALTH TASK FORCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE FOR
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS RIDGECREST LAZARUS WITH
ALAMEDA COUNTY TOBACCO CONTROL
COALITION AND PARENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS IS WITH NO
EXEMPTION. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS IRENE SEVEN THE BIG HIP
HOP OF ALL THIS ON THE
POLITICAL PPA COUNCIL AS WELL
AS A CLINICAL PHARMACIST I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH
NO EXCEPTIONS. THANK YOU. LINE
SIX TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS CHRISTIE WONG CO
FOUNDER OF FLAVORS A DAY KIDS
LIVERMORE AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
WITHOUT WE EXEMPTION. THANK YOU.
ONE THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AT THREE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LOOK. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS RANI I'M WITH THE WITH
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND I'M
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS TWENTY ONE I LIVE IN IRVINE
AND I PUT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK. ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M JANE WILL
AND THE PAIR WITH SPRING VALLEY
PTA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SEVEN EIGHT THREE AT THAT.
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JON
THAT DOOR LOOK AT CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU. FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I'M CAN I'M INDEED-
AFFECTIONATE BASES IN THE
PENCIL CON BALLY AND I SUPPORT
SB SEVEN NINETY AS IS WITHOUT
EXCEPTIONS THANK YOU. LINE FOR
SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS IRWIN MORGAN
REPRESENTING THE PALO ALTO
COUNCIL OF PARENT TEACHER
ASSOCIATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE SEVEN NINETY THREE AS
HE IS WITH NO FURTHER
EXEMPTIONS. THANK YOU THE
CHECKOUT LANES OF ARE YOU COULD
NOT GET ON YES OF COURSE THANK
YOU HELLO. YES YOU MAY THANK
YOU OKAY J. J. TRIAL FROM HELLO
OF THE COUNCIL OF P. T. A.'S IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WHEN HI. AND
MONIQUE MARCIN ALL THREE OF
THEM ARE HELLO TO BE BONE ALL
THREE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FIVE FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT IN A RESPONSIBLE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER SIX TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
GAPS IN PAUL YOUR ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO A STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURE OKAY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
TOBACCO FREE COALITION SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WE SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE AS IS.
WITHOUT EXCEPTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
HEALTHY CHAMBERS AND I AM A
SENIOR AT COLLEGE AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AS BEING
SEVEN NINETY THREE. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE ZERO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PROVIDED ME DID
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. MOVING
ON TO MY NUMBER EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE AT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE AFFECTS YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOCELYN AND WORDS I AM
A PARENT AND A MAPUCHE
COORDINATOR AT THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN FAMILY CULTURAL CENTER
AND I SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE
THREE. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
THERE AFFECTS YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS GO TO ONE ELEVEN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND I
THINK RIGHT STANDING OFF
WAIVERS ALL TOBACCO PRODUCTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE SIX
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR KERRY MEMBERS
FORMER UP HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE FOR
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JANET THE BREMEN
RESIDENT OFFENDING CLERK ON THE
AT THE FOR THE BILL AS IT IS
ABOUT CAPTION. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT. NINE THREE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RARE IS THE BILL LEFT
MUCH NEEDED PROBATION IF THE
COURT. THANK YOU FOR. THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MONDAY HE WILL GO OVER CHAIR I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES THEY'RE NOT
WITH THE BOARD AS IN SEVEN NINE
THREE. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BACK CATALINA CANCER THE CORBIN
AND KAISER ON BEHALF OF
COMMONSENSE COOK BUNKER TO
SUPPORT THE VERSION BEFORE YOU
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY TWO TWO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE SIX THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN IT. THE
MUST RESIST AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SALAS WHAT KIND
OF OUR ROBIN TOURETTE KERN LOS
ANGELES. RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
WRITTEN WITHOUT EXCEPTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO
TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS VICTOR AND I'M
A SIXTH GRADER HUNTINGTON
MIDDLE SCHOOL PART OF THE STATE
AND LET NONPROFIT NATIONAL
YOUTH THE BACK BECAUSE- I POOR
SB SEVEN NINE THREE AS IS WITH
NO EXEMPTION TO MENTAL
CIGARETTES AND FLAVORED CIGAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS DOCTOR MONEY HOPING
SO SURE I'M A PROFESSOR OF
PEDIATRICS AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY AND I'M ALSO THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE TOBACCO PREVENTION TALK
IT I'M IN STRONG FAVOR SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
WITHOUT EXCEPTIONS MAY I PLEASE
READ THE NAMES OF A FEW OF THE
YOUTH GROUP WHO CANNOT JOIN.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE WHO ARE
USE UNDER AGE TWENTY ONE
ALLIANCE MISERS NADIA ALDRIDGE.
WE SPEAK. AS JESSE GONZALEZ
BRENDA YOU VOTERS NAOMI LOZANO.
THEN LOZANO HER ALL PATEL AND
REVA JOHN WE'RE ALL LOW ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR YOUTH BOARD WHO
ARE IN STRONG FAVOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I BELIEVE
THE CHAMBERS FROM CHICO
CALIFORNIA I'M NOT FRUSTRATED
PARENT. OF A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. LINE THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THERE ARE A COUPLE
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE FOR NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
AMANDA MAY HELP YOUR WATER WITH
A CALIFORNIA LGBTQ HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE THREE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NELSON
LINE AND I'M A JUNIOR AT
MARYLAND HIGH SCHOOL I'M ALSO A
NATIONAL YOUTH AMBASSADOR FOR
THE CAMPAIGN FOR TOBACCO FREE
KIDS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
TO SAY LAST FRIEDMAN WITH
PARENTS AGAIN VACANCY THE
CORRECT- PAID AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
WAS NO EXCEPTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE SIX SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS IAN RIGHT- I AM A FORMER
SMOKER OF FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS AND I AM A STUDENT AT
LOYOLA MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY AND
I AM IN THE VERDANT SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ARMENIANS PERCENT IDEA MY
JUNIOR THE DATE THAT THE
TOBACCO PREVENTION ACTIVE IN
COMMUNITY HEALTH INTERNET BASED
CALIFORNIA THE BAY AREA STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY THREE
WITHOUT EXCEPTIONS. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I AMBER WHERE I AM NOT
PROUD PARENTS GIVE YOU THE FULL
TILT AND I'M NOT COUNTY.
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTY
NINETY THREE. LINE SIXTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RUTH THE
LANKY I LIVING ORANGE COUNTY IN
A JOB YOUR SUPPORT SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE SIX FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE SIX FIVE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GONE WITH
THE UNDERGROUND BE NEGOTIATION
I'M FOR THE STOCK I'M GONNA
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY. LINE ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE ONE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GERRY I
LIVE IN THE CITY AT AN ALL DAY
AND I SUPPORT BANNING ALL
FLAVORS FROM ALL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE FOR SEVENTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. MY POINT
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO BUT WITH NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE TO SEVENTEEN.
NINETY SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WOULD NOT
RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE NUMBER
FOUR FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS MICHELLE
REINHARDT AS A MATTER AND THE
TEACHER I- AND IN THE CITY OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND I SUPPORT
THE ANY CALL. THE PRODUCTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE
COALITION FOR THE BACK REMEMBER
IN ACCOUNTING SUPPORT SB SEVEN
NINE THREE AS IS NO EXCEPTION.
THANK YOU. ON A SEMI. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THANK YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
DOCTOR BOBBY SHOT FROM THE VICE
PRESIDENT WITH THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE INLAND EMPIRE
SMOKE OUR PROJECT WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE WITH NO OPTIONS
AND ALSO THREE OTHER MEMBERS
THAT COULD NOT GET ON. ON THAT
IN STRONG SUPPORTER WELL MISTER
JACKSON PRESIDENT OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BACKING WE'RE
COMMERCE MISS TAMMY CHAPARRAL
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT QUARTER TO
THEIR- SOVIET TO MILLION. I
THREE ARE IN SOME OF SB SEVEN
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY FOR FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I CAN. WE CAN. OKAY I'M
I'M WAITING FOR MY CALIFORNIA
OF COMFORTABLE BUT NOT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
THREE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE ISOPEN. ALL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND STRONG
SUPPORT WITH NO EXCEPTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS RAY WATER THE SECOND
YOUTH MINISTER AT MOUNT SINAI
ASSEMBLY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN NINETY THREE WAS NO
EXCEPTION. THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE. THREE ONE FIVE SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THE
WOMAN WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
AND INLAND EMPIRE IN SUPPORT
WITHOUT EXEMPTION. THANK YOU.
LINE FIVE FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM A WITH ANY LOUDER
RESIDENT OF- PAPER DINA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE
THREE AT THE END BUT NOT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE NINETY
REMINDED OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
ALL THAT THE F. C. W. WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU FOR WALL ON BEHALF OF
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OF BRITAIN
WITHOUT EXEMPTION. THANK YOU.
ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR MIND IS
OPEN. HI. HELLO. ONE ONE. HELLO
YOUR MIND IS AN- HI MY NAME IS
JOHN AND REYES CAN COLLEGE AND
I WHAT I OF MY BREAK. THANK YOU.
ONE TO FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME ASIA
PREDICATE I WORK FOR THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION A CO
SPONSOR OF THE S. EIGHT NINETY
THREE OUR BAY AREA OFFICE I
SUPPORT THE- IF NOT AMEND. STOP
THE SALE OF THAT SO I THINK
BACKUP YOU THINK. LINE THREE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL OF BUT THEY LOOK AT IT BUT
YOU KNOW. LINE THREE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOLDING ON
THE LINE NUMBER THREE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE LEVEL OF
THE- YEAH ARE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS PIERRE MUSCLE. I'M HERE
TO OPPOSE SB. SEVEN NINE THREE.
OKAY THANK YOU. WE'RE LOOKING
FOR SUPPORT LINE ENERGY NINE.
ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MACHINE I
WORK AT PARAMOUNT WE ARE TO THE
STATE THE BIG LEAD AND BACK AT
THE SEVEN NINE THREE WHICH BUT
THAT THAT THE WHOLE CULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA THE FACT THE BILL IN
PROTECT LOOK AT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR ZERO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME POLITICAL YOU
KNOW I AM NOT COMING IN EUROPE
TALK WITH TITLED IN THE OPEN TO
RALLY CAR AND I STRONG SUPPORT
AT SEVEN NINE THREE. THANK YOU.
NINE SIX NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JANIE WORKING WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION WE ARE A
PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND PRINT FOR YOU TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YOUR ONE SIX
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CARLOS LEON WITH
COMMITTEE COALITION REPUBLICAN
BROWN OR ASIAN IN SOUTH CENTRAL
LA. ALSO OF THE BILL WITHOUT A-
THANK YOU. AND FOR TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND RESILIENCE OF
AMERICANS FOR NON SMOKERS RIGHT
WE SUPPORT THE STILL WITHOUT A-
THANK YOU. LINE FOR THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA THANKS FOR
PRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ANYTHING I'M PROUD MEMBER THAN
LOOKING FAMILIES BUT PLAYED
PRACTICAL MYSTERON SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WITHOUT EXEMPTION
THINKING THANK YOU. NINE SIX
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS OFFICERS WILL GO
LOWER AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE THREE I
AM A FRESHMAN WHO GOES THERE
WILL VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE FIVE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
THE ATTACK BY THAT AND I'M
THANK THE HIGH PART OF THE
BLOOD NOT. BATTLE CONTROL I
SUPPORT A SEVEN NINE THREE
ADVANCE KNOWS THE YOU CAN BOTH
THE IN FLAVORED. THANK YOU.
LINE SEVEN TIGHTEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THE NFL
BECAUSE AND I AM A RESIDENT OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND A
MEMBER OF THE COALITION RIGHT
BACK THE LOS ANGELES AS WELL AS
BACK OF THE FAMILY FIGHTING-
LABORED COALITION AND I SUPPORT
SEVEN NINETY THREE AT IS
WITHOUT EXCEPTION THANK YOU.
THANK LINE SEVEN SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
BOB GORDON CO CHAIR OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO TOBACCO FREE
COALITION IN SUPPORT AS THE AS
WITH NO EXCEPTIONS THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS COREY BUT
I'M ALL THAT THE BOARD AT SEVEN
NINETY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE SEVEN
TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WITH NO RESPONSE TO MOVE ON TO
MY NUMBER SIX ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS THE
VIEW AND I'M A SOPHOMORE AT AND
GIVE A HIGH SCHOOL IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER SEVEN TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS MERRY BANNERMAN MEMBER OF
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY TOBACCO
CONTROL COALITION AND I SUPPORT
SB SEVEN NINE THREE ADDED NO
DAMAGE. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE FOR FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSIBLE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER SEVEN FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HELLO- THIS IS DORIAN FOR MEN
ON THE CO FOUNDER OF PAID AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
WITH NO EXEMPTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
KEVIN ROLLINS- THE RESIDENT
APPOINTED BEACH CALIFORNIA AN
EXTRA WE SUPPORT BILL SB SEVEN
NINE THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING CHRIS STARTED OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BLENDER
TITUS WOULD DECEMBER A DINO A
COALITION FOR TAP TOBACCO FREE
SAMBAR ENDINO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SEVEN NINETY THREE
WITH THAT EXEMPTION. THANK YOU.
NINE SIX ZERO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME GET A HALL
AND SEVENTEEN AND I GO TO ORDER
FISCAL SCHOOL OF THE ART I
FULLY SUPPORT THAT SB SEVEN
NINE THREE AT IS WITHOUT
EXCEPTION. THANK YOU. YEAH.
LINE FIVE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE BY OKAY YOUR IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME'S MICHAEL IN AND- I
AM AN ACTRESS MASTER AND ALSO A
PARENT OF TWO BOYS FROM SAN
MATTEO COUNTY AND I FULLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
WITHOUT ANY EXCEPTION. THANK
YOU. LINE SEVEN FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CALPERS AND
ELEVENTH GRADER AT A LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL ADDS IS WITHOUT
EXCEPTION. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVEN THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME A
COUPLE IN A CRISTINA ON MY
PERRIN CONSUMER DINO COMMUNITY
COALITION FOR CHANGE AND
SOMEONE AND YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT BANNING
ALL FAVOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER ROUND WITH
WIDENING GROUP REPRESENTING
CHANGE FOR JUSTICE IS THE PORT.
THANK YOU. MY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSIBLE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CATHERINE AGREED ON A
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS MATT
DO WELL CALLING FROM THE OFFICE
OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF ANY
KIND A LOCKET FALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY FOR FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
MA'AM. AND BELLCORE WITH
PARENTS AGAIN VAPING E.
CIGARETTE AND THE ANTI VAPING
ALLIANCE IN SACRAMENTO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE FIFTH
PAHLAVI ASCO PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I AM A STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVEN THANK YOU CAN.
THANK YOU. RELATED HARLEM
ANOTHER REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THE TIME. NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WOULD NOT RESPONSIBLE
BONTA MY NUMBER FIVE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO ON
BEHALF OF POSTAL COMMUNITIES
DRUG FREE OALITION LIKE THE
COURT OF. THE COURT MUST BE
SEVEN NINETY THREE ALL ROOMS
WITHOUT ANY CHANGES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. LINE EIGHT
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE.
NINE EIGHT THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSIBLE BONTA
LINE NUMBER EIGHT SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
ALREADY A PRIME IN WHAT WILL GO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR YES MA'AM HELLO. HELLO
OKAY YEAH. YES PLEASE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS SIMON PETER
REPRESENTING THE EAGLE OF
PROJECT I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINE THREE THANK YOU.
LINE SIX EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
ARMENIA HIGH A SOPHOMORE AT THE
COR HIGH SCHOOL IN REDWOOD CITY
AND I SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY TO TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSIBLE
BONTA ONE NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DIANA BUT HE'S THERE WOULD
RESULT PACKARD CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL STANFORD STANFORD
CHILDREN'S HEALTH EFFECTS FROM
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN NINE THREE
AS WRITTEN. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHT THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TWYLA LAUGHTER REPRESENTING SAT
CULTURAL HAVE MEDIA FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
SEVEN SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS JIM NOW
CLAYTON I'M A CO FOUNDER OF
FLAVORS ADDICT KIDS LIVERMORE
AND ALSO A PAIR OF TWO
TEENAGERS I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
AND SEVEN NINETY THREE AS
WRITTEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS ROSLYN
PAIN FROM SAN FRANCISCO A
MEMBER OF PARENTS AGAINST
MAKING IT EASIER TO READ I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY THREE AS WITH THE
WITHOUT EXCEPTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE SEVEN NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MRS LINDSEY PLAYED UP
BY THEN ATTACK A MAN NOW MOTHER
Q. AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS WRITTEN WITHOUT
EXEMPTION. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DOCTOR GALLERY YEAR- PROFESSOR
AND HEALTH POLICY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO AND CO FOUNDER OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN TOBACCO
CONTROL LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. I
KNOW SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE
THREE AT WRITTEN WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL EXTENSIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE EIGHT
FORTY FOUR YOUR LIGHT AND OPEN.
LIKE EIGHT FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO MY NUMBER
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE SEVEN NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME YOU LIVE LAST
IS AND I'M CALLING WITH THE
TOLL ORGANIZING ACADEMY AND I
SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
AT THIS WITHOUT EXCEPTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
THREE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SEVEN EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS TERRY
AND DALY I'M A MOTHER OF THREE
YOUNG ADULT MEN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE THREE
WITHOUT EXCEPTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ABOUT
ME. YES MA'AM OKAY HI AM BOTH
THE RUSSELL CALLING WITH THE
SELECT ORGANIZING ECONOMY AND I
SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE THREE
THOUSAND AS WITHOUT EXEMPTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LOOK PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH.
YEAH NUMBER HELLO MY THREE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT A RESPONSIBLE ONE TO MY
NUMBER SEVEN FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY LINE ITEM
ON HIM WITH. I'M PAMELA GRANGER
SMOKE FREE MORAN AND TOBACCO
FREE TO KNOW MY COUNTY GRAND
PARA TO FIVE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
TARGET IN SUPPORT OF BANNING
ALL FLAVORS SMALL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO NINE ALONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH ACTUALLY I'M
PRETTY OPPOSITION. I AM TO
NINETEEN CAN YOU PUT ME BACK IN
THE QUEUE ON THE OPPOSITION.
CAN YOU PUT ME IN THE I'M IN
THE OPPOSITION. OKAY DO THAT.
FARM OF MINE TO HAVE TO BE.
SEVEN NINE THREE. THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHT FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ERICA
HOW AND I'M NOT A FRESHMAN AT
UCLA AND ARE LISTED ON THE
NONPROFIT INTERNATIONAL YOUTH
THE BOTTLE CONTROL I SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE AT THAT
WOULD NOT EXTENSION CEMEX ABOUT
THE GROWTH THAT THAT WAS THE
GUARD. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SIX FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IS THAT MINE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHICH IS MY LINE.
YOU THIS IS YOUR LINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS A MUCH
DEEPER LEVEL AND I AM THE LIGHT
BUT I LEARNED ALL UP BUT- OF
NOT CHAPTER. AND I'M B<c.cyan> YOU</c>
FOR THE OPPOSITE OPPOSITION TO
THE- SB SEVEN NINETY THREE THIS
WILL CALCULATE MORE BUSINESSES
THANK YOU FOR CALLING THANK YOU
YOU. ANYMORE IN SUPPORT. MY
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NAY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HI. I'M CARE OF
HONOR FROM SAN DIEGO AND I AT
B. SEVEN NINE THREE NO OPTION
THANK YOU. LINE FIVE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FIVE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANKS A LOT THANK YOU.
HELLO HELLO NINE THREE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MARIA ISABEL RUTLEDGE
FROM MOSCOW CENTRAL OFTEN
PHILIP WITH COMMUNITY COALITION.
AND THE COURT OF SB. NOT SEVEN
NINE THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT THANK YOU. LINE SIX
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHT
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M CELEBRATING HERE AND I'M
WHAT. FIVE AND WE'RE BOTH NINTH
GRADERS APART IS NOT A
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON TO MY NUMBER SIX
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIX THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MALDONADO MY
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THE THIRD
PARTY RENTAL CISCO AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
NINE SIX THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE SIX THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I'M CALLING FROM HELLO
MY NAME IS RANI AND PEOPLE IN
PORT TO PORT OF. THE AT THE A
CAMCORDER OKAY- IF BOTH THE
COURT WOULD BE AT THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU. AND THAT TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON THE PART.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
WILL GO AHEAD NOW AND MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION. OUR FIRST
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE FOR
I BELIEVE IS SAID JACKIE I AND
SHE WAS ON THE PHONE EARLIER
AND- IN ALL. WITNESS WILL BE AT
OUR D. S. LA SO SERVE MAKE
AVAILABLE TESTIMONY HERE. EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES
AND AS WITH OUR FIRST WITH OUR
PREVIOUS WITNESSES WHO WHO
STUCK TO THAT VERY CLOSE. THE
WE'LL WE'LL BE ASKING YOU TO DO
LIKEWISE SO WHEN WE FOUGHT BACK
YET AS TO WHAT THE- HER TO GO
FIRST. I'M WHAT HANG ON ONE
SECOND WE HAVE SOMEONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY MY
APOLOGIES- PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
STAR HI ADRIN MOHAMMED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
INSOFAR AS A BILL ARE WITH THAT
AS AS WITHOUT EXEMPTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT. OR
ANYONE ELSE IN OUR WITNESS ROOM
IN SUPPORT NOW THERE'S NO ONE
IN THERE SO OKAY. SO WE'RE BACK
ON TRACK MY APOLOGIES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE UP THERE IN
THE GALLERY- MADAM- MODERATOR
IF YOU HAVE THIS JACQUI AIRS ON
THE PHONE WE'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
HER TESTIMONY NOW. ONE AN OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON RESPECTED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACKIE YEARS
AND I'M THE OWNER OF WINCHESTER
FUEL INTO MACULA CALIFORNIA. IN
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER FOR
THIRTY YEARS EIGHTEEN AT THIS
PARTICULAR LOCATION AND
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED NINE PEOPLE
THESE EMPLOYEES ARE MEMBERS OF
MY FAMILY AND I TAKE GREAT
PRIDE IN PROVIDING THEM WITH
GOOD JOBS THAT ARE FOLKS. THE
TRAIN. STATION READING THEM
WELL. WE NEED NINE INTO THE IN
THE MANNER ALLOW THEM TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
OPERATE AS A POSITIVE A MEMBER
OF THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY I AM
AWFUL OF MOM FOR AND I HAVE SIX
WONDERFUL GRANT. LET ME. START
BY SAYING THANK YOU FOR TRINITY
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND COMMITMENT TO DOING WHAT IS
BEST. FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
HOWEVER I AM GREATLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL TO BAN THE
SALE OF FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS INCLUDING MENTAL
PROGRESS. THE GUARDS AND
SMOKELESS TOBACCO. IT IS
CRUCIAL TO THE FUTURE OF MY
BUSINESS THAT I BE HERE TODAY
TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE MINE. WHO PAYS
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
IF YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. AS A MOTHER AND A
GRANDMOTHER I AGREE THAT USE
VAPING IS AN ISSUE THAT SHOULD
BE ADDRESSED. BUT INCLUDING
MEDICAL CIGARETTES THE GARDENS
PUBLIC TOBACCO AS PART OF THIS
LABOR BAND. MAKES SENSE.
NATIONAL DATA SHOWS THAT YOU.
HAVE THE CLIENT STORY.
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA PUTTING IT
WELL THE PRICE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT
GETTING AMONG ALL A GROUPS
FALLEN TO OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
THAT HAPPENED WITHOUT A POLICY
OF PROHIBITION AND THAT GOES
RIGHT INTO THAT THAT UNDER AGE
YOU BURKE AT THE BACK OF
PRODUCTS ARE JUST. IN THROUGH
LEGAL BUT THE LIKE. EVERY ALL
OF MY EMPLOYEES TO CHECK IT
DILIGENTLY COMPLIED WITH THE
HIGHER AGE REQUIREMENT I COULD
HELP A FOR PROFIT AS
DEMONSTRATED BY MY PERFECT
TOBACCO COMPLIANCE RECORD. I
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY IN ADDITION A TOTAL
TOBACCO FLAVOR BàN WALK IN THE
SALE OF THESE PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA IT WILL SIMPLY
CREATED A LEGAL MARKET AND
ENCOURAGE AN INCREASE IN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. I THINK.
FIRSTHAND RECENTLY WENT BROKE
INTO MY STORE NOT ONCE BUT
TWICE IN THE MONTH OF JUNE FEEL
SEPARATE. AB EIGHT PACK THE
FIRST TIME IN FORTY FOUR PACKS
SECOND BY. THE ONLY OTHER ITEM
THEY STOLE WITH THE COFFEE YOUR
WOULD ONLY. BE CRIMINAL SECOND
THE STEEL. BALL AND DEAL LA THE
PROP IN CALIFORNIA EVEN HIGHER
RATE NOW MORE THAN EVER YOUR
LONG MAY MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS. GET IT WILL LOCK
ARMS OUR LEAD WHEN USE ACCESS
TO BUT THE BAND IS NOW THE
RIGHT INSTEAD OF PROTECTING
KIDS FAMILY RESULT IN BACK A
LOT OF JOHN LIKE OF WAGES AND
WEBER ABOUT OF BILLION IN STATE
FOR A IN THE COMING YEAR. I AM
YOU DO THE RIGHT PLEASE YEAH
POSTAL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TEN AND YOUR COOPERATION.
THANK YOU MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE
RTS LA WE HAVE A WITNESS PLEASE
GO AHEAD OF. PASTOR. THE WAITER
ON MUTE THAT SO WE CAN HEAR
PASTOR TO A LESS. WE SEE HIM HI
THERE THANK YOU OKAY CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. TO EACH OF YOU HUNDRED
THESE CHALLENGING CONDITIONS TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG OPPOSITION.
TO SB SEVEN NINETY THREE MY
NAME IS PAST DECADE OF YOU TO
LOSE ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BAPTIST MINISTERS CONFERENCE OF
LOS ANGELES AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST
MINISTERS CONFERENCE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
JOINED TODAY. OF OUR UNITS FROM
SCLC COMMUTE FOR ALL WHO IS
HERE IN THIS LOS ANGELES
LOCATION TO EXPORT TO EXPRESS
OUR- ARE ARE NOT HOLDING THIS
BILL. THE BILL FOR THE SALES TO
INHERIT FAILED TO SEE AND
INHERIT THE INSTITUTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION ARE THIS ARE THE
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM THAT EXIST
IN OUR SOCIETY TO HEY. I'M NOT
TODAY TO POOR SMOKING IN FACT
WHAT NOBODY THE SMALL. BUT I
SURELY DON'T KEY IS TO SMOKE
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN HERE IS A
CLEAR EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN MIX
KEY AGENDAS WITH DOLE'S
DESIRES. THIS BILL WILL NOT
PREVENT SMOKING AT ALL. THIS
BILL WILL HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHAT WE SEE HERE IS THIS
BILL DISRESPECTS OUR COMMUNITY
OF COLORS AND THEIR PREFERENCE
WALLY EXEMPTS HOOKAH PRODUCTS
ON BEHALF OF THE MIDDLE EASTERN.
COLD 85% OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
CHOOSE MENTHOL AS THEIR SMOKING
CHOICE. IF YOU PUT A BAD ON
THAW IT WE'LL CRIMINALIZE THIS
PRODUCT IT WILL COST. IT
CONSEQUENCE DO YOU MEAN HAVE%
YOU EVER HEARD OF ERIC GARNER
IN NEW YORK HAVE YOU EVER HEARD
OF GEORGE FLOYD ALL OF THOSE
ARE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
ANALYZING AND BANDING THIS
PRODUCT WILL ALSO CREATE ANY
LEGAL BLACK MARKET FOR THIS
PRODUCT. IT'S EASY TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE AGAIN
RESTRICTING SOMETHING FROM OUR
COMMUNITY IT WILL CREATE A
SALES FROM INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
COMMUNITY PASSING IT TO OR FROM
AND WE DON'T NEED THAT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. REMEMBER THIS
REMEMBER IT IS ON JUST TO
EXPECT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN GREATER PUBLIC
HEALTH PROTECTIONS AND BASIC
CIVIL RIGHTS DON'T RESTRICT
SOMETHING FROM MARK. DON'T TAKE
IT FROM THE OTHER COMMUNITY
DON'T PUT A BAN ON THINGS THAT
OUR COMMUNITY WALL BECAUSE
AGAIN AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR NO HAN
TAOS WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR NO
TOKENS OF COURSE WE WILL WE
WERE WE PREFER. EVERYONE TO
EDUCATE INSTEAD OF INCARCERATED
WE DON'T WANT ANOTHER WAR ON
DRUGS WE SAW WHAT THIS MEANT TO
OUR COMMUNITY AND WE DON'T WANT
THIS I WANT TO STEAL SOME OF MY
TIME TO SENATOR. AT THE TOP AS
SO WHICH JUST A MATTER. IN
SUPPORT WHERE ARE YOU WERE IN
AYE SEES ME IN OPPOSITION SO
JUST PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. SO
SIX. MINUTES OF OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY SO IT'S JUST HIS.
NAME AND POSITION ONLY PLEASE.
OKAY RODRICK RIGHT FORMER
MEMBER OF BOTH HOUSES IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE. AND
FOR THE REASONS STATED IN OUR
REFERENCE WILLIS I AM THINK
POSED TO SB SEVEN NINE THREE
OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS OLIVIA BARBER. I'M
WITH SCLC AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
SHERRY SANDERS I'M WITH S. C.
L. FLEE HIGHER POLLS THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME AS I SAY
IN OF WALKING ON WITH SCLC AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HI THOMAS MORE GIVEN I'VE FROM
SCLC AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS ROSHAN
SANDERS ON WITH SCLC AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU. WHEN
THE LAN LANDRY I'M A MEMBER OF.
THE SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. IF WELL IF
THE NEIGHBORHOOD FOR IT AND I
DO OPPOSED THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WITH FEEL FREE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS A DARK ASCENSION IS
ON WITH SCLC AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOHN IN GRANADA AND WITH THE
SCLC AND OPPOSES BILL. THANK
YOU. MEETINGS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER SPECT AND I'M WITH
SCLC AND I DO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THERE
ANYONE ELSE THERE FROM OUR AT
THE RTS. OKAY LOOKS LIKE NOT SO
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE AND
ASKED THE MODERATOR TO OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION ONCE AGAIN JUST YOUR
NAME AND POSITION PLEASE. DO
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THE END AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FORGOT LINE THREE HUNDRED. ARE
WE THERE. IT'LL JUST BE WHAT.
MY NAME IS I'M PULLING THE ROCK
GROUP. THANK YOU. THANK YOUR
LUCKY ONE NUMBER FOR NEXT RUN.
BUT AS A REMINDER JUST YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
OPPOSITION.
AND JUST ONE MORE
MOMENT HERE.
JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE. WE DO HAVE OVER FIFTY
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT HERE
OKAY. WE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES.
HOW IT IN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE LINE FOR
SAFETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MERRIAM I'M IN THE
OFFICE. OF THE ERA. BOTH NATION.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESPONSIBLE RETAILERS AND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD BUSINESS ALLIANCE
WHICH WERE FOUNDED BY ERICA
ASIAN AND BLACK ON REFORMERS
AND THE BAY AREA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DAN
KELLY REPRESENTING CORE MARK
INTERNATIONAL BOY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
FIVE NINETY THREE CRITICAL I
HAD. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AMOUNT. YEAH YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS BRIAN YOU
GOT TIME OF TO PICK UP
SACRAMENTO ALI STRONGLY MY AND
ABOUT LIKE THE OPPORTUNE TO
SPEAK THOUSAND SEVEN TWENTY
NINE REGULAR CUSTOMER BUT
MICHAEL ALL. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY AND PLEASE
DON'T HANG. LINE FOR OUR NINE.
OVAL ROUND I WON FIFTY PEOPLE I
HAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE BAR ON
THE OUT AMERICAN INDICATING THE
GROWTH OF TAKING. WHERE
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESS AND ONE
MILLION FOR STORM FOR ACCOUNT
AND CAL. WHERE BOTH AT THE TIME
AND I THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THEY DID GIVE ALL SHOWN
FROM MEDICAL AYE OPPOSED SEVEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE. THANK YOU.
LINE SIX OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING SIR MEMBERS
NEIL CLARK ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRIBUTORS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE AT.
HELLO MY NAME IS THAT VICTORIA
DRAW OUR AND I WORK AT A MALL
BASED RETAILER- CALLED OTHER
PAPERS FROM THE COACHELLA
VALLEY AS A MEMBER OF THE VAPOR
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND ON
BEHALF OF THE OWNER OF THAT
THEIR FATE RIGHT AUTHOR I.
TRONG LATE AT THE SEVEN NINE
THREE. THANK YOU. WHY AM SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE. WELL I AM
SEVEN EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A STAB ME
ON YET SO AND NOW WITH THE
KEYNOTE. ONE OF THAT JEWELERS
AND WE STRONG OPPOSE AT THE
NINETY THREE WHO CAN TAKE THE
BACK THANK YOU HUNDREDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
INSTEAD TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY TWO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WILLOW RUN BY SIX FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ONE
BILLION BE SMART JUNIOR
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN LEADERSHIP
CONFERENCE UPCOMING CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AT THE SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. LINE
SIX OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS ANNOUNCING HE IN AND
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE TWELVE THOUSAND CONVENIENCE
STORE RETAILERS IN THE TATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SEVEN NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO DOES THE
RATING SUNDAY WITH COPPOLA GOOD
I'M I AM OPPOSING SB SEVEN
NINETY. FIVE FOUR HUNDRED AND
CAN YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD ON THE KNOWN MY NAME IS
COREY PIGGY I'M A RETIRED
EXECUTIVE FROM THE NEW YORK
CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT AND-
COLON AS A MEMBER OF THE LEAGUE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION
PARTNERSHIP AND WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. SB SEVEN NINE
THREE. THANK YOU. WHY AM SEVEN
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE SEVEN FIVE NINE PLEASE
BRAD. LIKE TWO HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT FOR EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI TOM ROBINSON WAS
ROTTEN ROBBIE STORES AND WE
OPPOSE SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE FOR THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY AM
FOUR THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOVADA LINE SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIELLE JONES
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ADVOCATE FOR SMOKE
FREE ALTERNATIVES ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE HARM REDUCTION
STABILIZE. THANK YOU. RIGHT ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHT YEAH YOU WERE WATCHING
BUT WE'VE BEEN WAITING ON THE
PHONE SINCE NINE ONE TWO ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
IVES DOMINGUEZ I RUN MULTIPLE
STORES IN SANTA BARBARA I AM AN
EX SMOKER MOVEMENT. THREE TO
FIVE YEARS THROUGH THE USE OF
NON TOBACCO FLAVORED OF A
PRODUCT I STRONGLY OPPOSE AT
DETACHMENT NINETY. THANK YOU.
LINE SIX FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS THE
GOVERNMENT DOLLARS THE PROUD
FATHER OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU. FIVE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE FIVE EIGHT NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH IS. WILL
MOVE ON THE LINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIX FEET FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING THAT THE
TRACTOR FERNANDO ON BEHALF OF
SWITCHER. IN OPPOSITE TO AT THE
SEVEN NAY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
HELLO YES PLEASE PLEASE GO
AHEAD OF CAR ARE. MY NAME IS
SCOTT THE BARD ONE WITH THE
HISPANICS SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AND THE MINORITY A
DIFFERENT THIS IS THE RATE AND
TERRIBLE TERRIBLE. I THE YOU.
WELL I FOR EIGHTY TWO PLEASE AT.
NINE FOUR EIGHT TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
TURNED OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE SIX NINE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL HELLO YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JULIE
OVER WATER FROM SAN DIEGO ON
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY FOR STATE
FOR BAKING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
OF AT LEAST SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND
PIXEL FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS ERIN NORWOOD
ABOUT THE SWEDISH MATCH NORTH
AMERICA WE HAVE AN UP CLOSE
LOOK AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BELL ASKING FOR THE EXTENSION
OF OUR EIGHT SMOKELESS TOBACCO
PRODUCTS HAVE BUT THE P. AND G.
I AND NUMBER TWO DE DESIGNATION
FROM THE FTA AS WELL AS OUR
NICOTINE ONLY PRODUCT THANK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE.
CURTAIN SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON OSCAR ROMERO AT
A DOZEN PAPERS I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOOKING
NEARLY. GREAT LARA FROM REALLY
ARE CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
RETAILERS IN THE CENTRAL COAST
AND OVER THREE MILLION EX
SMOKERS OF VOTING AGE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THERE WAS A STATE TENS
OF. THOUSANDS OF A ARE. WELL I
AND EIGHT OUT TO GOD. RIGHT AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. RIGHT FIVE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS THE AND I'M
ACTUALLY A MOTHER OF TWO
TEENAGE BOYS I'M AN ACTIVE
ADVOCATE FOR A HARM REDUCTION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINE THREE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT TACKLE BASEBALL
AHEAD. RIGHT TO CHALLENGE ZERO
THREE FOUR HAD. HI MY NAME IS
JUANITA. I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL REPRESENTATIVE HEARTFELT
BY ASSOCIATION OF
RESPONSIBILITY JONES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE OR AT. HI MY NAME IS JANET
BECAUSE I AM A MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY BIRTHDAY BIRTHDAY
THEME PAGE CHAPTER AS THE
CHAPTER. AT THE NINETY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE FOUR
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE IN OUR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN
GOLDSTINE I'M THE BOARD CHAIR
OF ONE COURSE OF ACTION
PARTNERSHIP OF WHAT'S RETIRED
LIEUTENANT WE GOT THE BEACH
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES. HOME
THANK YOU. LIGHT ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOHN DIXON AMONG ALL THE
PEOPLE LEAST PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
BLACK WON'T SPEND THAT COULD
NOT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
LOCAL. ACTION PARTNERSHIP AND
WE FIGURED WE ALL THE- THANK
YOU. RIGHT FIVE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIVE NINE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT NINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO
YOU SHOW FOR HONORABLY SMALL
CONVENIENCE STORE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. RYAN
TO SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRIGHTON TWO ONE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO THAT
SOUNDS LIKE FROM BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS ON ACTUALLY
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT
I DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO SPEAK
BEFORE TURNED WHICH STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ADDS IN.
THANK YOU. RIGHT TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OPPOSED SEVEN
NINETY THREE SB DOES NOT DILLON
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIVE
SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
RYAN AND I WORK FOR INSPIRED
BEAT COMPANY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RAIMES FOR EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE FOUR EIGHT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER EIGHT SEVENTY SIX FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOW GOOD
ENOUGH THAT THE BILL
CALIFORNIA. AND I OPPOSE. SB
SEVEN NINE THREE THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHT THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS DON DON
DORA FROM AFRICA AND I POSED
BILL THANK YOU. ONE NINE ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
NINE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WITH NO RESPONSE TO MOVE ON TO
MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN CHAIRMAN
CONDEMNING PLEASE YES. YEAH
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DAHLE DETAINED-
WHERE THANBEING CONVENIENCE
STORE FRANCHISE THE IMPOSTER
COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE AND THE IRONY OF
THEIR BUILDINGS WE ARE ACTUALLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. JUST YOUR
NAME AND Y. CHARACTERIZATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE TO SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWO
SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS A YOUR CATCH GUILD
REPRESENTING EACH YEAR AND THIS
CALIFORNIA CENTER MARKETS IN
OPPOSITION OF SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANKS THANK YOU. NINE
SIX FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT DEEP
FROM THE BUSINESS OWNER AN
ELDORADO COUNTY FATHER OF A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR AND
REGISTERED CERTIFIED COACH FOR
NOR CAL MOUNTAIN BIKE HIGH
SCHOOL TEAM TRAP SHOOTING TEAM
AND BOY SCOUTS AND I AM OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FIVE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSIBLE BONTA
Y. NUMBER NINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT HEARING. MY
NINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MATTHEW JENKINS FATHER RAY AND
I'M IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHRISTOPHER ARJUN OWNER THE
PAPER TRAIL THEM ON A
CALIFORNIA FATHER ONE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. LINE SIX HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS J. O. COMO PARA PARENT
OF TWO CHILDREN CALLING ORDERED
COUNTY OF ORANGE ON BEHALF OF
FIVE PONDERED OVER TWO MILLION
SMOKERS THERE BEFORE OF THE
BLACK MARKET WITH THE
DISCRIMINATE BILL I VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE- THAT. SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. JUST YOUR NAY. NINE
FIVE NINE EIGHT. NINE FIVE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS LAMB TO
WIN I'M FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA I'M AN ADULT OVER
TWENTY ONE AND A US ARMY
VETERAN I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER NINE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS. IS
YOUR SPOKE ABOUT THE LIQUOR OF
THE HELP TO THE VICTORIA WE
OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU. NINE NINE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS BOB IN THE THING AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. LINE
NINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NATIONAL PETROLEUM AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF FIFTEEN OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE AMERICAN PETROLEUM AND
CONVENIENCE STORE ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. NINE NINE TWELVE
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
RETURNS ON I'M AN EXPLORER AND
OPPOSES BILL SB SEVEN NINE
THREE THANK YOU. R. O. THAT ARE
CURRENT THREE HUNDRED NINE FOR
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS AMANDA ELLIOTT OF SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY I'M A FORMER SMOKER
OF TWENTY SEVEN YEARS TO QUIT
WITH THE FAR LEFT HARMFUL
PRODUCTS AND I AM APPROACH YOU
BABY BY BARBARA THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MARKET DALE
AND REPRESENTING CIRCLE K.
CONVENIENCE STORES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN EACH.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEX PENSION
I'M AN EXTRACURRICULAR OF OVER
TEN YEARS I DO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SB SEVEN NINETY THREE AND I
DO PROPOSED THAT YOU ARE
REINFORCED THE MODERN SOCIETY
CONTRIBUTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHT EIGHT RELY OPEN.
MY NAME IS ROBERT REDFORD A LOT
ANGELES BACK CRIED WHEN YOU
SCROLL OPPOSE. HE SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE BUT- THANK THANK
YOU. THANK NINE SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE GRAHAM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
POSSIBLE RETAILERS AND WE
OPPOSE BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU. NINE
NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHY NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO MY
NUMBER NINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS LOCKER ROOM FATHER OF TWO
AND A HALF OF THEM AIMED TO
PRICES BY. OBJECT SB SEVEN
NINETY ROWDY STRONGLY. THANK
YOU. NINETY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JAGDEEP
KALRA WOULD NEED OUR PETROLEUM.
I ALSO OPPOSED SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. MY NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM AT THE JAMES
LOCATED IN SAN DIEGO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. MY
NINE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS MY FUTURE IN
THE JOB SEVEN ELEVEN FRANCHISE
THE IN ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANDREI BY JOHN FATHER OF TWO I
LOOK FOR IS BY THE DISTRIBUTION
COMPANY I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
SEVEN NINETY. THANK YOU. MY
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL OF THE POSSIBLE
ANOTHER TOURNEY AND A BUSINESS
OWNER AND PROUD PARENT OF CORN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. LIME THREE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE NUMBER
NINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS RICHARD ABLE AND I
REPRESENT FIFTY FOUR FASTER
STORAGE BASED OUT OF
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA. I
OPPOSE SENATE BILL SEVEN THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE TO
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
BILL SIGNED WITH CORMARK
INTERNATIONAL REPRESENTING ITS
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE
THREE THANK YOU. ONE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS RAY UP TO LOG AND
MANAGE FOUR STORES IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OPPOSED THE SB SEVEN
NINE THREE THANK YOU. ONE FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS RYAN RECORDED
WITH CORMARK INTERNATIONAL
REPRESENTING OUR FOUR HUNDRED
THREE EMPLOYEES AND WE OPPOSE
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU. NINE TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES I CAN HEAR ME. YES
SIR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET UP
IN A RIDER CAN RIVERS AND CORE
MARK INTERNATIONAL LOCATED IN
HERE CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING
TO OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE THREE.
THANK YOU. ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TO KEEP SAID DO A
ANA BEHALF OF THE CENTRE VALLEY
CHAPTER MEMBERS OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN PRICKLE AND STORES.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY SEVEN
ELEVEN FRANCHISE OWNERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY OPPOSES
THE BILL SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN I CAN I BURKE YES PLEASE.
OKAY. GO AHEAD. WHICH IN A
MODEST MINDSET. I'M SORRY WHAT
ARE. REFERRING NUMBER IS MINE
WELL YOU'RE IN THE OPPOSITIONAL
CARE. YEAH I AM OPENING I AM-
CALLING FROM DORENBOS MARKS UP.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. NINE NINE
NINE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH I'M GOING I'M NOT
INVEST SO MINE IS ALSO GONNA
TRY I AM OPENING THE MEETING.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE TWENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI HEARING. GO
AHEAD WELL YES HI MY NAME'S
MANDY WITH DAVID THE I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
OKAY THANK YOU. ONE FOUR ZERO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS CABLE PRESIDENT SMALL
BUSINESS FORMERLY FAN WAS VERY
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE THREE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH BUT
CHAMBERS JOHN THE CALIFORNIA
FIELD INCONVENIENT WHY THE POST
THANKS THANK YOU. LINE EIGHT
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE EIGHT FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE NUMBER NINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AYE AYE SIR MORNING
HIGHLINE NINE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SORRY DO YOU
READY- SPANISH. SPANISH MONARCH
OWNER I DO NOT BELIEVE FOR
YEARS I. JUST TAKE MY BLOOD IT
IS LAW. OKAY THANK YOU. ONE MY
NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME'S JOHN
HOCHBERG WITH CIGAR BOX AN A
BUDGET PACT ABOUT CLOTHES WELL
AYE OPPOSED TO THIS SB SEVEN
NINE THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO EIGHT YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
MOORHEAD I'M A BUSINESS OWNER
AND I OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE
EIGHT. OKAY THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS. NELSON
OKAY CAL. AND I OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIVE SIX WHEN YOUR
MIND IS BUT- I NEED A LOT AND
THERE CAN. THANK YOU HELLO YEAH.
PLEASE GO AHEAD I WENT ON THERE
YEAH WE'RE HERE. AND THEIR
MONUMENTS. HEY THERE MY NAME IS
ST UP THERE ON BEHALF OF DOT
THE INK OF ALLEY CIRCLE CHEVRON
IN WOODLAND HILLS CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF CHEVRON
CONVENIENCE STORE RETAILERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. VEHICLE
SB SEVEN THREE NINE. SB SEVEN
NINE THREE OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LIE NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT HE
IGNORES THING FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I- MONTHS MALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND AYE OPPOSED
A BILL SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
YES I CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES. I'M SORRY I'M
ACTUALLY POSSIBLY FOR THE BILL
BUT I COULDN'T GET THROUGH OKAY.
UP SO I'M WRITING DIçN CARE
THANK YOU. I'M. NINE NINE
NINETY YEAR IS OPEN. HI MY NAME.
ARE WE ALL WHO WILL GO ON FOR
SB. SEVEN NINE. THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JACK
GRAYER- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESPONSIBLE
RETAIL I AM A FATHER OF ONE AND
I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE NO SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINE THREE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE NINE
SEVENTY FIVE I DON'T KNOW BUT-
YES MY NAME IS- JESSE SANGOMA
CLOCKED UP THREE AND- I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THAT
SB SEVEN NINE THREE OKAY THANK
YOU. NINE NINE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES
THERE IS GO AHEAD. IF THE
SENATE IS NOT. HELLO WHAT
UNDERSTAND SOMEONE HAD A
QUESTION FOR ME. YES HELLO
YELLOW GET THIS SENATOR REID
I'M CALLING BACK SOMEONE HAD A
QUESTION FOR ME I'M NOT THAT
I'M AWARE OF SIR. NO ONE'S IT
ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT
WE'RE JUST TAKING PEOPLE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL SO. OKAY
YEAH THIS WOULD MAKE A MISTAKE
HE- UNDER MR RIGHT CAN YOU YOU
A MOMENT SIR WE ACTUALLY DOING
OPPOSITION FOR BILL. OKAY AND
I'M- DOUBLE WHAT I WAS INVOLVED
WITH. IS THAT THE SEVEN NINE
THREE. WE ARE WE ARE TAKING
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL WE'RE NOT I'M NOT WE'RE
NOT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW SO. NOT AWARE. I
START. OKAY WITH SOMEBODY WAS
SUPPOSED TO ASK ME ALL RIGHT
I'LL I'LL I'LL HOLD ON. OKAY
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU AND MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER FIVE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI CHRISTINE FROM
SAN DIEGO AND I OPPOSE- SB
SEVEN NINE THREE. THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHT NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S
EIGHTY PERKINS ON BEHALF OF
CORMARK INTERNATIONAL MY TWO
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES IN MY
FOURTEEN HUNDRED RETAILERS I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU. NINE
TEN TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ADAM SWANSON I'M
HAPPY COSTA CLOUD LLC HELLO MY
CUSTOMERS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU. OKAY ROD RIGHT UP
WITH LINE TEN TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CALLING A MOMENT
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRY I AM A
FIFTY FIVE YEARS OLD RESIDENTS
ARE. ONLY A POSTAGE RACES BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NEXT ABOUT A
LINE NUMBER NINE NINE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO IBM OUR NO
CALLING YOU BACK FOR. HELLO
MA'AM. MY NAME IS PART OF A
CLOSE EYE ON I AM A SMOKE SHOP
EMPLOYEE IN ANY OF THOSE THAT
YOU SEVEN NINE THREE. THANK YOU.
OKAY BUT MY NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
HOLD ON A SECOND AND YOU GOT A
COPY OF THE BILL. PLEASE GO
AHEAD MA'AM. MY NINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS STILL OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER NINE ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HELLO. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I'M HERE EARLY IN
AYE AYE BOTH SB SEVEN NINE
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. WIND
TEN TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLYN
ROBBIE BUSINESS OWNER FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
PLEASE HELP US NOT DEPLOYED
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. NINE TEN THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS AMONG
SHOPPERS PASADENA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE
THREE OKAY THANK YOU. NINE TEN
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JAKE BERLINGO OF VALLEY
FORGE EVERYBODY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SEVEN I. THREE AND
I. IMPLORE YOU TO LIVING HERE
VOTERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MIND THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELL YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD HELLO YES MY NAME IS
CHRIS WEAVER AND I'M WITH RIGHT
BATES INCORPORATED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE THANK YOU MATTER
MODERATE TAKE TEN MORE. IN THEN
WE GO TO THE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY SO. TEMARA CALLS
PLEASE. IT WILL KEEP TRACK GIVE
HER. OKAY ONE TEN FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BILL BEER
CHAHAL- BEGIN BILL ON THE
BEHALF OF RAQQA AND I'M ALSO A
DEALER IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL OKAY
THANK YOU. NINETEEN FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GIVE ME TEN FORTY
ONE I APOLOGIZE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TEN FORTY ONE UNITED OPEN.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES I WANT
PROJECT THE CHAIRMEN AND
MEMBERS THAT ARE LLOYD IS NOT
BEING HURT EQUAL ARE YOU HAPPY
CALLING BEGINNING ON THE LAW
THANK YOU THIS. THANK YOU. YOUR
NAME. FORTY PLEASE. THANK YOU
SIR. TEN FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DIANE GRAY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESPONSIBLE
RETAILERS AYE OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE I THANK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I NINE FIFTEEN FIFTY
ONE PRE PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. HELLO MY
NAME IS RAHUL I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF WILL SIXTEEN EMPLOYEES-
WORK FOR ME. AND THEY'RE ALL
GOING TO GO JOBLESS WITH USE
THAT ONE DOES SEVEN THE THAT
POPPING NINE THREE OKAY I WILL
POST STRONG THANK YOU SO FIVE
CALLS. NINETEEN PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR NAY INITIALLY. NINETEEN
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
ZERO FIVE ZERO. HI MY NAME IS
THE A LOT. AND I AM A RETAILER.
YOUR ARE FULL BODY STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE SB SEVEN NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. YOUR CORNER GAS
AND I AM MORE BUSINESS ON TECH
AND ON FROM HERE THAT AVAILABLE
SB SEVEN. THANK YOU. LINE FIVE
NINETY TWO YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THE ONE FIVE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLAYED. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MIGHT BE A VERY PART BOTH
AND AYE OPPOSED SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THERE ARE NAME IS FOR OF%
GOING FROM SOME HE'S A- ONLY
PULLS SB SEVEN NINETY. THANK
YOU AND THE LAST MONTH LAST
CALL PLEASE. NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CONFISCATION IT'S ACTUALLY. IF
OKAY ONE ONE FIVE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN EVEN AFFILIATION PLEASE.
COMPLETION IT MAKES YOU CAN GET
WORK WE HAVE RESPONSE FROM
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR SHOULD WE
TRY ONE MORE ARE WITH THAT
ANSWER I THINK THAT'S IT THANK
YOU I JUST MET WITH THE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN AN AND NOT
FROM A THEY ARE WELCOME TO. LET
THESE COMMITTEE PORTAL. I
BELIEVE WAS ONE. PERSON WHO
WOULD ON THE LINE FOR A VERY
LONG TIME WAITING TO. IN IN
SUPPORT WE JUST GET. I'M WITH
THE FROM AUTUMN OGDEN. IF SHE'S
STILL ALIVE WE COULD OPEN THE
AND THEN I KNOW WE HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE HERE THE CHAIN AS
WELL SO. SO MARTIN IS UP THERE
PLEASE PER. ONE ZERO. AND IF
NOT- WILL GO UP THANK WILL THAT
WILL WILL DISTENDED THERE WE
HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN THE CHAMBER
PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER VAN
BUSKIRK I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SO THE RETAIL
TOBACCONISTS AND IT'S
CALIFORNIA MEMBER. WE OPPOSE SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE FOLLOWING
REASON BEING ONE THANKS GIVE ME
THINK YOU'RE JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION THAT'S THE THIRD
TIME JUST THIRTY SECONDS NOPE
THANK YOU. ANYBODY. SURCHARGE
AT THAT IT. ONE MORE THAT'S IT
OKAY I'M SORRY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. OKAY MAN FOR A BRACE
FROM BRINGS BACK THE. BEFORE I
ASK COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE
COMMENTS. WHEN ASSETS HELLO. I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO I'D LIKE TO
ASK YOU TO TAKE. SO I'M GONNA
ASK YOU TO TAKE TO AMENDMENTS.
FIRST OF ALL I'M GONNA ASK YOU.
AS THIS WILL BE CALLED
SUBDIVISION FIVE. EXEMPTION
SHALL NOT APPLY TO THE SALE OF
PREMIUM CIGARS SOLD IN CIGAR
LOUNGES WHERE PRODUCTS ARE
PURCHASED AND CONSUMED IN THE
ON THE PREMISES. AND ANSWER
SECTION SIX THE SUBDIVISION
SHALL NOT APPLY TO LOOSE LEAF
TOBACCO ARE YOU WILLING TO
ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS SENATOR
HILL. MISTER CHAIR I AM WILLING
TO ACCEPT IT WOULD APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
INTENT AND WE JUST SAW THESE
AND JUST HEARD THEM TO HAVE-
CONVERSATIONS IN THE DRAFTING
OF THOSE IMAGE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE- INTENT IS CLEAR IN IT
WITHOUT THAT OPPORTUNITY I
ACCEPT THE. AMEND EXCEPT THE
MOMENT THAT IMPORTANT ARE ALL
RIGHT ENOUGH OKAY RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU AT THIS POINT WE
WILL ASK MEMBERS COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS OF THE. THANK YOU
CHAIR I JUST US YOU KNOW I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THIS IS A ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN EXTREMELY. ENGAGING FOR
OUR STATE AND I KNOW FOR THE
LETTER AS WELL. AND I WONDER IF
THE OVER THE LAST DAY. THIS IS-BEEN AN ISSUE THAT- IT HAS BEEN
AN ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD. I'M A FORMER SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AND WHEN E.
CIGARETTES AND VAPING FIRST
CAME OUT SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAD-
NO IDEA WHAT TO DO- WE DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT THEY WERE WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW. WHAT CATEGORY I'M
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION. I HAD TO.
FOR A WITH LEGAL COUNSEL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER IT WAS
COVERED UNDER TOBACCO OR NOT.
I'M IN SO I THINK WE'VE HAD TEN
YEARS OF LOT OF. X. IN OUR
STATE IN AROUND COUNTRY. WHY
FLEET BATTLE IS. PART TO ARE
STILL. AND WHY IT'S BECAUSE A
GATEWAY SO. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR HAS- BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD. I KNOW THAT THIS IS
BEEN DIFFICULT IT'S BEEN YEARS
IN THE MAKING BUT I DO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AROUND. THIS AND
THE CONNECTION TO- TOBACCO USE
AMONGST MY PEERS- ARE VERY REAL
AND IN SO MANY LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- IT'S BEEN WELL
OVER A DECADE. THAT WE'VE BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH WHAT TO DO ABOUT
THIS. I THINK WITH. IT THERE'S
NO TO THE REST. BLOOMS ARE BIG
ISSUE AND YOU THINK ABOUT THOSE
ELEMENTS THAT- DON'T HELP
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS AND YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS ONE OF THEM
SO YOU KNOW I'M A CO AUTHOR OF
THE BILL I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL. I DO APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT AROUND THE STATE ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS. WHAT
I'VE BEEN IN. POLICYMAKERS AT
THE LOCAL CHANNEL AND STATE AND
NATIONAL LEVEL HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO TACKLE THIS- AND I THINK WE
KNOW A LOT ABOUT THE IMPACT IT
HAS ON MINORS AND HOW THAT
SERVES. AS A GATEWAY FOR
PROLONGED USE- AND ALSO HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT ARE VERY ILL IN A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBER
LIMON I CAN'T HONESTLY CAN'T
REMEMBER WHO WAS NEXT SO. I HAD
MR RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN CENTER THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS A VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION FOR IT AS WE TALK
ABOUT THESE VAPING PRODUCTS AND
I THINK THE FLAVORS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THAT ARE REALLY
ATTRACTIVE TO THE CHILDREN ARE
YOU TO THE STATE- ARE LOOKING
AT THIS BILL IN ENCINO THERE
WERE SOME OF PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT YOUR ONE INDEX
TO TAKE. OUR UNFORTUNATE WE
DON'T HAVE THEM A LOT SOONER
RATHER THAN- I WAS ELEVEN HOURS
SO TO SPEAK THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT. KIND OF A BETTER. WHAT
THESE A MEMBER MEAN AND HOW IT.
IN REALITY TO THE BILL I'M GLAD
YOU ARE WORKING ON SOME OF
THESE AND LOOKING TO ACCEPT. AS
AS- BEING PRESENTED- BUT STILL
HAVING SOME ISSUES TO GRASS
AROUND IT- I'M TORN ABOUT THIS
BILL IT'S IMPORTANT BILL IT'S-
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY. A
NEEDED AND TO ADDRESS BUT- I
JUST HAVE TO COMMENTS I WANTED
TO MAKE ABOUT THIS BILL. ONE IS.
THE LAST. THAT'S BEING TAUGHT
ABOUT AND STAFF ANALYSIS OF
ABOUT TWO HUNDED MILLION
DOLLARS- WHAT DO WE LOOK TO DO.
BECAUSE OF THAT LOST REVENUE TO
OUR BUDGET- WILL LOOK AT A
STATE BUDGET OF OVER FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN LOST REVENUE
OR OR AND- AND- DILEMMA THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE- HOW TO
SELECT OR OR CURRENT BUDGET FOR
THE NEXT YEAR. MOVING FORWARD
AND- FUNDING SOME OF THESE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BENEFITTED FROM. OUR FROM- THE
SALE SOME OF THESE PRODUCTS.
ARE THE SECOND ONE UPS YOU KNOW
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
BILL. IS ENFORCEMENT OF IT WHO
DO WE LOOK TO. ENFORCE THAT
THESE PRODUCTS ARE NOT BEING
SO. COMMUNITIES WILL LOOK AT
THAT ISN'T I'M IS BUT- FIRST
RIGHT THEY'RE NOT YOU WITH.
COVERT PARTNERS. THE IS.
LIMITED SO I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
WOULD LOOK TO ENFORCE IT- JUST
OPPOSED TO COMMENTS AND- I'M
LEANING. MAYBE SUPPORT THIS
BILL IF I DO WOULD BE AS
OCCURRED VOTE BECAUSE OF ARE
WHATS BUT- MYSELF AROUND THE- A
MAN. THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED. I
WOULD RESERVE MY- SUPPORT. TO I
NEVER FOR SO IF YOU CAN JUST
KIND OF PIGGYBACK ON THE TWO
THE PURCHASE THANK REMEMBER IN
IN REALLY THE COST THE OR THE
LOS INCOME AS WANT TO SAY I HIS
BE OVER SHADOWED BY WHAT IS THE
REALITY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL SAVE AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT SAID YOU KNOW THERE
ARE THE BIG SPECIALLY LIKE THE
MEDIC CAL COST THE SAVINGS OF
THREE POINT FIVE EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR- WITH THIS
LEGISLATIONWITH THIS BILL
PASSED WITH A BE A TREMENDOUS
SAVINGS OF HEALTH COSTS THIS IS
THE- BILLION IN. NORMAL HEALTH
CARE CURRENT J. TWO WHICH
SHOULD REDUCE HEALTH OF UP THAT
MOST OF US PAY FOR OUR HEALTH
INSURANCE IT IN TOTAL THIS WILL
GREAT SAVINGS IT WILL BE A
REVENUE LOSS AND FRANKLY TO
LOOK AS THE AS AN AUSTIN
PRICING PLACE ON IPHONE WILDER
KIT BURKE T. YOUR. BROUGHT OVER
TO T. INTO IN THE VEHICLE
SAVINGS. THANK YOU BEFORE WE
MOVE TO THE NEXT A MEMBER JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY SOMETHING IS MY
ERROR I APOLOGIZE IT'S A LONG
TEST OF ALREADY WE STILL HAVE
MANY BILLS AHEAD OF US SO- I DO
WANT TO CLARIFY THERE WERE
ACTUALLY THERE ACTUALLY THREE
PIECES OF THE AMENDMENT. NUMBER
ONE A. B. WE'RE WE'RE ASKING
FOR WE'RE EXEMPTING ESSENTIALLY
A PREMIUM CIGAR WE'RE DEFINING
THAT AS ANY CIGAR THERE'S NOT
MASS PRODUCED BY USE OF
MECHANIZATION AS A RAPPER IT IS
MADE ENTIRELY FROM WHOLE
TOBACCO AND AS A WHOLESALE
PRICE OF NO LESS THAN TWELVE
DOLLARS. THAT IS IN THE
SUBDIVISION SHALL NOT APPLY TO
THE SALE OF PREMIUM CIGARS
HOLDEN. AND LOUNGES WHERE
PRODUCTS ARE PURCHASED AND
CONSUMED ON THE PREMISES. AND
THEN THE THIRD PIECE OF THIS IS
IT SHALL NOT APPLY TO LOOSELY
TOBACCO. WHICH IS MEANT. TO GO
TO ENCOMPASS PIPES. AND ALSO
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE USING THIS
FOR A CEREMONIES IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN INDIAN CEREMONY SO.
THAT IS NOT WAS NOT AS BAD AS
THE CONTEXT IN WHICH THESE
THESE ARE ARE PRESENTED SO I
APOLOGIZE THAT I DIDN'T MAKE
THAT CLEAR I DO HAVE A COPY OF
IT THANK YOU. I UNDERSTAND THAT
SO THANK YOU. SO I'M TRYING TO
THINK WHO IS I THINK MISTER
RAMOS WAS NEXT. THEN MR MCCARTY
AND MISS MISS BURKE. WE'RE OF
GOING AROUND HERE NOT NOT
IGNORING YOU MISTER FOR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- FIRST
OPPORTUNITY AND THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MUCH. NEEDED
BAIL- THERE IS AREAS- THAT I
STILL HAVE CONCERNS AND THAT'S
THE FUNDING MECHANISM OF IT-
CERTAINLY BROUGHT UP THE GOOD
WORK THAT FIRST FIVE HAS DONE
TO EDUCATE THE COMMUNITY. ON
THE PROBLEMS WITH TOBACCO BUT
YET WE DON'T HAVE THAT REVENUE
STREAM FOR EDUCATION ON THE
VAPING PRODUCTS OF IT AND WE'VE
TALKED AHMET LAYING ON THAT
COMPONENT OF IT. SO I WANTED
TO- AS THIS DIALOGUE CONTINUES
TO MOVE FORWARD THAT IT'S CLEAR
THAT THERE HAS TO BE SOME TYPE
OF DISCUSSION ON THE FUNDING
STREAM FOR THE VAPING PRODUCTS
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THE
FUNDING. INTO THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO BE ABLE TO EDUCATE A LOT OF
THE- COMMUNITIES- THAT NEED
THAT EDUCATION ON THE VAPING
PRODUCT ITSELF. WE'VE TALKED AT
LENGTH AGAIN ON WHAT WE START
AT THE VAPING I AGREE THERE
NEEDS TO BE. SOME TYPE OF
BANNING ON THOSE PER BUT ALSO
THEIR- COMPONENT TO FALL SAME
REVENUE MACINNES. FIRST FIVE
WE'VE TALKED AT LENGTH ON THAT
AND ALSO. TALKING ABOUT TOBACCO
IN THE ILL THAT ARE THERE NOW
THAT WE'RE INTO THAT BUT WE
ALSO TO SEE. THAT CREATION
AMERICANA WAS A- SO THINK THAT
ABLE TO FORWARD THINK THROUGH
THESE TOPICS THAT WE WOULD BE
HIT WITH THAT EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS ON THAT ASPECT ALSO.
AND I GET TO- WHERE MY
COLLEAGUES. MONNING BROUGHT UP
AS FAR AS THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM CERTAINLY ONE OF. I
THINK WHOSE HAVE THE RESOURCES
FOR. IS IT LOCAL LAUNCH. WE
ASKED TO BRING THAT FOR AND
I'VE I BRING THAT UP NOT SOME.
TO JUST MORE TO TALK ABOUT THE
PRODUCT THE PROBABILITY OF
WHO'S IN FORTUNATE BECAUSE WE
SEEN WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH
THE- WITH ILLEGAL MARIJUANA AND
DISPENSARIES THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND NOW WE'RE TRYING TO CLOSE
THOSE DOWN TO GET THE REVENUE
INTO THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS SO
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT ARE VERY
REAL- AND THESE ARE IS STILL.
ARE VERY- CONCERNING TO ME
SPELL WHEN WE START TO TALK
ABOUT VAPING AND THEN WE GOING
TO- THE TOBACCO IN SOME OF
THESE OTHER AREAS BUT YET WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT.
WHERE THAT ENFORCEMENT'S GONNA
COME FROM THESE ARE THINGS THAT
I WANT TO BRING UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE WERE ON RECORD
TALKING ABOUT THESE REASONS IN
THE FUNDING STREAM THAT I
BELIEVE SHOULD BE PART OF A
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD
SHOULD THIS BILL CONTINUE TO BE
DEBATED- AND THESE ISSUES ALONG
THE WAY THANK. YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR. MISTER MISS
BURKE I THINK OR I THINK AND
THEN A STRICT MCCARTY. PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD MR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BEING SO GRACIOUS WHEN WE
SPOKE- ABOUT THIS BILL WE
HAVEN'T ALWAYS AGREED BUT I
BELIEVE WE'VE ALWAYS HAD A VERY
GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP AND I
HAVE A TON OF RESPECT. FOR THE
SENATOR AND HIS WORK CAN YOU
CAN YOU SPEAK UP JUST A YEAH
FOR THE SENATOR AND HIS WORK-
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
BEFORE I SAY WHEN I'M GETTING
READY TO SAY. THAT THAT IS
CLEAR THANK YOU HOWEVER.
THERE'S A HOWEVER- YOU KNOW I
THINK MOST OF US AGREE HERE
THAT. WE DON'T WANT TO SEE KIDS
SMOKING IN FACT IF I HAD IT MY
WAY NO ONE WITH SMOKE. I'M NOT
A FAN AT ALL. THAT SAID
DECIDING HOW TO VOTE TODAY HAS
BEEN REAL A REAL CHALLENGE FOR
ME. AND I WANT TO BE SUPER
CLEAR ABOUT THE CRUX OF MY
ANNOYANCE IS THAT THE BILL IS
INDICATIVE OF A TREND THAT I
FIND BELITTLING AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO THE WHITE
OR GOLD OF INCLUSIVITY
EMPOWERMENT AND ENRICHMENT THAT
OUR STATE CONTINUALLY PREACHES.
SMOKING ADDICTION MUCH LIKE
ALCOHOL DEPENDENCY IS USUALLY A
SYMPTOM OF A MUCH LARGER
PROBLEM. THESE PRODUCTS TO
BECOME VICE IS USED TO ESCAPE
REALITY. TAKE A DRIVE THROUGH
AND THEIR PORTION OF MY
DISTRICT AND YOU WOULD BE HARD
PRESSED TO FIND A LIQUOR STORE.
DRIVE THROUGH THE OTHER SIDE
AND YOU'LL BE HARD PRESSED TO
FIND A GROCERY STORE OR A
HOSPITAL YES. THERE IS A LIQUOR
STORE CONVENIENCE STORE ON
EVERY CORNER. AND PEOPLE WANT
TO TALK TO ME ABOUT COMMUNITIES
BEING TARGETED. OVER AND OVER
IN THE BILLS WE PASS I SEE
SYMPTOMS OF OUR STATE PROBLEMS
BEING ADDRESSED AND WEEK
CASUALLY GLOSS OVER THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES OF THOSE
PROBLEMS AND THIS BILL IS NO
DIFFERENT. ACCORDING TO THE CDC
ADULTS BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL
OR MORE THAN TWICE AS LIKELY TO
SMOKE AS ADULTS WHO ARE ABOVE
THE POVERTY LEVEL AN ANNUAL
INCOME. THAT GAP JUMPS THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY WHEN WE
COMPARE ADULTS WITH LESS THAN A
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION TO ADULTS
CO GRAD. IT'S NOT COINCIDENTAL
WE KNOW THERE IS A DIRECT
CORRELATION BETWEEN POVERTY AND
THINGS LIKE SMOKING AND
DRINKING THAT HELP PEOPLE AND
THESE ARE THINGS THAT HELP
PEOPLECOPE WITH THE STRESS AND
TRAUMA OF PROPERTY. SINCE THIS
BILL. FIX THIS BILL IS MADE
OVER TO THIS HOUSE I'VE DEALT
WITH. MORE CALLS MORE MEETINGS
MORE TAX SOMETIMES AROUND THE
CLOCK NOT TO MENTION SOCIAL
MEDIA TRYING TO PUSH ME IN MY
OPINION IN ONE DIRECTION OR
ANOTHER AND IT THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION. WHERE IS THIS FURY ON
ACTIVITIES AROUND BILLS THAT
TACKLE REAL POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES. OR TO
PROTECT KIDS ARE WHEN IT COMES
TO PROTECTING THE LIBERTIES OF
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE. I'M NOT
SURE I SEE HOPE YOU'RE- I SEE
FOLKS BANG ON A DRUM THAT CLAIM
TO PROTECT BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE BUT ONCE AGAIN
CRIMINALIZING THEIR CHOICES
WHEN WE SHOULD BE CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES AND SERVE AND
INCENTIVIZING BETTER CHOICES.
EVEN MORE CONFUSING IS THAT
WHILE WE SIT HERE AND LAUNCH
THAT ANY TOBACCO USE IS HARMFUL
THIS BILL CONTAINS A CARVE OUT
FOR A CERTAIN TYPE OF PRODUCT.
FOR NO SCIENTIFIC BASED REASON.
THE PROPONENTS SAY THAT YOU
WOULD THAT YOU WANT TO HELP
MINORITIES FROM DETRIMENTAL
HEALTH IMPACTS THAT ARISE FROM
TOBACCO USE ONLY THEN TO
INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT APPLIES
ONE GROUP OF MINORITIES IS MORE
RESPONSIBLE. THAN ANY OTHER TO
INDULGE IN THOSE PRODUCTS. MY
STRUGGLE LEADING UP TO THIS
HEARING HAS BEEN BASED IN THESE
KIND OF FRUSTRATIONS. AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE. THAT MOVING
FORWARD THAT I CAN SEE THE SAME
ENTHUSIASM AND COMMITMENT TO
LIFTING BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
UP NOT JUST TREATING US OUT
WHENEVER YOU OR WHATEVER OF
THOSE SEE IF IT. HOWEVER I
DECIDED TO VOTE TODAY I HAVE TO
BE HONEST IT'S NOT A WIN FOR
ME. I WILL BE DISAPPOINTED AND
WHATEVER I END UP VOTING TODAY.
BUT I THINK YOU FOR THE HARD
WORK SENATOR I THANK YOU FOR
THE HARD WORK MISTER CHAIR AND
TO ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO SPENT. COUNTLESS TIMES
ASKING ME ABOUT THIS ISSUE I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR SUPPORT
AND CONVERSATION AS WELL. THANK
YOU MISS BURKE MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
THANK SENATOR HILL FOR PUSHING
THIS FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS
THIS IS. AN ISSUE THAT IS BEING
HER UP IN DOWN OR- THERE ARE A
HUNDRED JURISDICTIONS I BELIEVE
THAT HAVE TAKEN SOME SORT OF
POLICY AT THE- LOCAL- THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON FLAVORED TOBACCO
INDOOR ENERVATING AND- THE TIME
IS RIGHT THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE
EPIDEMIC. THERE A COUNTRY
BEFORE KOPET NINETEEN HIT THIS
WAS THE PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC
AND THE ISSUE OF THE DAY ON THE
NEW YORK TIMES DAILY AND FRONT
LINE AS FAR AS WHAT'S HAPPENING
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY. IN URBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MIDDLE AMERICA
IN SCHOOLS UP AND DOWN OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
BATHROOM UP. THE BATHROOMS ARE
LOCAL MIDDLE SCHOOL HERE AT CAL
MIDDLE SCHOOL ON SATURDAY THE
LOCAL PARENTS WERE TELLING
THEIR THEIR THE JUL ROOMS WHERE
KIDS WERE GOING AND ON THEIR
BREAKS HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY
ENGAGE OF FLAVORED TOBACCO. I
SAW APPARENTLY TIME AND THEY
HAD THIS LITTLE HOODIE AND A
LITTLE STRING ON THE HOODIE WAS
A FLAVORED- FLAVORED TOBACCO
THAT DEVICE AND THERE ARE IN
THE CLASSROOM AND SO- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THESE THINGS CAN'T BE
NON FLAVORED AND THAT'S A
REALITY BUT LET'S FACE IT. THE
HOOK. ARE YOU. FOR FLAVORS THAT
ARE JUST ROMANTICIZING WHAT'S
COOL I I'LL NEVER FORGET. LAST
YEAR I TOOK OUR LITTLE GIRLS TO
SELL GIRL SCOUTS APPEAR AT
SAFEWAY THEY'RE TEN YEARS OLD.
AND WEBER MY LITTLE DAUGHTER
VICTORIA SAID DADDY. THAT
CIGARETTE SMELL SO GOOD WHAT
WAS IT. SOMEONE WALKED OUT WITH
VAPING SECOND SMELLED SO GOOD
CIVIC CENTER MANON SOMETHING
ELSE WHICH IS THEY TASTED GOOD
IT SMELLS SO GOOD IT TENURE.
AND I HOPE TO GOD MY KIDS NEVER
GET ADDICTED TO. TOBACCO
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
COMPANIES HAVE ONE MISSION TO
MAKE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
THEIR COMPANIES AND THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS AND THEY HAVE ONE.
BY PRODUCT AND THAT'S KILLING
PEOPLE. THERE'S NO GOOD THAT
COMES OUT OF THIS PRODUCT. THAT
HEALTH COSTS ARE TREMENDOUS AND
WE'LL GET TO THAT THE SECOND
ONE FOR ON THAT. LIKE THIS AND
THAT COMPLICATED THIS IS
BIPARTISAN IN THE SENATE THE
SAME BUILD A STRONGER BILL AT
OR REPUBLICAN SENATORS VOTE FOR
THE- SO I HOPE THAT THIS. HOUSE
ST IS NOT THAT COME. AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BACK HOME THE ONES
YOU CARE ABOUT THIS. ARE
TALKING ABOUT HEALTH MATTERS
CERTAINLY THERE ARE A FEW
BUSINESSES THAT ARE GOING TO
LOSE. MONEY AND PROFITS FOR
THIS BUT WERE MORE ABOUT SAVING
LIVES IN CALIFORNIA HELPING A
FEW BUSINESSES THRIVE SELLING
TOBACCO PRODUCTS THE BILL. THIS
ISSUE TOO IS I THINK VERY
IMPORTANT DURING COPA NINETEEN.
BECAUSE FACE IT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ARE FACING PROBLEMS FROM.
FROM VAPING HAVE HAVE. IMPACTED
I MEAN SYSTEMS AND THERE'S THE
REST OF THE YOUNGER PEOPLE I
WOULD SAY THERE'S A PROBABLY A
BIG CONNECTION WITH PEOPLE WHO
HAVE- VAPING ADDICTION AND
THAT- FRANKLY HAVE SUCCESS OF
IT HAVE HAVE. HER CAR MORE
LIKELY TO DO. OKAY CAN MORE
LIKELY TO BE AT RISK BURKE OF
THE NINETEEN. I WANT TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF THE FINANCES FOR
THIS AND- LET'S FACE IT WE ARE
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WHEN AT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
ARE HAVE TWO DAYS TO LOOK AT
THE HELP THAT. THE LABOR
TOBACCO HURTS. THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS AND OUR KIDS I
THINK THAT THE LAND WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW. AND
IT'S TRUE I SAID THIS WHEN MY
COLLEAGUES LAST NIGHT I DON'T
WANT TO FLIPPANTLY JUST
DISMISS. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE THAT'S MONEY
BUT A TWO HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET. TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE MOST OF
THE TOBACCO TAX MONEY IS ONE
TIME RIGHT. THE INCOMING MONEY
TO FIRST FIVE BODIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THESE FIRST FIVE
BODIES WHO SUPPORT THIS BILL
HAVE SAID THEY WILL GLADLY GO
OUT OF BUSINESS TOMORROW. THEY
USE THEIR MIND. AND FOR THESE
pTHINGS LIKE EARLY EDUCATION AND
HEALTH CARE FOCUSING ON KIDS
ZERO TWO FIVE THEY KNOW IT'S A
DECLINING REVENUE SOURCE. THEY
DON'T USE ANY OTHER MONEY TO
FUND ON GOING THINKS THERE'S
NOT MONEY TO FUND OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM NOT MONEY FOR
KATE NOT MONEY FOR EARLY AT.
BECAUSE IT'S ALL. ONE TIME AND
IS THE- GRANTED LAST YEAR. WE
HAVE A NOW ATTACKS ON THE FOR.
THAT HAS IT AS GET SO THIS IS A
GREAT TO DO THIS BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT TO BE A LOSS OR
SOMETHING ISN'T REAL. I WILL
TWO OF THE FULL EFFECT YET SO
AS FAR AS THE IMPACT FOR OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR OUR- IT'S
MINIMAL. SENATOR DOLE SAID THE
SAVINGS ARE TEN TWENTY TIME
GREATER IS AS WHAT YOU WITH
WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY THESE
TREMENDOUS COST TO OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AND MEDIC COW- SO
THIS IS THIS IS RIGHT FOR SO
MANY REASONS I WOULD HAVE
PREFERRED THAT THE OF THE OTHER
PERSON BUT THIS IS A LIBERTY OF
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND I FULLY
RESPECT OUR OUR CHAIR AND OUR-
SENATOR- YOU KNOW WORKING ON
THIS SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE NIGHT HAD THE SAME DAY LAST
YEAR THIS YEAR WE DECIDED TO GO
WITH ONE DEAL WITH WITH THE
BILL HERE BEFORE CITY ITSELF
CERTAINLY PROUD TO BE A JOY
AUTHORS AND I WANT ADDRESS
WHOLE. THEY SAY THE VISION I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A YOU TO SAVE
THEY WERE GONNA BE ARRESTING.
FOR USING THIS PRODUCT FOR
SMOKING A MENTHOL CIGARETTES
WERE SAYING THAT NO LONGER
COULD PEOPLE SELL THE PRODUCT.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ARRESTING PEOPLE FOR
POSSESSION. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MEET THE INCREASING PENALTIES
FOR ANY OF THAT. BUT I DO THINK
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG
IN OUR SYSTEM WOULD HAVE IF YOU
HAVE A LIQUOR STORE AND YOU CAN
LEGALLY SELL BOOZE TO A MINOR.
YOU GET POPPED ONCE OR TWICE
YOU LOSE YOUR LIQUOR LICENSE
AND AS A SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
BUT IF YOU'RE A- CONVENIENCE
STORE. AND YOU HAVE MULTIPLE OF
SELLINGTO MINORS THERE'S NOT
THAT CONSEQUENCES THAT NOW
THEY'RE BUILT ANOTHER DAY I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO GO AND
ADDRESS THAT I THINK WE DID
HAVE SOME PARITY ON THAT. THERE
IS NO DISINCENTIVE FOR
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR- BUT IN
SOME THE TIME IS RIGHT FOR US
TO DO THIS IN CALIFORNIA- AGAIN
WHERE THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. AND
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A OF A MOST AND- ON THIS
BILL MISTER JACK. THANK MCCARTY.
THAT'S CORRECT. PERMISSION TO
READ. COURSE THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO READ A LITTLE BIT ON
THE FISCAL IMPACT FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT STATE
THAT THE ESTIMATED TAX REVENUE
LOSS OF THIS BILLIS A HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION THIS FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
FROM CIGARETTES TO MILLION FROM
TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN MILLION
FOR NEXT YEAR'S FISCAL YEAR.
THE FIRST ENTIRE FISCAL YEAR
THAT THE BAND WILL BE IN EFFECT
IN ADDITION THE SOCI TAX SALES
LOST THIS OF ANY SIX POINT
MILLION TWELVE MILLION TO THE
RURAL FIVE FIFTY AT THE-
SOMEONE SO. ALL OF THAT IS
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF US TO BE
ABLE TO DIGEST. I BRING THAT UP
BECAUSE THIS BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED- AND BROUGHT TO THIS
HOUSE FOR US TO VOTE ON- IN AND
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I
DON'T THINK THERE IS ANYONE IN
THIS FLOOR RIGHT NOW OR IN BOTH
HOUSES. THAT AGREE WITH THE
CRISIS ON YOUTH KEEPING
EVERYONE WANTS TO SEE THAT MOVE
FORWARD I HAVE NOT SPOKEN TO
ANYONE MEMBER. IN EITHER HOUSE
AND IN EITHER PARTY OR ONE
PARTY. THAT DISAGREES WITH. I
BUT THIS IDEA THAT ONLY BECAUSE
THIS IS A- POLICY COMMITTEE.
DURING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC THAT
WE WILL NOT THINK ABOUT THE
FISCAL IMPACT JUST SEEMS A
LITTLE. UNORTHODOX AND A
LITTLE- NARROW MINDED NEXT
YEAR. WE WILL BE FACED WITH AN
MASSIVE REVENUE LOSS WE WILL BE
ASKED TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
THINGS TO CUT. I THINK THAT MY
COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
THOSE CONCERNS ARE ALREADY
THINKING ABOUT THAT. SO NEXT
YEAR WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
BUDGET. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
THINK OKAY DO WE CUT FUNDS FROM
CHILD CARE. DO WE CUT FUNDS
FROM TEACHERS NURSES I JUST
THAT'S PROGRAM WHICH HELPS
SENIORS AND THOSE ITH
DISABILITIES. THOSE ARE REAL
CUTS THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FACE. TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION MAY SEEM LIKE A DROP IN
THE BUCKET IN A BUDGET THAT'S
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. BUT FOR
NONPROFITS AND FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS BACK HOME THAT IS
A LOT OF MONEY. AND SO I FIND
MYSELF IN A VERY STRANGE
SITUATION OF HAVING TO BRING
CERTAIN THINGS UP AND HAVE BEEN
ASKING QUESTIONS AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE IT. CLEAR TO THE
MEMBERS OF OUR HOUSE AND THE
OTHER HOUSE- TO THE ADVOCATES
TO THE LOBBYIST. ALL OF US THAT
ARE SITTING IN THESE CHAIRS
RIGHT NOW IN THIS AMAZING
INCREDIBLE SPACE. HAVE A RIGHT
A DUTY AND OBLIGATION. AND
QUITE FRANKLY A PRIVILEGE. TO
BE ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS. SO
WHEN YOUR RESPONSE ME WHEN I AM
ASKING THE QUESTION IS WHY
AREN'T YOU AUTOMATICALLY WITH
US. I HAVE ANY PROBLEM WITH
THAT. BECAUSE IT IS MY JOB TO
ASK QUESTIONS IT IS MY JOB TO
UNDERSTAND IT IS MY JOB TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE MOVING POLICY.
THAT MAKES SENSE. SO I'M GLAD
AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I HAVE HAD
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING BILL TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE FOR THE- ISSUES THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN A- I THINK
THE VAPING ISSUE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ADDRESS WE
HAD A BILL. IN THIS HOUSE. THAT
WAS REFERRED TO A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE THAT WAS REFERRED-
I'M SORRY THAT DID NOT GET
REFERRED. ON THE SENATE SIDE-
THAT ACTUALLY ADDRESS SOME OF
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT FROM A MEMBER OF
THIS HOUSE. AND I'VE HAD TO
EXPLAIN TO SOME FOLKS. SOME
TERMINOLOGY THAT IS USED ON THE
STREET IN TERMS OF WHAT IS A
BLUNT. I HAVE TO I HAVE A
COUPLE OF MEMBERS AND- THEY
DIDN'T KNOW. SO WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND IT'S A LITTLE
FUNNY MAYBE BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. YOU
KNOW I THINK IT YOUR WHATEVER
THAT IS USED BY YOUNG PEOPLE
AND ADULTS THAT HAVE CLEARED
OUT AND THEN YOU PUT A CANNABIS
AND IT. OR WE'D IN IT RIGHT.
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY SMOKING
A CIGARETTE THE OTHER SMOKING A
BLUNT BECAUSE THAT'S JUST THE
WAY THAT SOCIETY WORKS. AND THE
FACT THAT WE ARE PASSING
LEGISLATION. ON TOBACCO- AND
NOT KNOW EXACTLY HOW IT IS THAT
PEOPLE USE IT. IS JUST MIND
BOGGLING TO ME BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE BEYOND. THIS CAPITOL
THIS BUILDING. THAT ARE GOING
TO BE LOOKING TO US THINKING
WHAT ARE YOU DOING. BUT THERE
IS A BIGGER THERE IS A BIGGER
GOAL- I'M ACTUALLY SURPRISED WE
HAVEN'T INCLUDED FLAVORED
CANNABIS IN THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THAT IS ALSO SOMETHING.
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE USING BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT VAPING AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TOBACCO NOW
I HOPE THE MOMENTUM. FOR FEVER
CANNABIS IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT IN THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE THAT IS ALSO AN ISSUE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE IN THEIR
BATHROOMS AT HIGH SCHOOLS THAT
I HAVE HEARD DIRECTLY. FROM
YOUNG STUDENTS IN MY COMMUNITY
AND MY DISTRICT ON THE OVER. A
CELL IS ILLEGAL CANNABIS
DISPENSARY IS THAT JUST POP IN
IN AND OUT. AND SO IF THE ISSUE
REALLY IS TO ADDRESS. TEEN
VAPING AND TEEN CONSUMPTION
THEN I HOPE THAT THAT'S A
CONVERSATION AND THE POLITICAL
COURAGE THAT WE CAN ALSO
INCLUDE ONE LOOK AT.
LEGISLATION IN THE FUTURE SO
AGAIN THANK YOU- TO THE CHAIR
INTO THE AUTHOR FOR THE
CONVERSATION- I DO BELIEVE
THAT- THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- BUT I JUST AGAIN
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO
EVERYONE THAT IT IS OUR JOB AND
OUR OBLIGATION OR DUTY TO ASK
QUESTIONS. AND THINK ABOUT THE
HOLISTIC WAY IN WHICH WE DO
POLICY AND A HOLISTIC WAY IN
WHICH WE LOOK AT HOW THE BUDGET
IS IMPACTED AND WILL BE
IMPACTING THE COMMUNITY MOVING
FORWARD NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- CENTER THANK
YOU- WAS GREAT TALKING TO YOU
EARLIER TODAY- A LOT OF WHAT I
SAID HAS ALREADY BEEN STATED
AND I DO WANT TO REITERATE A
COUPLE THINGS THOUGH BECAUSE I
DO FIND IT FASCINATING. THAT WE
ARE THE FATHER OF TWO KIDS- WE
ARE TASKED TO PROTECT OUR KIDS
AND- LIKE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SADDAM SACRAMENTO HERE. WHEN
YOU GO INTO A STORE AND YOU
SMELL WAIT. I ACTUALLY CAN'T
TELL THE DIFFERENCE WHETHER
IT'S NICOTINE OR TOBACCO INDOOR
CANNABIS I CAN'T. SO IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT PROTECTING YOUTH FROM
VAPING. I DO FIND IT
FASCINATING THAT WE HAVE NOT
BROUGHT IN CANNABIS INTO THIS
DISCUSSION. YOU GO INTO A
DISPENSARY IT'S IKE ****
WONKA'S CHOCOLATE FACTORY. THEY
GOT FLAVORS ALL OVER THE PLACE
STOP THE DON'T EVEN SOUND GOOD
TO ADULTS. BUT NONE THE LESS
THEY'RE SELLING AND YOU CAN'T
TELL ME. MARKETED TO ADULTS.
NOT HAPPENING BUT SOMEHOW.
WE'VE ALLOWED THE CAMERAS
INDUSTRY JUST TO GO OFF AND DO
THEIR THING AND I'M NOT EXACTLY
POSE BUT I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT AE SMOKING
CANNABIS OR CBD SIDE OF THINGS.
AS PRIMARILY THE THC SIDE
CANNABIS IS WHAT THEY'RE
WORKING FOR. SAID I WASN'T VERY
VERY CONCERNING TO ME AS WELL
AS THE HOOKAH ASPECT OF THIS WE
EXEMPTED HOOKAH IN THE ORIGINAL
BILL. WHAT I FIND INTERESTING
BECAUSE RIGHT BEHIND BEING
HOOKAH IS THE NUMBER TO. HAS A
NUMBER TO A NUMBER OF YOU DOING
IT. NOT TO MENTION THAT THE
RUNNING AROUND WITH ESSENTIALLY
A BALL WITH TUBES OUT OF IT
FEDERAL SUCKING ON AN X.
SPECIALLY IN THE BEEN A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH WE'RE JUST SIX. EXPECTING
THEM TO SAY THAT DOES
EVERYTHING. GOING TO HAPPEN. I
AM VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT. AS WELL AS THE ECONOMIC
LOSS OF TAX REVENUE LOST TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WE'RE
MOVING FORWARDS BEEN SAID A
COUPLE TIMES WITH. TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT WE HAVE
JUST THROWN OUT THE DOOR IF
THIS THING PASSES AND RIGHT NOW
IN THE STATE THAT IS
DESPERATELY. TRYING TO FIND A
REVENUE STREAM. WE'RE GOING TO
WHACK. AND ALLOW TO GO TO
MEDICAL AND GUESS WHOSE
DISTRICT HAS A LOT OF MEDICARE.
RECIPIENTS OF MINE AND I KNOW A
LOT OF YOURS DO AS WELL SO WHAT
ARE WE GONNA GO I THOUGHT REAL
HARD LAST YEAR TO KEEP IT IT
SERVICES IN AMERICA. MAYBE
THAT'S GONE SO THE DIABETIC
PATIENTS SUFFER SO WE'RE
PICKING THESE WINNERS AND WE'RE
PICKING THESE LOSERS. AND I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AND
THAT IS WHY I DO WANT TO
PRESENT A SET OF AMENDMENTS I
KNOW THERE WAS A MOTION MADE.
SO I WANT TO MAKE SUBSTITUTE
MOTION. FOR A SET OF AMENDMENTS
THAT TAKE THIS BILL. FROM A
TOBACCO BAN FLAVORED TOBACCO
BAN INTO A 1100% FLAVORED VAPE
BAN AND EXCLUSIVELY JOB TITLE
STARTED HAS PROBABLY THE MOMENT
I WOULD ASK PASSED THOSE OUT
NOW I MEAN WE CAN. TO MAKE A
MOTION TO ADOPT. OKAY SO YOU
HAVE A MOTION FOR WAS TOO LATE
ON THE DRAW. IS THERE A SECOND
TIER MOTION. THE ORDER DID MISS
WALDRON SECONDS MOTION. THE
CONCERT BUT YOU DID. I'D LIKE
TO MAKE MY MOTION TO TABLE
AMENDMENTS. SO CHEN TO TABLE
THE AMENDMENT SO THAT IS NOT
AVAILABLE THAT WIRES THAT WE-
MAYBE YOU CAN EXPLORE. WE HAVE
A MOAT HE HAS A MOTION. WHICH
WAS. AND THEN MISS LIMóN MADE
A MOTION TO TABLE AMENDMENTS
AND THAT WAS SECONDED BY MR-
MCCARTY. SO THE MOTION ON THE
TABLE IS TO LADY AMENDMENTS
OKAY THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO
LADY AMENDMENTS- CHAIR ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THE LADY
AMENDMENTS THAT WAS. PRESENTED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA. LEFT
THE CALL NOW OKAY. SORRY WE
ALREADY HAVE A MOTION THAT'S
BEEN SECONDED FOR THE BILL CAN
BE INTRODUCED ANOTHER MOTION AT
THIS POINT I'D LIKE THERE WAS A
MOTION YOU CAN MAKE A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION. SO.
SURGICALLY HASSLES MINISTRY
PASTEL SO WE HAD A WE HAD A
MOTION AND NOW WE HAVE A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION WHICH IS
ALLOWED I BELIEVE I UNDERSTAND.
AND WE'RE ASKING TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE. AND
I'M ASKING SO MY ASK IS TO- I'M
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. WHICH
WILL ALLOW US TO PROCEED WITH
THE ORIGINAL MOTION. AND SAID
THAT. READ MR FOR MOTION.
VICTOR SO CHAIR IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MATT SECRETARY
CALDERON PLEASE MOTION TO LADY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE. A
CHAIR RECOMMENDS AND I WOULD I
WOULD I MAYES. MAYES NO
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA
I BURKE. BURKE I CARILLO.
CORREO HI FLORA NO FLORA NO
ONLY MON LIMóN I MCCARTY
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
RAMOS. RAMOS OUTSIDE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON WALDRON NOW. SO THE
ORIGINAL MOTION IS BEFORE US.
ELEVEN ICE FOR KNOWS MOTION BY
MISS LIMóN PASSES AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN TABLED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I DO HAVE A
COUPLE MORE- JUST STATEMENT THE
CALLER OF COURSE. AND I WOULD
LIKE US IN THE RIGHT I KNOW
HE'S ON THE PHONE AND HAS BEEN
TRYING TO GET IN A COUPLE TIMES
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU A
VERY SIMPLE QUESTION SO IF WE
COULD- BRING HIM ON THE LINE.
BUT THERE IS A- YOUNG MAN- I
KNOW ONCE AGAIN THE CINEMA FROM
SACRAMENTO MAY COMMENT THAT HE
DOES NOT KNOW OF ANY. YOU KNOW
BODY THAT'S BEEN ARRESTED
BECAUSE OF ILLEGAL. CIGARETTE
SALES AND GUIDING THEIR
GARDENING OR- WE SAID
POSSESSION. THIS IS WHAT I'M
I'M WORRIED ABOUT. LIKE THESE
FOLKS. WHEREVER THEY ARE. IF
THEY WANT TO BUY THIS IF THEY
HAVE AN A PROBLEM. THEY'RE
GOING TO GET THIS PRODUCT. WE
KNOW THIS WE DO ACROSS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS SO I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THIS WE'RE GOING TO
CREATE. ANALYST AT MARKET WITH
THE SODA HUGE HUGE CONCERN THAT
I HAVE I'M NOT GOING TO ALLOW
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FROM
SOMEBODY OUTSIDE THIS IS THE
ARCHITECT OPTED FOR MEMBERS TO
DELIBERATE MISTER RIGHT. COULD
HAVE BEEN A WITNESS HE COULD
HAVE BEEN A WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS HE WAS HE WAS NOT. HE
HE DID HE DID OFFERING ME TO-
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
S. FOR THE MEMBERS TO
DELIBERATE- LOOK THIS BILL AND
I WOULD JUST SAY THIS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT CRIMINALIZE THIS
WE HAD A BILL BEFORE US LAST
YEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE. THAT
DID PRIOR TO MY AMENDMENTS THAT
PULLED ALL THE CRIMINALIZATION
ITEMS OUT OF THAT. WE HAD A
MEMBER WHO WANTED TO
CRIMINALIZE. THIS ISSUE AND I
PULL THAT OUT. THIS BILL DOES
NOT CRIMINALIZE THIS ISSUE. IT
DOES NOT DO THAT AND I THINK
IT'S A RED HERRING AND I AND TO
IMPLY THAT IT DOES IS NOT NOT
CORRECT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
AUTHOR IT DOESN'T BUT IT DOES
YEP MAGIC MIGHT CREATE A BLACK
MARKET WE DON'T KNOW IS THAT A
POSSIBILITY. WE DON'T KNOW.
THIS STILL SOMEONE COULD STILL
BUY THESE PRODUCTS ONLINE. IF
THEY HAVE TO DO IT AND THEY
COULD STILL BUY IT ONLINE THIS
DOES NOT RESTRICT THAT. BUT IT
DOES. PREVENT THE ATTRACTIVE
NUISANCE. OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO SPONTANEOUSLY FIND A
WAY TO GET A PRODUCT IN A
CONVENIENCE STORE. THAT'S THE
GOAL HERE AND SO I THOUGHT I'D
AND THAT IS MY DEPARTMENT
THAT'S MY BUT I. YOU KNOW AND
YOU KNOW NO AND I EVERY DRIVERS
STRUCTURE OPINION ON. THIS AND
I DO WORRY THOUGH BECAUSE IF WE
STILL CAN BUY ONLINE AS WELL AS
CASINOS I THINK IS IN THE BILL
AS WELL CORRECT. WE DO NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY OVER SOVEREIGN
NATIONS SO. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
PEOPLE RUNNING UP TO WHEREVER
OR BUYING ONLINE. CARTONS AT A
TIME. AND SELL THEM ON STREET
CORNERS LIKE THAT IS A CONCERN
BECAUSE NOT EVERYBODY HAS
ACCESS ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES DO ALL THE STUFF.
SO THERE IS A CONCERN TO THIS-
AND I WILL I'VE BEEN TALKING TO
LONG. TIME JUST FINE AND YOU
KNOW I THINK YOU ALSO KNOW- MR
FOR THAT THE WORK WE DO HERE IS
NEVER CARVED IN STONE. AND IF
THERE AREN'T UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES I FULLY HOPE THAT
THIS BODY. SENATE WILL BENEFIT
THE CONSEQUENCES- BUT AT THIS
POINT I WOULD HAVE TO STATE
IT'S SOMEWHAT HYPOTHETICAL
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A OF THAT
DONE EVERYTHING. SUCH THAT
MINIMIZE MY SUB THANK A TEACHER
THANK REST FOR ME AFTER MAYES I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE KIND
OF AWKWARD SITTING AT THERE ARE
GOING TO TALK TO THE SENATOR.
OKAY THE NORTH WORSHIP BAND.
THE BILL FOR OF THEM. AIMS
OFTENTIMES IN COMMITTEE WHERE
WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A REAL
DEBATE AND REAL CONVERSATION
THAT IT'S ALL. DONE BEFOREHAND
AND WITH THAT THE PANDEMIC AND
THE WAY THAT WE HAD TO OPERATE-
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE ALLOWING THIS A
SORT OF. OF CONVERSATION- I'VE
GOT AN AWFUL LOT TO SAY BECAUSE
IT SEEMS LIKE OVER THE LAST
WEEK TWO WEEKS I'VE HAD A LOT
OF. A CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
AND THIS IS A- AN ISSUE FOR ME
THAT I TEND TO- HAVE CONFLICT
BETWEEN HEAD AND HEART. ON IT-
BECAUSE- FROM A PHILOSOPHICAL
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW I WANT TO
ADVANCE LIBERTY I WANT PEOPLE
TO MAKE DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES- I DON'T LIKE A
TOBACCO I KNOW THAT'S AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF. OF
DAMAGE. AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE DOCTORS THERE'S HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND NO. THE CHAIR-
HAS SEEN THIS FIRST HAND AS A-
AS A DENTIST WHERE HE'S SEEN
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD CHIU OR
WHATEVER ELSE THAT HAS HAD
INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF IMPACT
AND ORAL CANCER- THAT'S THAT'S
COME FROM THAT WHEN YOU. WHEN
YOU YOU SEE THAT FIRST HAND.
ARE YOU BEGIN TO A HAS AN
IMPACT HAS IMPACT ON YOUR
PSYCHE TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON
WHAT YOU. ON ON WHEN YOU BECOME
ABOUT A MEMBER ELECTED OFFICIAL
MAKES YOU WANT TO GO HAVE A
HAVE SOME CHANGE. BUT THE ONE
THING I WOULD LIKE TO SAID I DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU THE
SENATOR IS. THE ONE THING I
HAVEN'T ENJOYED OVER THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH- MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS IS THE- ME
SOME OF THE- HOMINEM ATTACK
THAT HAVE BEEN- BEEN. LAW STAFF
AT ONE AND OTHER I'M THINKING
THAT WAY PARTICULAR CHAIR. IS
DOING IT. HE'S. TO TECH
CANNABIS OR- OTHER PARTICULAR
CHAIR BE. HE'S TO HAVE BACK OF
BIG TOBACCO OR- THIS NUMBER
DOESN'T LIE THIS BE. OF ONE OR
THIS MA'AM DOESN'T LIKE THIS
BECAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER REASON.
WHAT I FOUND IN MY
COMPENSATION- WITH ALL OF YOU.
THERE'S A SENSE. CONCERT ABOUT
THIS AND YET THE SAME TIME I
THINK YOU'RE STRUCK LIKE I AM A
BETWEEN. THE IN. ALL THIS
BECAUSE THE BILL AS IT'S- A
WE'VE SEEN. I DON'T KNOW LOVE
BUT I DO KNOW THAT WHEN I GONE.
BACK TO MY DISTRICT AND I'VE
GUY INTO TOUR OF THE HIGH
SCHOOLS WHEN I'VE SPOKEN TO
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND YOU
TALK TO THEIR STUDENT RUN. TO
NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT I'VE SEEN
IN EVERY HIGH SCHOOL TO BRING
UP. THE FACT OF VAPING. AND
THERE'S A QUESTION I HAVE IS
LIKE WAIT A MINUTE ISN'T
ILLEGAL ALREADY FOR YOU KIDS TO
BE ABLE TO ACQUIRE. A VAPING
ISN'T ALREADY- DON'T YOU HAVE
TO BE TWENTY ONE TO BE ABLE TO.
TO BUY THAT AND YET KIDS ARE
GETTING IT- DONE. AND OF COURSE
WE ALSO KNOW. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT. THE FLAVORS ARE APPEALING
TO THE THESE KEY AND HAVE MADE
IT. MADE IT COOL SO I ALL OF
THAT KEY. ARE GETTING IT AND IT
IS A AT A CRISIS STAGE AND AS
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS AS
POLICYMAKERS. WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING OF IT. AT THE SAME
TIME A CONCERN FOR ME AND I'VE
MADE- THIS OF THIS ARGUMENT IN
REGARDS TO YOU KNOW THE SEVENTY
FIVE OR EIGHT YEAR OLD FORMER
NAVY VET. THAT ARE. CAN PI AND
HIS FAVORITE. I'M HIS FAVORITE
TOBACCO OF ANY SAYS BLACK
CHERRY. I FOR ME REALLY GOING
TO TAKE AWAY THAT BLACK CHERRY
TO. FROM THE FORMER NAY VETS
SMOKING FOR THE LAST FORTY THAT
DOESN'T MEAN. TO ME. NIGHT THAT
HE WON BY EVEN IF THE THIS BILL
PASSES SINGLE BY THAT LINE A
RIGHT CAN DO THAT. YOU KNOW I'M
GOING TO THE STORE FOR THREE
YEARS AND- IN ESSENCE A WE
WOULD BE. THAT AWAY WHICH I
LEADS ME TO WHAT I'VE BEEN TALK
MORE THAN I. TO DO SO PLEASE ME
FORGIVE ME. I'D LIKE TO. SET UP.
FROM SEPT TO BROUGHT THIS TO
SOME OF ISSUES WHY IT. WE AND
YOU RAISE THE ISSUE OF HOW CAN
SOMEONE SINCE PURCHASE IF
YOU'RE A MINOR A PRODUCT THAT
YOU CAN'T BUY IT FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS OLD. BUT THE RECENT
SURVEYS THAT WERE DONE SHOWED
THAT 74% OR 71% OF THOSE. WHO
PURCHASED JUHL PODS AND JUUL
PRODUCTS WERE UNDER THAT. 71%
WERE ABLE TO BUY IN A STORE
WHERE IT WAS. ILLEGAL TO
PURCHASE THOSE PRODUCTS. AND
WHEN HAVE STING OPERATIONS BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THEY FIND IT 50%
IS WHAT THE- BY RATE HAS BEEN
WITH THOSE MINERS SO WHATEVER
WE'RE DOING IS NOT WORKING. SO
THE IDEA OF TRYING TO FIND A
WAY TO STOP. BIG TOBACCO FROM
INCENTIVIZING AND ADDICTING
CHILDREN WHICH HAS THE HIGHEST
RATE IN NATURAL WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CANNABIS AND I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION. BUT THE RATE
OF CANNABIS ADDICTION IS ABOUT
NINE POINT ONE PERCENT. ALCOHOL
IS ABOUT FIFTEEN POINT 4% OF
USE. TOBACCO THIRTY ONE POINT
9% ADDICTIVE REYES SAID THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
AVERAGE IN THE BEGINNING AGE OF
A SMOKER IS THIRTEEN YEARS OF
AGE. I TOOK MY FIRST. I THINK
DRAGONESS AT WHATEVER COLLEGE
RECORD I THINK I WAS ABOUT
THIRTEEN. TASTED SO BAD I WOULD
NEVER TOUCH IT AGAIN. BUT IF IT
HAD THE COOLNESS OF PEOPLE. OR
THAT MEANT WHICH IS WHAT THE
FOR WITH THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
ATTRACTING THEM THAT'S WHAT'S
GETTING THEM ENGAGE THAT'S
WHAT'S GETTING THEM. ADDICTED
AND AT THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE YOU
NEVER SEE ANYONE I DON'T KNOW
OF ANYONE THE TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY YEARS A EVADE WAKES UP
IN THE MORNING SAYS. I THINK
I'M GONNA START SMOKING TODAY.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN. SO THEY GET
THEM WHEN THEY'RE ON. A TRACK
THEM WITH THE FLAVORS. AND THEN
THERE HOPE FOR LIFE AND THEN
THE KILL AT SOME POINT ALONG
THE WAY. THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT IN THIS BILL THAT WE
ATTRACTED WE GET THE FLAVORS.
AND THAT WE GET THEM YOUNG. AND
THAT WE DO IT NOW WITH TOBACCO
AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT CANNABIS AND
THE OTHER THING I'M OVERWHELMED
FRANKLY WITH WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY I MET MY
CLOSEST PAGES OF TRYING TO
ARGUE THE POINT AND BRING IT
HOME I DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT. I
MEAN THIS IS I AM SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE CONVERSATION. SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE HEARTFELT
FEELINGS. THAT I'VE HEARD
TODAY. AND THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE IN THE FUTURE WITH
THIS ON THE REVENUE. FOR
CANNABIS. FOR THE ISSUES OF
TRYING TO DEAL WITH ALL OF THIS
IS THAT THE NUANCES THAT ARE
DEVELOPED IM SORRY I WON'T BE
HERE TO HELP YOU WITH IT. SO
SANTA CAN I TALK ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SOME
LANGUAGE- ABOUT SOME BUS.OTHER
EXEMPTIONS- THAT HAVE BEEN.
BROUGHT BEFORE US- I JUST
BEFORE THE MEETING I TRIED. TO
CALL THIS A LITTLE BIT ACCEDED
TO THE- A THIRD OF SEPTEMBER.
BROUGHT UP I REALIZE THAT I.
BIGGEST ON A TO BACK AND
TOBACCO RELATED ITEMS WHEN SHE
REFERRED TO YOU- THE BLUNT THAT
WAS ME. I DIDN'T I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT- SO I I'M NOT A STREET
SMART AS I THOUGHT THAT THAT
THAT I WAS- I GUESS I DON'T
REALLY THINK I WAS THAT SMART
ABOUT. STUFF ABOUT BEING STREET
SMART. BUT SO WE THE ONE WE'VE
GOT THE HOOKAH EXAM SHIFT AND I
SHARED WITH YOU ON THE PHONE
TODAY- MY EXPERIENCE AND HAVE
LEARNED ABOUT THE HOOKAH AND
THE CULTURE OF SURROUNDING
HOOKAH- OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WE DON'T NEED TO GO INTO
THAT. BUT NOW WE'VE GOT A
COUPLE OF OTHER EXEMPTIONS.
BEFORE I. WENT TO REGARD THE
PREMIUM CIGARS WHICH WE THINK
REALLY ONLY. ARE USING PREMIUM
CIGARS. WE'VE ALSO GOT AN
EXEMPTION FOR A PIPE THE- LOOSE
LEAF PIPE TO BE AT IT'S IS IT'S
CRAFTED. SO THE QUESTION THAT I
HAVE IS WE'VE EXEMPTED HOOKAH.
WE'VE EXEMPTED PIPE THAT
TOBACCO. AND WE'VE ALSO- BOTH
AND PREMIUM CIGARS FROM THIS
BAND. IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE
THAT NEEDS TO BE EXEMPTED THAT.
WE KNOW ABOUT THAT MAKE. MORE
RIGHT. THE GOALIE. IS THE WITH
KIDS RIGHT WE WANT TO STOP KIDS
FROM GETTING HOOKED ON THIS.
BUT THERE ARE PRODUCTS TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THAT ADULTS USE ARE
THERE UP PRODUCT WE SHOULD ALL
PUT IN. TO MAKE THIS BILL A
BETTER BILL I'M NOT AWARE. IN
THE ISSUE AT THE EXIT. AND WHAT
WHAT CONVERT THAT. I'VE HAD
WITH SOME OF THE MEN. THIS
COMMITTEE AND WHERE THE- SHINJI
AVAILABLE WE DO HEARD ABOUT
TODAY YOU HAVE TO WAIT RISKS
WHAT IS THE OF YOUTH GETTING
THAT PRODUCT AND BECOMING
ADDICTED TO IT AND THEN HOOK A
VERY LIMITED IN LOW RISK. S.
PREMIUM CIGARS OVER TWELVE
DOLLARS VERY LOW RISK. AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE IDEA PACKAGE
FOR- TOBACCO GROUND TOBACCO OR
RELIEF TOBACCO. IT FOR PIPES
ANOTHER VERY LOW RISK AND IT
WILL BE CRAFTED I BELIEVE IN A
WAY THAT WILL NOT INSTANCE.
INCENTIVIZE THE USE IN OTHER
TYPES OR FORMS OF- OF PRODUCTS
SO I LOOK AT THE RISK FACTOR IN
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME AND WAS CERTAINLY THE
AMENDMENTS WERE MY CHOICE. OF I
HEARD ABOUT THAT ABOUT THEM
TODAY I'M WILLING TO ACCEPT
THOSE BECAUSE I THINK AS WE
KNOW POLITICS IN THIS BUILDING
THIS CALL. IN HIS TO ACCEPT.
THE LOOSE LEAF ON THE DEAF AND
TALKING HYPED AS LOOSE LEAF A
INCLUDE A LOOSE LEAF CHU POINT
THAT U. S. W. W. WOULD YOU
WRITE DOWN ON THE TOBACCO OVER
ON THAT YOU WOULD SUCK ON THE
BALCONY OF THE JUICES
UNDERMINES IN IT DOES NOT. I
WOULD HAVE. TALK TO THE CHAIR
ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
AND ARE THERE ANY OTHER
EXEMPTIONS AT ALL FOR ANY
CESSATION BISA THE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS. THAT ARE GETTING
PEOPLE OFF OF ACCO OTHER ANY
OTHER FLAVOR THAT MIGHT AND
DIVIDE THEY KEEP THEIR SOME
**** I THINK IT WILL BE. SOLD
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF IN THE
FACT THIS IS A DEVICE IF YOU
WANT TO BE. AS A IN. IN CALL
YOUR THIS IS IT DEVICE THAT
DRUG HAS APPROACH THAT YOU GO
THROUGH TO BE FOR THAT AND NONE
OF THE PRODUCTS THAT WE'VE SEEN
TALKED ABOUT OR USED BY YOUTH
TODAY OR CLAIM TO BE CESSATION
DEVICES ARE ACTUALLY.
LEGITIMATE LICENSED CESSATION
DEVICES OKAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
THAT TEACHER THANK YOU. OH I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY MISTER NAZARIAN
APOLOGIZED. ON I'M SORRY I JUST
WANT TO STAND UP AND STRETCH MY
LEGS A LITTLE BIT BEFORE I NO
GO AHEAD MISS AGUIAR-CURRY AND
THEN MISTER NAZARIAN TURN TO
MAKE IT A QUICK IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY SENATOR I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWAR- YOU KNOW IN A
PERFECT WORLD WE WOULD HAVE HAD
THIS VETTED WITHOUT MULTIPLE
MEETINGS. AND HERE WE ARE AND
WE ALL ARE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS ISSUE PARTICULARLY
FOR KIDS IN VAPING. AND WE ARE
IN THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. AND SO
I JUST THAT THEN I'VE TOLD SO
MANY FOR PEOPLE TO COME INTO MY
OFFICE A CALL MAY BE EITHER
SIDE IS THAT GOSH IF IT WAS MY
WAY. REGIS TO VAPING AND
FLAVORED THE- OF VAPING IN
JEWEL AND JUST KEEP IT SUPER
SIMPLE SO WE CAN ADDRESS THESE
KIDS. BECAUSE NOW WE'VE MUDDIED
THE WATER AND THERE'S A LOT OF.
CONVERSATION IS STILL NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN PLACE I THINK I MEAN I
THINK THAT- MISTER FLORA AND
OTHERS OF. THIS HEART GOES OUT
AND I THINK THERE'S PART THAT I
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE BROUGHT
THIS FORWARD. AND EVERYONE'S
OPINIONS IMPORTANT. AND THIS IS
TEARING ME APART BECAUSE I SEE
THE IMPORTANCE AND MY CONCERNS
I HAVE GRANDCHILDREN I HAVE
CHILDREN I'VE GOT MY NIECES AND
NEPHEWS TO TELL ME WHAT'S GOING
ON THE FAVORITE. AT A BREAK MY
HEART AND- THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO THE SCHOOL DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO AND SO- YOU KNOW I'M
REALLY CONFLICTED. A REALLY
CONFLICTED AND I WAS VERY CLEAR
WITH YOU ON THIS BEFORE- I'M
GONNA BE HONEST I'M GONNA
SUPPORT YOU TODAY BUT I NEED
YOU TO KEEP KEEP WORKING ON
THEM. AND I'M AND I SIT RIGHT.
AND I MAY NOT. A SUPPORT YOU
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FLOOR BUT
IT'S NEEDS MORE WORK- IT'S- THE
WATER THAT MUDDIED ON THIS. I
FAMILIES WERE IS JUST CAN BE
ONE. OF OKAY AND NOW IT'S KIND
OF ONE OF THOSE CAN FIGURE SO I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS AWFUL. BERMAN YOU HAVE A
WORK TO THIS FOR A LONG. ALSO
SOME MEMBER WORKED ON THIS A
LONG TIME AND THERE'S SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO MAKE IT
RIGHT. AND IT'S SO HARD TO DO
SO I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU.
AND ALL THE COMMENTS TODAY I'M-
I REALIZE THAT MY COLLEAGUES
AND REALLY CARE ABOUT OUR
YOUTH. AND THEY WANTED TO MAKE
IT RIGHT AND- I'M HOPING WE CAN
DO THAT AND I'M HOPING WE HAVE
A REALLY GOOD PRODUCT TO SEND
TO THE GOVERNOR. WHEN THIS IS
ALL SAID AND DONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
THANKS TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS. IMPORTANT BILL
FORD. FOLKS I'LL BE VERY CANDID
WITH YOU I'M NOT SO CONFLICTED
ABOUT THIS AT ALL. I THINK
THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF WORK TO
DO. I THINK SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED ARE
EXTREMELY VALID. BUT MAYBE MY
PERSPECTIVE IS VERY DIFFERENT.
I GREW WHEN MY FAMILY WAS
SEPARATED DURING THE WAR IN
IRAN AND WE HAD TO MY MOTHER
AND I WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
COME HERE. AT THE AGE OF EIGHT
I SAW MY MOTHER STRUGGLING WITH
THE LEVEL OF STRESS. HAVING TWO
CHILDREN HERE ONE CHILD IN A
THIRD COUNTRY AND HER HUSBAND
IN YET A THIRD COUNTRY. WE WERE
SEPARATE INTO THREE CONTINENTS
AND THAT STRESS OF NOT KNOWING
WHERE THINGS WERE GONNA GO
WHILE SHE WAS WORKING THREE
JOBS. SHE STARTED SMOKING. SHE
WOULD FINISH A PACK A DAY. THAT
I WOULD FIND THE PACKS AND
THROWN AWAY. AT EIGHT. I'M GLAD
I DIDN'T GET HOOKED ON IT.
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN WHAT IT DOES
TO FEEL WE ALL HAVE FRIENDS WHO
HAVE WITNESSED WHAT'S HAPPENED
TO THEM. SO I CAN'T SHARE THAT
I'M I DON'T SAY IT LIGHTLY BUT
I CAN'T SHARE THAT I'M
CONFLICTED ABOUT THIS. ANYTHING
I WAS HAVING TOUGH TIME.
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE GAMES
MANSHIP THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
BETWEEN OUR TWO HOUSES. THAT'S
BEEN EMBARRASSING THIS PANDEMIC.
WHEN WE SHOULD BE ADVANCING
STRAW BILL THAT HOW THE
LEGISLATURE IS WORKING ON
BEHALF OF ITS CONSTITUENTS. IT
WHICH EACH OTHER'S BILLS. AND
IT'S NOT EVEN PARTISAN BY THE
WAY. IT WOULD BE ONE THING IF
IT WAS REPUBLICAN ON DEMOCRATS
IT'S DEMOCRATS DOING IT TO EACH
OTHER. MORE TO COME ON THAT
LATER BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM SOME AUTHORS. ON
THIS BILL THOUGH. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'VE
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD I THINK
THERE IS A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN SOME VALID
POINTS BROUGHT UP ABOUT HOW
THIS IMPACTS CB. AND SOME OTHER
SOME OTHER AREAS THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON. BUT I'M
GOING TO BE PROUD TO JOIN YOU
IN SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY I
DO HAVE HOPE YOU GET THE TO
PASS IT. I DO HOPE THAT ALSO
YOU WORK WITH OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM- THE ASSEMBLY WHO ALSO HAD
A SIMILAR BILL. AND TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION SOME OF HIS
CONCERNS- AND I DO ASK THAT
YOU. IF YOU WOULD HONOR ME
WITH- ADDING YOU ADDING ME AS A
CO AUTHOR YOUR BILL IS WELL.
BUT HAVE A- COST ISSUE THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS WELL. I
APPRECIATE YOU RAISING. THE
AWARENESS ON THE NUMBERS WE DO
SEE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THOSE ARE NUMBERS WE CAN
ACCOUNT FOR RIGHT. BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF HEALTH CARE
COSTS. THAT WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW. WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW. WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
SEEING AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ACCOUNTING FOR THERE'S NO
NUMBERS IT'S IMMEASURABLE HOW
EXPENSIVE IT'S GOING TO BE.
WHEN FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
KIDS. OF MOST OF THOSE KIDS
ALREADY DEPENDENT ON STATE ON
MEDIC CAL RELATED- OF STATE.
FUNDED COSTS AND FEDERAL FUNDED
BECAUSE PROGRAMS. HOW MUCH OF A
COST THEY'RE GONNA BE
CONTRIBUTING BY NOT BYE BYE
ENDING UP IN HOSPITALS. SO IT'S
LET'S ALSO LOOK AT THE FUTURE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A FEW
REMARKS I JUST WANT TO FIRST
START BY SAYING SENATOR. SHARE
YOUR PERSISTENCE- YOUR
PRESENTATION- I KNOW THIS IS
BENEFITS AN ISSUE OF IMPORTANCE
TO YOU FOR MANY YEARS AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT ALSO
FOR THE OTHER- CO AUTHORS IN
THE ROOM I APPRECIATE YOUR
CAMPING THIS ISSUE- THROUGH ITS
IT'S DIFFERENT HURDLES ALONG
THE WAY I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE- BODY FOR ITS IT'S
CONVERSATION THAT THE IDEAS
BEING PUT ON THE TABLE
QUESTIONS THE CONCERNS OF
THOUGHT THAT WHAT A BODY LIKE
THIS. IT TO DELIVER ABOUT REYES
ISSUES AND RAISE QUESTIONS LIKE
THE LAST SPEAKER- SEE THIS AS A
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD ISSUE
I'M NOT CONFLICTED ABOUT IT I
THINK IT IT COMES WITH THE
SIMPLE ISSUE OF THE FACT THAT
WE'RE FACING A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS FOR OUR CHILDREN WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT I TO MAKE IT BETTER
TO. I IMPROVE HEALTH AND THIS
IS WHAT SHOULD BE DOING I THREE
KIDS I TALKED TO ONE OF MY
DAUGHTERS ABOUT- THE FLAVORED
TOBACCO ISSUE AND I SAID TO
HER. WHY DO. YOUNG PEOPLE TO
SMOKE WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THE
ATTRACTION. AND SHE SAID PEOPLE
LIKE MENGONI LIKE MEANT. AND I
SAID WHAT ABOUT NON FLAVORED
TOBACCO SHE SAID THAT SHE
THINKS THERE THAT'S GROSS AND
YOUNG KIDS ARE NOT ATTRACTED TO
THAT SO SOME IS. SO THAT YOUNG
KIDS ARE GETTING ACCESS. EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE UNDER AGE AND
THE TRACTION IS CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW THE DATA THERE IS IT OUT
IT'S THE FLAVORED AT TOBACCO SO
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING- I STRONGLY RECOMMEND
THAT THIS BODY DO AS IT IS A
HEALTH COMMITTEE STEPPING UP
AND PUBLIC HEALTH. OF OUR
COMMUNITY. WALDRON I DO WANT TO%
A POINT ABOUT THE BUDGET ISSUE
N. AND THAT THE DEPLETING FIND
A COMING FROM OUR ARE TOBACCO
TAXES ARE THAT WOULD RESULT
THAT'S BEING PROTECTED I DO
THINK THAT WE CAN'T ALWAYS HAVE
PARA ONE HATTON ONE SET OF.
UPLOADERS AND NOT LOOK AT THE-
THE BUDGET ISSUES ESPECIALLY IN
A TIME OF SO SENSITIVE ABOUT
THE BUDGET BUT I BUT I WILL SAY
THIS THAT THAT SHOULDN'T BE A
SURPRISE WHEN IT COMES TO SIN
TAXES WHEN IT COMES TO LIKE TO
PACO. THEY PUT AN END TO TERROR
DEBATE HERE ALSO THAT OVER TIME
THEY WILL TO AND WHEN THEY ARE
DEPLOYED THAT A GOOD SIGN IN
THIS THAT IT MEANS PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPROVED. LAST OR SMALL
IN COMING DOT AND THAT'S GOOD
FOR OUR HEALTH ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK AS THE SECOND CENTER SAID
AT THEM MULTIPLE SAVINGS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OFF AND OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THAT WE WILL BE
REALIZING SO APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION I APPRECIATE YOU
CAMPING THIS OP PROP TO THINK I.
ON A PHONE RIGHT FOR THE BUT
I'M A CO AUTHOR OF THE VOTING
CAN APPRECIATE YOU CENTER HAVE.
THANK YOU I KNOW. THE HOUR IS
GETTING LATE WE HAVE A LOT WORK
AHEAD OF US AND I'LL DO MY BEST
TO BE BRIEF BUT I DO HAVE SOME
POINTS I WANT TO MAKE. YOU KNOW
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
SAYS THE TOBACCO KILLS MORE
THAN EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE A
YEAR. EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE.
IT'S THE MOST DEADLY. CONSUMER
PRODUCT EVER MADE. PERIOD THE
CDC SAYS THE TOBACCO COMPANIES
TO FIND ON THE WEBSITE ADD
MENTHOL TO MAKE CIGARETTES SEEM
LESS HARSH AND MORE APPEALING
TO NEW SPOKES MOTORS IN YOUNG
PEOPLE. THAT'S THE CRUX OF THE
ISSUE HERE IS TRYING TO NOT
HAVE THE NEXT GENERATION HOOKED
ON A DEADLY PRODUCT. SO I LOOK
AT THIS IN MY MIND AS AS A
PREVENTIVE MEASURE AND WHEN YOU
DO PREVENTION IT'S AN
INVESTMENT. TO REAP THE FUTURE
REWARD AND THEIR FUTURE AWARD
IS A REDUCTION IN THE THREE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR WE SPEND. ON MEDIC CAL ON
SMOKING RELATED ILLNESSES.
THINK ABOUT THAT SO YES WE WILL
HAVE A SHORTFALL HERE. BUT IS
IT BETTER TO ALLOW AN INDUSTRY
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR KILLING
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR.
SOME SLACK SO THAT WE HAVE A
COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR MORE IN IN REVENUE OKAY.
IS THAT THE TRADE OFF HERE.
BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN FIND A
COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
QUITE FRANKLY IF THAT'S WHAT IT
TRULY WORKS OUT TO BE. SO THIS
ISSUE IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME.
MY ENTIRE PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
HAS BEEN ABOUT TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE STOP SMOKING. I WATCHED
MY GRANDMOTHER IN A NURSING
HOME. WITH CRIPPLING RHEUMATOID
ARTHRITIS. SMOKING METHYLATED
CIGARETTES WHEN SHE COULD
BARELY LIKE THAT BECAUSE SHE
WAS SO CRIPPLED UP. HE DIED. OF
CANCER I WATCHED MY GRANDFATHER
ROLLING HIS OWN CIGARETTES AND
BEING FASCINATED BY IT. TO
WATCH HIM DIE OF A HEART ATTACK.
IT'S DEEPLY PERSONAL TO ME. I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE I SAW ON MY PRACTICE
COME IN WIDTHS GOAL OR
COPENHAGEN. TUCKED BETWEEN
THEIR CHEEK AND THEY'RE LEFT.
YOUNG KIDS BASEBALL PLAYERS
HOOKED IN WHEN THEY WANTED TO
QUIT THE COULD. I THINK OF THE
TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD BASEBALL
COACH IN CINEMA COUNTY. WHO
DIED OF ORAL CANCER FROM THAT
KIND OF PRODUCT. THE LEFT
BEHIND A YOUNG CHILD. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
HERE SO FOR ME THE CHOICE IS
VERY CLEAR. IT ISN'T JUST ABOUT
VAPING WHY BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
CAN DEBATE STATISTICS ALL DAY
LONG AND YOU KNOW I THINK-
MISTER FLORES SAID THAT HOOKAH
IS LIKE THE NUMBER TO CONSUME
PRODUCTS OUT THERE BUT YOU JUST
WANT TO BAN VAPING. THAT'S A
BIG WIN FOR TOBACCO COMPANIES.
BECAUSE I THINK A LOT. OF THEM
ARE BEGINNING TO WRITE THIS OFF
ANYWAY. BECAUSE OF JULIAN SOME
OF THE OTHER ISSUES OUT THERE
BUT WHAT THEY REALLY WANT TO
PROTECT IS THIS. THEY WANT TO
PROTECT PRODUCTS LIKE THIS. TWO
PACK SWISHER SWEETS CHOCOLATE
FLAVORED DOLLAR FORTY NINE. TWO
PAC EACH A DOLLAR FORTY NINE.
TWO PAC MAN ANNA SMASH A DOLLAR
FORTY NINE. TWO PACK TROPICAL
FLUSH A DOLLAR FORTY NINE I CAN
GO ON BECAUSE YOU'RE TWENTY
FIVE OR THIRTY OTHERS INCLUDING
BOOZY WATERMELON BOOTIES HOUSE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT HERE BECAUSE IF WE JUST
BAN VAPING. THE KIDS ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO USE THIS PRODUCT
IT'S A HUGE WIN FOR THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY HUGE. SO I HATED
HAVING TO ASK YOU TO TAKE
AMENDMENT SENATOR. BUT YOU KNOW
THE PROCESS AS WELL AS I DO THE
GOAL IS TO MOVE SOMETHING GOOD.
AND SOMETIMES THE PERFECT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IT RARELY
HAPPENS IN THIS HOUSE IF I HAD
MY WAY WE'D BE ON SQUARE ONE
WHERE YOUR BILL WAS STARTED.
THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY
AMENDMENTS. WE'RE TRYING TO
SAVE LIVES HERE FOLKS THAT'S
THE BOTTOM LINE. AND THAT'S WHY
I'M SO PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
IT'S BEEN MY ENTIRE
PROFESSIONAL LIFE. WHEN I WAS
THE MAYOR OF MY OWN CITY BEFORE
I CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE WE
RAISE THE AGE THAT YOU COULD
BUY TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO TWENTY
ONE. THE FIRST CITY IN THE
STATE TO DO THAT. AND WE A
REWARD FOR THAT WAS THREATENED
LAWSUITS BECAUSE- IT VIOLATED
THE STEAK ACT WE COULDN'T DO IT.
WE COULDN'T DO IT. SO WHEN I
CAME HERE I WAS FORTUNATE UP TO
SENT TO PARTNER WITH CENTER PAN
DURING THE SPECIAL SESSION IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE GOT
THAT PASSED AND THAT'S SPREAD
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TWENTY PLUS
OTHER STATES OF DOING THAT NOW.
WE WERE THE FIRST I WANT TO
CALIFORNIA TO BE THE FIRST. WE
OWE IT TO OUR CHILDREN. TO GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO NOT BE
HOOKED ON THESE PRODUCTS.
PEOPLE START SMOKING MOSTLY 90%
M. START BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. THAT'S WHY THESE
PRODUCTS EXIST TOBACCO
COMPANIES WANT KIDS TO USE
THESE PRODUCTS BEFORE THEY'RE
TWENTY ONE AND SO TO GET THEM
OUT OF STORES. SO THEY'RE NOT
CONVENIENT. IS THE GOAL HERE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TODAY I KNOW IT'S
BEEN LONG I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK AHEAD OF US. SENATOR
HELP I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR THAT VERY PASSIONATE
STATEMENT- IT'S INTERESTING HOW
IT IS PERSONAL I GUESS FOR ALL
OF US SOME FORMER ANOTHER. MY I
HAVE NO ONE CLOSE THAT HEAVILY
SMOKED. AS MUCH OR BROUGHT DOWN
THEIR LIFE BUT- IT'S
INTERESTING WAS TWENTY SIX
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS THE MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF SAN MATTEO. AND
THIS SEEMS LIKE SO FOREIGN
OVERTIME TODAY BUT WE HAD THE
FIRST IN THE STATE IT WAS A
FIRST FOR THE SECOND. THAT
BANNED SMOKING. IN RESTAURANTS.
OR IN THE WORKPLACE. OR IN BARS.
IN THE REACTION TO THAT THE
UPSET THE ANGER THE FIGHT THEY
THEY ACTUALLY WENT AFTER MY
BUSINESS THAT I HAD AT THE TIME
SHE'LL HAVE- AND- THEY WANT IF
YOU'RE TAKING A BUSINESS AWAY
FROM US. WE'RE GOING TO GO
AFTER YOU. THAT'S HOW THEY
FIGHT. AND IT'S NOT FAIR BUT I.
WANT TO THANK YOU THIS WAS SUCH
AN ENLIGHTENING. HEARTWARMING
AND- TOUCHING CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE IT'S ALL ABOUT THE KIDS.
ALL ABOUT THE KIDS AND THAT'S
WHAT I HEARD TODAY REGARDLESS
OF THE SIZE SIDE OF THE AISLE
REGARDLESS OF THE VOTE. IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE KIDS AND YOU
BROUGHT THAT HOME. AND WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE GO
FORWARD WE LOOK AT THOSE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED WHETHER IT'S
FINANCIAL. OR RACIAL. AND
REALLY DECIDE HOW WE WANT. TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS UP.
SUCCEED AND LIVE LONG AND
HEALTHY LIFE. I FREE THIS COMP
I'VE REALLY APPRECIATE ACTION
FROM ALL OF YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK. THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL IT'S BEEN SO LONG
I'M NOT SURE WHO MADE THE
MOTION I'M NOT SURE WHO MADE
THE SECOND. MANY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOOK MOM. OKAY WELL WE
GOT WHAT WE GOT COMPETING
PEOPLE NOW SO I WILL I WILL SAY
MAKE THE MOTION BY MISTER
MCCARTY THE SECOND BY MISS
LIMóN. WHAT WAS THAT. THAT'S
OKAY FOR MR BONTA OKAY. THAT
WILL GO THAT WAY THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROACH. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE MOTION IS DUE
PROCESS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MADE. MAYES NOT VOTING AGERA
CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA ICEBERG.
BURKE NOW VOTING. BURKE II.
CORREO CARILLO I'D FLORA FLORA
NO LIMóN LIMON AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
AYE RAMOS. RAMOS NOT VOTING
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON.
WALDRON NOT VOTING. TEN I TO
KNOWS BILL PASSES. THE COMMENTS
ARE TERRY. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR HELP
GRATEFUL THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS I WANT TO KNOW-
WE DID HAVE ONE CHANGE TO THE
AGENDA THERE. S. S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN BY THE
AUTHOR. SO WITHOUT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO- S. B. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR MONNING SENATOR
MONEY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY I APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGE THAT I'VE WITH MANY OF
YOU AND WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR- EXCEPT THE
CHAIRS SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK LARA
PLANNING CHRISTINE MOBLEY FOR
ALL YOU'VE YOUR HARD WORK THE
STAFF WHO HAVE WORKED ON THIS
BILL. THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT PATIENTS CONSUMERS AND
COMMUNITIES. OUR CONSTITUENTS.
FOR TOO LONG STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT HOSPITAL CONSOLIDATION
RESULTS IN INCREASED PREMIUMS
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT ADDRESSED
THIS ISSUE. THE EVIDENCE IS
CLEAR AS REPORTED BY THE LA
TIMES AND IS PRESENTED IN
ACADEMIC JOURNALS. EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES LITTLE OVERSIGHT OF
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION AND MARKET
PRACTICES LEFT UNCHECKED HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW AND UTILIZE ABUSIVE MARKET
PRACTICES THAT DRIVE UP PRICES
AND REDUCE ACCESS FOR CONSUMER.
IN NINE SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
LARGE HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AS
WELL AS PRIVATE EQUITY GROUPS
AND HEDGE FUNDS TO OBTAIN
APPROVAL FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BEFORE AN ACQUISITION
OR CHANGE OF CONTROL WITH ANY
OTHER HEALTH CARE FACILITY OR
PROVIDER. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD EVALUATE THE PROPOSED
TRANSACTION BASED ON TWO
FACTORS FIRST WHETHER THE
TRANSACTION WOULD INCREASE OR
MAINTAIN CARE COORDINATION AND
OR INCREASE OR MAINTAIN
AFFORDABILITY OF CARE TO AN
UNDERSERVED POPULATION. AND
SECOND WHETHER THE TRANSACTION
SUBSTANTIALLY LIKELY TO RESULT
IN ANTI COMPETITIVE EFFECTS
THAT OUTWEIGH ANY BENEFITS. IF
THE ACQUISITION OR CHANGE OF
CONTROL DOES NOT MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL MAY DENY THE
TRANSACTION OR PROPOSED TERMS
OF CONDITIONS TO IMPROVE THE
BENEFITS TO THE COMMUNITY. SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN DOES NOT
OUTRIGHT DENY ANY TRANSACTION
IT IS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
PATIENTS AND CONSUMERS OUR
CONSTITUENTS THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT OF THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
GROWS IT MUST INCREASE OR
MAINTAIN IT SERVICES NOT JUST
ITS PROFITS. ADDITIONALLY SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN ESTABLISHES
THE HEALTH POLICY ADVISORY
BOARD THE BOARD WOULD BE MADE
UP OF A BROAD CROSS SECTION OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND WOULD ADVISE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL I'M
PROPOSED CONSOLIDATION
TRANSACTIONS. FINALLY SB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN WOULD DECLARE THAT
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS THAT
EXERCISE SUBSTANTIAL MARKET
POWER MAY NOT ENGAGE IN
BEHAVIOR THAT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
LIKELIHOOD OF ANTI COMPETITIVE
IMPACTS. ANTI COMPETITIVE
BEHAVIORS ARE DEFINED TO IN
MARKET. DUE TO THE ELIMINATION
OF COMPETITION DIMINISHING
QUALITY REDUCING CHOICE
INCREASING THE TOTAL COST OF
CARE OR DIMINISHING ACCESS TO
OR AVAILABILITY OF HOSPITAL OR
NON HOSPITAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THE CHAIRS AMENDMENTS
THAT I'VE AGREED TO DO THE
FOLLOWING. THEY ADD A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET TO THE PROVISION OF THIS
BILL RELATING TO THE AG'S
AUTHORITY TO REVIEW
TRANSACTIONS. THEY RAISE THE
THRESHOLD FOR EXPEDITED REVIEW
TO A TRANSACTIONAL VALUE OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. OR HIGHER.
THEY ADD COUNTY FACILITIES TO
THE LIST OF EXPEDITED REVIEW
ENTITIES YOU SO MUCH OKAY. THEY
CHANGED THE AG A THORNY TONIGHT
CONSENT FROM SHALL TO MAY. IN
THE EXPAND THE CRITERIA FOR
APPROVING A CHANGE OF CONTROL
TO INCLUDE MAINTAINING SERVICES.
AS THE WORLD RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS MEMBERS
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE IS MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER
AT THE SAME TIME COBIT NINETEEN
HAS CREATED AN ENORMOUS
FINANCIAL STRAIN ON BOTH
HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIANS MAKING
THESE PROVIDERS SUSCEPTIBLE TO
CONSOLIDATION ATTEMPTS BY LARGE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRMS AND HEDGE FUNDS.
HAS COVERED NINETEEN IS FORCING
CONSOLIDATION WITHIN THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
INSURERS RESPONSIBLE OVERSIGHT
OF THE GROWTH OF LARGE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS AND THEIR
IMPACT ON THE HEALTH CARE
MARKET. WITH THE LEADER OF THE
CHAIR I DON'T LIKE TO PRESENT
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL JENNY PHILLIPS SPECIAL
ASSISTANT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND EMILIO BERNINI
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ANTI
TRUST SECTION WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. I
WILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MINING- WOULD LIKE TO GO TO THE
PHONE AND- TAKE OUR WITNESSES-
FIRST OUR FIRST WITNESS WILL BE
JENNY PHILLIPS SO. AS WE CAN
HAVE A LONG TIME I THINK THERE
MIGHT STILL BE A MODERATOR
THERE I KNOW WE'VE BEEN TALKING
FOR AWHILE BUT- HELLO. AN
AIRLINE OF JAPANESE ARMY.
MISTER CHAIR CAN HEAR ME I'M
SORRY. THE CHECK OUT YES PLEASE
HI JENNY PLEASE GO AHEAD WE CAN
THAT WE CAN ABSOLUTELY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN BUILT ON THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING PATIENTS BY
EXPANDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S AUTHORITY OVER
HEALTHCARE TRANSACTIONS AND
ENFORCEMENT OF ANTITRUST LAW.
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO REVIEW AND CONSENT FOR ANY
SALE OR TRANSFER OF THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY OWNED OR
OPERATED BY A NONPROFIT
CORPORATION. SB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN BUILT ON THE SIGNAL LAW
BY REQUIRING HEALTH CARE.
PRIVATE EQUITY AND HEDGE FUNDS
ALL THIRTEEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
APPROVAL BEFORE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE CHANGE OF CONTROL WHAT
HAPPENED ANOTHER PROVIDER
INCLUDING BOTH. FOR PROFIT AND
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS. THIS
REVIEW IF INTENDED TO AND-
THESE COUPLE TWENTY CONSIDERING
IMPACT OF. REQUIRING A- THAT
THE PROPOSED TRANSACTION WILL
BENEFIT PATIENTS IN THE FORM OF
INCREASE CLINICAL INTEGRATION.
ACCESS AND AVAILABILITY TO
SERVICE IT IT'S PRETTY WOULD
ALSO ENSURE THAT THE ANTI
COMPETITIVE THE FACT OF THE
PROPOSED TRANSACTION IS NOT
OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS TO
CONFIRM. UNDER S. NINE SEVEN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
COULD NOT REVIEW EVERY PROPOSED
PROVIDER TRANSACTION INSTEAD
THE REVIEW IF LIMITED TO ONLY
BILL TRANSACTIONS THAT INVOLVE
A HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. PRIVATE
EQUITY GROUP OR HAD FIVE. WHEN
THEY ARE ACQUIRING OR MAKING A
CHANGE OF CONTROL FOR PROVIDER
SERVICES OR FACILITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE AT THE NINE SEVEN SEVEN
DOES NOT COVER EMPLOYMENT
ARRANGEMENTS OR LEASE AGREEMENT
UNLESS AT. LEAST IS ACTUALLY
THE EQUIVALENT OF A SALE. BUT
ABU PROFIT NINE THAT SEVEN IT'S
UNLIMITED SPECIFIC TIME FOR AND
CONSISTS OF A FIFTY DAY AND
MITCHELL WILL BE A PERIOD. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL REQUIRES MORE
INFORMATION OR DETERMINES THE
PUBLIC MEETINGS APPROPRIATE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MAY EXTEND THE
REVIEW PROCESS. ONLY AT
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES AN EXPEDITED
REVIEW PROCESS. FOR SPECIFIED
PROVIDERS. SB NINE SEVEN ON THE-
BUILT ON THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
ANTITRUST LAW BY SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING ANTI COMPETITIVE
BEHAVIOR BY LARGE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THAT USED THEIR MARKET
POWER TO DRIVE UP PRICES. UNDER
THE BELT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WOULD BE PROHIBITED FROM USING
THEIR MARKET POWER TO INCREASE
PRICES WOULD NO LONGER BE
PERMITTED TO USE HARMFUL
PRACTICES SUCH AS TING AN
EXCLUSIVE DEALING CONTRACT.
ANOTHER KEY ASPECT OF SB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN IF THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THEATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD ADVANCE NOTICE ABOUT A
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM REQUIRES A
NEW PROVIDER. EXISTING
ANTITRUST. BLOOD DOES NOT ONLY
PROVIDE THE H. GENERAL WITH THE
NOTE THAT. HAVING THE ABILITY
FOR THE TELL CARE SAID
TRANSACTION OF THEY ARE
FINALIZED WILL HELP ABOUT PRICE
INCREASE. AND PROTECT. PATIENTS
TWENTY GENERAL IF PROUD. ENOUGH
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IDOL AND HAVE TO TAKE A
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS EMILIO THERE. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. SURE A NEW CAR
WATCHING THAT IN MY STATEMENT
I'M SORRY. ARE YOU TALK FOR
THREE MINUTES AND I THINK THAT
WAS OKAY OKAY WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A PARTY DOWN. OKAY SO WE HAVE
WEEK YOU HAD YOU DID HAVE THE
OPTION OF SIX MINUTES OF THREE
MINUTES EACH. BUT AS YOU WISH
SO. IF THEY HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
TO ADD YOU'VE GOT. A COUPLE
MINUTES LEFT IF YOU WISH. WITH
ANOTHER WITH ANOTHER SUPPORTING.
OKAY SO WITH THAT WE'D LIKE TO
GO SEE OTHER OTHERS OTHERS IN
SUPPORTERS OR ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBER WHO IS IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OUR WITNESS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. SEE NO ONE WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE WE'RE ASKING FOR
SUPPORT- FOUR SB NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN- THIS IS JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION ONLY PLEASE. SOME
MISTER MARK MADAM WHO.
MODERATOR PLEASE I'M NOT SURE
WHAT GENDER WE ARE ANYMORE SO-
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. INE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR. AND WHAT A
LINE FIVE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GENTILONI ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALIVE OUR LINE ELEVEN
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SARA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WELL
I AM ALIVE IN EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NO AT BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY TWO OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. INDEED
THE END ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BLIND SIX
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CENTIGRADE YES HE W. WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS STEVE
CATHOLICA WITH THE INDEPENDENT
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ELEVEN FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS ERIN HAVE
ANYBODY HAPPEN NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR PLEASED I. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS BILL KRAMER ON BEHALF
OF THE PACIFIC BUSINESS GROUP
ON HEALTH STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE TEN SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND
HAPPY TO HELP ACTIONS ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW ELEVEN HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO
BE. I AM ELEVEN OUT TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU. NOT SUPPORT
MY NAME IS GET THEM PATEL. THEY
WERE JUST TAKING SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO DO THAT
SAY THAT AGAIN WE'RE TAKING
OPPOSITION YOU'RE WELCOME TO
GET BACK INTO THE QUEUE. RIGHT
OR IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BORDERLINE ELEVEN THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE
FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
GIPSON PATEL I WILL BE GOOD I
AM CLEARLY WHEN PEOPLE AND I DO
NOT THE FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE THE ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
TWO MORE IN Q. THANK YOU OKAY.
NINE ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
AHEAD. THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS A
LOT OF PENSIONARY OFF.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
BOTTLE I LOVE IN FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THERE GROWTH LEFT
ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
UNION OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION AS OUR THERE WAS NO
ONE ELSE OKAY WHERE WE DID
CHECK THE CHAMBER WE CHECKED
THE ROOM SO OKAY- MOVING ON TO
OPPOSITION NOW. TO ON THE PHONE
ALEX HAWTHORNE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN AMY
DURBAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION SO.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY- PLEASE
WITH THEM IN. MADAM MODERATOR.
EVENING MISTER CHAIR TALUKS CAN
WE LIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING OUR TOP PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
OCCIPITAL AND A BROAD COALITION
OF OTHER HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR ONE
FUNDAMENTAL REASON. IT WILL
CREATE A BERRIER HEALTHCARE
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE CRITICAL FOR
ACCESS TO CARE ACCESS TO SCARCE
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND ACCESSIBLE
STAFF. THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TODAY ALREADY
HAS SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT AND
THE SPECS. AS PART OF THE
EXTENT THE POWERS VESTED IN
THAT OFFICE. IN ADDITION TO
ENFORCING EXISTING ROBUST ANTI
TRUST LAWS THE OFFICE ALSO HAS
COMPLETE DISCRETION TO REVIEW
THE SALE OF NOT FOR PROFIT
HOSPITALS WHICH ARE THE
MAJORITY OF HOSPITALS IN THE
STATE. THE LAWS AND POWERS ARE
USED EVERY YEAR AS RECENT
LAWSUITS AT HOSPITAL SALES AND
ATTACHED. ADULT FOCUSED SERIOUS
FAULT BECAUSE IT CAPTURES ALL
HOSPITAL TYPES PUBLIC PRIVATE
NOT FOR PROFIT INVESTOR OWNED.
IT LOCAL. IN THE CONFLICT WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. TO CREATE
AN ADDITIONAL CONCURRENT AND
REDUNDANT. PROCESS FOR
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS WHICH
pCONFLICTING REVIEWS FOR SALES.
ALL THE BENEFITS OF HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS GROUP PATIENT
COORDINATION AND CARE IMPROVE
DISASTER RESPONSE GREATER
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND SUPPORT
FOR STRUGGLING HOSPITALS WHICH
EXPLAINS THE BURDENS WELL
BEYOND HOSPITAL SYSTEMS AND TO
ALL OTHER PROVIDERS. TO DELIVER
HEALTHCARE TOGETHER. AND THIS
IS JUST HOW OF THE BILL. THE
BILL ALL CREATES A ONE SIDED
SYSTEM WITH NO MEANINGFUL
APPEAL OR DUE PROCESS AND NEW
ANTI TRUST LAWS THE PLACE THE
BURDEN OF PROOF. ON THE
PROVIDER AND A GUILTY UNTIL
PROVEN INNOCENT SYSTEM. IT IS A
PERMANENT TRANSFER OF ENORMOUS
POWER. TO ONE ELECTED OFFICE.
THE JUDGE AND JURY FOR
THOUSANDS OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS YOU SIR. SHE CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE WILLING TO ENGAGE
IN A DISCUSSION ABOUT POLICY
REFORM TRANGER OVERSIGHT.
INCLUDING EXISTING OVERSIGHT
BUT NO IT'S NOT THE TIME AND
THIS IS NOT THE VEHICLE. I
WOULD- JUST NOTE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT THAT CAN BE
MANAGED TODAY DO NOT REMEMBER
OPPOSITION AND WE URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS. A MAJOR EVENT
THANK YOU MEDICARE MEMBERS YES
HI AMY DURBIN OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION. IN GENERAL THEORY
OF SUPPORTIVE OF GOVERNMENTAL
ACTIONS DESIGNED TO ASSURE
HOSPITAL MARKET COMPETITION
HOWEVER THIS BILL GOES WELL
BEYOND HOSPITAL ACQUISITIONS
AND MERGERS AND WOULD CAPTURE
AND LIMIT AB AFTER A OF HEALTH
TRANSACTION. INCLUDING LEASING
AND OTHER CONTRACTING
ARRANGEMENTS WITH INDIVIDUAL
PHYSICIANS AND PROVIDERS NOT
JUST HEALTH SYSTEMS FOR EXAMPLE
CONTRACTS BETWEEN MEDICAL
GROUPS AND HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE
ON CALL SERVICES TRAUMA
SERVICES ARRANGEMENTS BETWEEN
PROVIDERS AND HOSPITALS
REGARDING STOPPING PROVIDING
SERVICES THROUGH TELEHEALTH.
ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
BATMAN MEN'S CHANGING THE WORD
AFFILIATION TO CHANGE OF
CONTROL DO NOT CHANGE THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL IN THAT REGARD
BECAUSE THE DEFINITION REMAINS
THE SAME IT STILL MEANS ALL
ARRANGEMENTS AND AGREEMENTS
PARTNERSHIPS AND LEASE REMAINS
THE DEPTH IN THE DEFINITION OF
ACQUISITION AS WELL. IN
ADDITION THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
BELT A SUBSTANTIALLY BALANCED
FOR INSTANCE IT BROADLY
CAPTURES HEALTH PROVIDER
ARRANGEMENTS YET IT DOESN'T
CAPTURE HEALTH PLANS UNDER THE
SAME PROCESS BOTH EMAIL TO
ALLOW PRIVATE EQUITY FIRMS TO
VIOLATE LAWS TO ENSURE OUR-
QUALITY. CARE FRAMEWORKS THAT
FOR THE BILL AS WELL WAIT
TOWARD HIM AS WHICH BY MUCH
IMPORTANT. NOT PROPERLY BALANCE
WEAPONS TO WORK THE AS ACTS TO
CARE. THAT MEANS THE NOT ONLY
THE BILL FRAMEWORK ABOUT OF CON
WITH AN PROVIDERS BUT IT WILL
PREVENT THEM FROM BEING A- AND
ALLOWED. THE LAST MAIN POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IS THAT THERE'S NO
LIMITATIONS OR EXEMPTIONS IN
THE BATTLE FOR ACCESS SMALLER
PROVIDERS TRANSACTION RURAL
AREAS. FOR INSTANCE THAT
PROPOSED AMENDMENT REGARDING.
MAINTAINING ACCESS OR CHANGING.
THE SHELVES TO. DOES NOT CHANGE
THE BROADER FLOOD FREE MARK
WITH THE BROAD CRITERIA AND
DEFINITIONS THAT MUST BE MET
AND FELL. WHILE THAT ONE
MILLION DOLLAR THRESHOLD AND
SIMILAR AMENDMENTS RELATED TO
EXPEDITE IT OR THIRTY OR SIXTY
DAY AUTOMATIC PROCESS EITHER
STATED ATTEMPTS TO LIMIT
IMPACTS ON SMALLER PROVIDERS
AND DECREASED. TRANSACTION
MEETING APPROVAL THEY'RE ALSO
NOT EXEMPTION ALL UP BACK. YOU
STILL. NOTIFYING ME HE WHICH
REVIEW CONNECTS HIGHLY TO DO
FURTHER LET ME AND DELAY
TRANSACTION. SO WE BELIEVE TO
BE BY MISSPELLING GOOD WE ALSO
BELIEVE IT'S- WRITTEN LEADING
TO OF UNCERTAINTY AN ALREADY
VERY UNCERTAIN ENVIRONMENT.
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS AND WE'RE
WORKING TO THE OPERATORS OF
ADDITIONAL AND FAST RESOURCES
JUST TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
THIS BILL WILL ONLY FURTHER
DECREASES OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACCESS TO NECESSARY HEALTHCARE.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
NOTE THAT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION. JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION ONLY PLEASE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE
ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO ONE WILL GO
TO THE WE DON'T HAVE WE HAVE NO
ONE IN THE WITNESS ROOM SO
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE SO THIS
WOULD BE- PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION
TO NINE SEVENTY SEVEN- WITH-
NAME AND POSITION ONLY SO-
MADAME MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVER TO AYE
NUMBER TEN ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MECOLE
WORTMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ALIVE IN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
ON BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ALIVE IN TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
LARGER MARKET THAN IN THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE CLOSED
TO THE BILL IN CURRENT FORM.
THANK YOU. LEVINE HAD EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT VENTURE
WITH AMERICAN OF OBG TO
DISTRICT AND THE CALIFORNIA
COULD MEDICAL SO IT HAPPENED TO
NINE SEVEN THANK YOU THANK.
BLIGHT ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS KELLY HEAD WITH POPULAR
BY ON BEHALF OF THAT ARE HELD
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DO PAY
HOSTS REPRESENTING CAN HELP
VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
ELEVEN NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING KELLY MAC MILLAN
ON BEHALF OF MEMORIAL CARE IN
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TWO
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE BANK TO
HEALTH MOBILE IN THE UNIVERSITY
HEALTH THE ALLIANCE OF CATHOLIC
HEALTH CARE AND PEACH THE
PRODUCT THEY DO NOT HOSPITALS
IN OPPOSITION. Q. BLIND SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN BREAKING
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
NOT WITH. THANK YOU. I'D ALIVE
IN FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JONATHAN QUICK ABOUT THE SCRIPT
SO. IN OPPOSITION SB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN. THANK BLIND FOR SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
WONDERING IF THIS IS MADE HIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BLIND FOR NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PRETTY WILL RETURN
NUMBER CANNELLA BE HALF A
DIFFERENT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
FIVE FIVE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS NEAR MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRITAIN YOUNG
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. NINE ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOTHING
SIRIANO ON BEHALF OF TECH
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ELEVEN THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MEGAN
WEBER ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M HELIC ITEMS ALL OF THE
KAISER PERMANENTE A IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. FIVE SIX
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SIX FOUR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEVADA LINE ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS FRED KNOW
WHERE I WAS SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION FOR STANFORD HEALTH
CARE STANFORD HEALTHCARE VALLEY
CARE IN THE ASSOCIATION OF
DENTAL SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE A LOT
THIRTY NINE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
BILL BARCELONA WITH AMERICA'S
PHYSICIAN GROUPS IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL ON BEHALF OF ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MEDICAL
GROUPS AND I. T. AGE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. LINE
ALIVE AND TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE ONE ONE ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMORY WILL TAKE FIVE
MORE- AND- WILL WILL THEN LET
WILL THEN WE WILL END THE OP
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. IF THERE
ARE FIVE HERE ONE MORE BY THE
LINE. THREE SEVENTY SEVEN.
HELLO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HOPE
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ALIVE IN TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB IN
THE FUTURE MEMBERS JOHN DORIAN
BAPTIST KINDRED HOSPITAL IN
YEAR GROUP IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
INVESTMENT COUNCIL WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
THREE NINE NINE. HAVE NOT FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WORKER
COMMITTEE. MR BONTA. THANK YOU
SENATOR MONNING FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AYE AYE EIGHT
APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS ON
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND
PATIENTS AT AS YOU STATED IN
OUR PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS
pDAY AND- I'VE ALSO HAD CAN'T
STOP THE SPONSOR AND A NUMBER
IN OPPOSITION. AND I THINK THE
MEMBERS HELP MAKE CLEAR WHAT
WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE NEED FOR
THE CHANGE OF CONTROL. THE
FOCUS ON A HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
OR PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP. OR
HEDGE FUND OF IT BEING A
PARTICIPANT IN AND NOT CHANGE
OF CONTROL. ARM AND THE
DEFINITION HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
BEING SOMETHING OF A SYSTEM
INVOLVING THREE HOSPITALS WHEN
THE GENERAL ACUTE CARE.
HOSPITAL IN CALIFORNIA SO I
APPRECIATE ALL THAT CLARITY
EVEN WITH THAT CLARITY I'VE HAD
QUITE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
AROUND- AB WORRY ABOUT OVER
BREAT. AND PICK OUT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT ENTITIES
AND WHAT ARRANGEMENTS ARE
CAPTURED BY THIS BILL. I
UNDERSTAND IT KAISER HAS
CONCERNED THAT ITS ENTIRE
SYSTEM MIGHT BE CONTEMPLATED
AND COVERED BY THIS GUY NO
THAT'S NOT YOUR TENT- AND SOME
OF THE SMALLER- ARRANGEMENTS-
BETWEEN SMALLER PRACTICE
GROUPS. I DON'T THINK IS YOUR
INTENT AS WELL SO I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ASK THAT. YOU CONSIDER
CONTINUE TO CONSIDER THOSE
CONCERNS AND- PROVIDE. AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD I'M GONNA SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO PROTECT
HEALTHCARE PROTECT CONSUMERS
PROTECT PATIENTS- I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING IT AND
HOPEFULLY GET A CLEARER FORM.
WHEN HITS THE FLOOR- IF IT GETS
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE ON TO
BEFORE THANK YOU SENATOR MONEY.
THE CHAIR IF I MIGHT JUST
COMMENT ON A COUPLE OF THE
ISSUES BECAUSE- I THINK I WAS
ABLE TO HELP CLARIFY IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS AND- THE BREADTH
OF THE OPPOSITION I CERTAINLY.
RESPECT TO THE SELF INTEREST OF
THOSE BUSINESS ENTITIES
ASSOCIATIONS ETCETERA. BUT
AGAIN THE THRESHOLD LANDS OF
THIS BILL IS PROTECTING
PATIENTS AND CONSUMERS SO THE
QUESTION IS COME UP ABOUT- I
THINK THERE'S BEEN AN OVER
BREATH AND SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT. THE ENTITIES
THAT WOULD BE CAUGHT UP THAT IF
A PHYSICIAN GROUPS SOUGHT TO
NEGOTIATE A LEASE. WITH THE
PROPERTY OWNER IN THEIR OUNTY
THAT SOMEHOW THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE REVIEW OF THE
TOURNEY GENERAL. NO IT WOULD
NOT- WITH THE NARROWING
AMENDMENTS WE FURTHER FOCUS ON
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AS YOU
MENTIONED BEING THREE HOSPITALS
ONE OF WHICH HAS TO HAVE A CUTE
KERR. THE KAISER EXAMPLE- THEY
ARE A BIG HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING. WHEN
KAISER SETS UP A NEW FACILITY
ITSELF INITIATES THAT IT'S NOT
THROUGH ACQUISITIONS AND
AFFILIATIONS IT'S THROUGH. THEY
START FROM THE GROUND UP IF
THEY'RE BUILDING A NEW HOSPITAL
OR STARTING A NEW PRIMARY
CLINIC. THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
OF THE KAISER MODEL- BUT WHEN
WE LOOK AT A HOSPITAL THAT MAY
BE IN DISTRESS. AND THERE'S A
LARGER HELL CARE SO. THAT IS
INTERESTED IN ACQUIRING THAT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT BLOCK THAT
IT DOES NOT PREVENT THAT IT
DOES INSTITUTE A LEVEL OF
REVIEW THAT IS CURRENTLY ONLY
THERE IF AN ENTITY IS A
NONPROFIT. A LOT OF THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET IS FOR PROFIT
TO FOR PROFIT AND THAT'S WHERE
YOU GET EQUITY FUNDS AND HEDGE
FUNDS THEIR NUMBER ONE
ALLEGIANCE. IS TO THE
SHAREHOLDERS. THE SHAREHOLDER
SERVED BY GENERATING PROFIT.
THIS BILL SIXTY EQUALIZE THAT
LEGITIMATE INTEREST IN A FOR
PROFIT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO
PROTECT THE PATIENT AND THE
CONSUMER SO AGAIN I APPRECIATE.
YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR DRAWING
OUT SOME OF THESE DISTINCTIONS
FOR BETTER UNDERSTANDING THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. CEREMONY I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ARE TRYING TO
DO- AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
COST OF HEALTH CAR CARE- ARE
SKYROCKETING. I'VE HAD MANY
MANY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
BILL AND I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND AS I TOLD YOU
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED VISITING
A SAID. I ALWAYS I'M GONNA
WATCH OUT FOR MY- DISTRICT AND
I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT
UNINTENDED. IN MY DISTRICT MY
CONSTITUENTS CONSTITUENTS RELY
ON VARIOUS PARTNERSHIPS AND
STAFFING CONTRACTS FOR CENTRAL
AND SPECIALTY CARE. BASED ON MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS HERE TODAY AND
WITH MY LOCALS IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THERE IS A BROAD VARIATION
OF INTERPRETATIONS ON WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. AND DOES NOT CAPTURE.
FOR EXAMPLE I HAVE BEEN HEARING
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
RESTRICTING RETIRING DENTISTS
AND OPTOMETRISTS. STAFFING
CONTRACTS TO KEEP OUR E. OURS
OPERATING AND INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN FQHCS IN
HOSPITALS. WHEN MY LOOK ARE
CALLING ME SAYING THAT THIS
PROCESS IS GOING TO BE CHILLING
TO THEIR ABILITY CONTINUE TO
OFFER BASIC CONTRACTS AND MAKE
AGREEMENTS WITH COMMUNITY IN
MIND. I HAVE TO TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY. WHAT INSURANCES ARE
THERE IN THIS BILL THAT
BENEFICIAL ARRANGEMENTS LIKE
THESE WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. IT IS LARGELY THE
SUBJECTIVE OPINION OF ONE
OFFICE. THANK YOU. MANY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD ON THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION IT YOU JUST ENDED ON.
SO THE ATTORNEYGENERAL WILL
ASSEMBLE A BOARD OF ADVISORS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL
SECTORS INCLUDING COMMUNITY
CLINICS HOSPITALS RURAL
HOSPITALS INVEST GROUPS LARGE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS EVERY
STAKEHOLDER AFFECTED BY THIS
LEGISLATION. WILL HAVE A PLACE
AT THE TABLE IMPORTANTLY. THIS
BILL ALSO GIVES OUR COMMUNITIES
A VOICE. TO SEEK OBJECTIVE
REVIEW OF TRANSACTIONS THAT MAY
HAVE AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON THAT
COMMUNITY THAT WE REPRESENT.
THE HOSPITAL EXAMPLE OF A SOUL
HOSPITAL THAT'S IN ECONOMIC
THIS. IT IS THE ONLY PROVIDER
TO THAT COMMUNITY. THE
OBJECTIVE OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT SERVICE TO PROTECT
ACCESS IN TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE THAT'S WHY
ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT.
THERE DOES NOT HAVE TO BE A
DEMONSTRATION OF IMPROVEMENT OF
SERVICE IT COULD SIMPLY BE THE
MAINTENANCE OF THAT SERVICE WE
ALSO HAVE A WAIVER. IN RAW
DISTRICTS SOME OF YOUR ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WOULD QUALIFY AS A
RURAL DISTRICT THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO A WAIVER. FOR THAT
REVIEW BASED ON THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE SERVICE
AREA IT'S BEING SUPPORTED. I
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I STILL
THINK THERE IS SOME- QUESTIONS
THAT SOME OF MY- CONSTITUENTS
WOULD HAVE REGARDING THAT
PARTICULAR RURAL AREAS I WILL
SAY THAT- AGAINST MY BETTER
JUDGEMENT. I WILL SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. BECAUSE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD
WITH YOU AND I THINK THAT
YOU'RE AN HONEST MAN WILL WORK
HARD AT THIS AS WELL AS WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
BUT I DO WANT TO GO ON RECORD
THAT I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AGAIN WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES. I HOPE
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE WITH THE OPPOSITION BEFORE
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ON
THE FLOOR AND I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS WHOLE THANK YOU.
MR MAYS. I WANNA- THANK MY TWO
COLLEAGUES BEFORE AFTER THEIR
COMMENTS AND THEY'RE CONCERNED
AND OBVIOUSLY CENTER YOU'VE
DONE QUITE A BIT OF WORK ON
THIS- BUT- YOU AND I'VE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO HAVE ANY
CONVERSATION- AND I PREFER
CONVERSATIONS FACE TO FACE-
BEFORE THE- THE PANDEMIC WE
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT- AND BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC WHEN YOU CAME IN
MY OFFICE- I WOULD HAVE ACCESS
PROBABLY MORE THAN LIKELY
WALKED OUT OF THIS AND WALKED
INTO GO BE WITH THE CHAIR ABOUT
ABOUT IT MAYBE- THE
AGUIAR-CURRY AND I WOULD HAVE
HAD SOME CONVERSATION AND I
WOULD HAVE. WENT OVER UP TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS THIS AND
SAID HEY HAD- JAMES WHAT'S-
HOW'S THIS GOING TO AFFECT OUR
REGION- WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT AND YET THE BILL BEFORE
US RIGHT NOW THE BATTLE FOR
TODAY WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
IMPACT UPON OUR HEALTH SYSTEM
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE'S
NOT A MEMBER IN THIS ROOM THAT
FULLY UNDERSTANDS WHAT THAT
IMPACT GOING TO BE NOW MY GUESS
IS MY GUESS IS THAT THERE'S
BEEN A FEW MEMBERS THAT HAVE
GOTTEN A PHONE CALL FROM A
STATEWIDE ELECTED OFFICIAL SAID
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE ME THIS BILL
GIVE ME A COURTESY BILL TO GET
THIS. MY GUESS IS DON'T KNOW
THAT TRUE BUT- THAT WOULD BE MY
GUESS. I THINK IT'S PROBE FOR
US RIGHT NOW AT THIS. TO PAY.
TO TAKE APART. BRING THIS BILL
BACK NEXT SESSION LET US DIG
INTO THIS TO FOR OUT THIS IS
THE PROP WAY TO ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE THERE IS NO
DOUBT- SENATOR. THAT THE
PURPOSE BEHIND THIS BILL IS A
IS A SINCERE WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A VERY LARGE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ACROSS US
THAT WITH WHERE WE'RE STAND
RIGHT NOW. THAT IS DONE
SOMETHING THAT BAR MORE THAN
LIKELY NOT APPROPRIATE BUT TO
HAVE A BROAD BRUSH ACROSS THIS
ENTIRE STATE. TO HAVE A POLICY
LIKE THIS THAT WE DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND AND WE HAVEN'T FULLY
DUG INTO I THINK WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE SIDE BAG MY CALL
TODAY. I URGE TO BE ABLE TO PUT
A PAUSE ON THIS AND LET'S COME
BACK NEXT NEXT YEAR TO WORK ON.
ANYONE ELSE HERE. FIRST WHAT
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS WE HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME TOGETHER ON THE
PHONE- AND- YOU KNOW
NEGOTIATIONS CAN BE TOUGH- IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO ME THAT
MAKE SURE WE'RE MAKING
LEGISLATION THIS WORKABLE IN A
LARGE ESTATE AS LARGE AND
DIVERSE CALIFORNIA. IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE. THE MAINTAINING
ACCESS LANGUAGE ACCESS TO CARE
LANGUAGE WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME. THERE WERE MANY EMPTY
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH ME
AS WE STRUGGLE WITH THE
EFFECTIVE COVERT NINETEEN HAS
HAD ON OUR POPULATION ECONOMY
MAKING SURE COMMUNITIES DON'T
LOSE ACCESS TO CARE ESPECIALLY
THROUGH A HOSPITAL CLOSURE. IS
IMPERATIVE AND THAT MEANT THAT
AMEND WILL ENSURE THE AG ALSO
HAS THE ABILITY TO HIM APPROVED
CHANGE THE SECOND OF CONTROL
THAT MAINTAINS RATHER AND
ACCESS OF CARE. YOU KNOW I HAVE
A HOSPITAL IN MY DISTRICT THAT-
WAS ON THE REALLY ON THE ON THE
ROPES. AND WAS WAS LOOKING AT
CLOSURE- FORTUNATELY ANOTHER
HOSPITAL SYSTEM WAS ABLE TO
COME IN AND THROUGH AN
OPERATING AGREEMENT THAT THAT
AWESOME THAT HOSPITAL IS
REMAINING OPEN THEY WILL
ACTUALLY- BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THE SYSTEM THEY WILL
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE WHAT. YOU'RE
WITH THE INTENT WAS ORIGINALLY
WHICH WAS TO IMPROVE CARE I DO
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE OF THE
SIZE OF THEIR SYSTEM. BUT THERE
ARE OTHER COMMUNITIES OUT THERE
WHERE AN ACQUISITION OR OR
CHAIN OF CONTROL. MIGHT JUST
MAINTAIN IT N. AND THAT AND
THAT MAY BE ENOUGH. FOR THAT
COMMUNITY. I THINK THE HARD
THING FOR ME- IS THAT. WE ARE
WORKING TO TRY TO FIND A WAY TO
MAIN YOU KNOW. MAINTAIN THE
COST OF CARE SO THAT IS
REASONABLE FOR PEOPLE THIS IS A
BILL ABOUT CONSUMERS. WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE SYSTEM. THAT
IS CLOSE TO US ALLOWED FOR THE
INCREASE IN COST. FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO BE 2230% HIGHER
THAN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE CONSOLIDATION OF
THE SYSTEM. THAT TO ME IS
UNFAIR. AND THAT IS THE MEAT OF
THE ISSUE THAT IS WHY THE BILL
IS HERE. YOU KNOW YOU MAY ARGUE
THAT THE BREADTH OF THE BILL
AND ALL OF THAT. BUT WHAT WE'RE
ALWAYS TROUBLES ME IN THESE IS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT I FEEL LIKE.
THE EMPHASIS HAS HAS BEEN ON
THE OPPOSITION TO MORE TO KILL
THE BILL. THEN TO RECOGNIZE AND
WORK WITH US IN A MINUTE. THE
COSTS ARE TOO HIGH. THE COST
THAT IT IS NOT AFFORDABLE
ANYMORE. WHEN THE COST OF
HEALTH CARE DOUBLE IS RISES AT
TWICE THE RATE OF INFLATION YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT AND
RECOGNIZED THERE IS A PROBLEM.
BUT AT TIMES THE INTERESTS ARE
SO LARGE. THE INTERESTS ARE SO
GREAT. THAT WE OFTEN IGNORE
THAT NOW THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT OUR HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLE LIFELINE TO US.
RIGHT NOW ABSOLUTELY WHERE WE'D
BE WITHOUT THEM. BUT THERE ARE
BAD ACTORS. THERE ARE BAD
ACTORS AND WE HAVE TO WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT AND SO I'M
I'M GOING TO PRIVACY SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL WE WORKED EXTENSIVELY
ON THIS SIDE BY BETWEEN THIS
BILL AND ANOTHER BILL WE HEARD
EARLIER HI. YOU KNOW THEY WERE
DONE THEIR MEMBERS AND BUDGET
SURE WHICH BILL I WAS WORKING
ON QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE THIS
BEEN THAT IT'S BEEN THAT
INTENSE BUT BUT I APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS- YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE A
GOOD MAN TO WORK WITH YOU'RE
NOT OF A MAN YOU HAVE YOUR YOU
HAVE YOUR HEART RIGHT. I
BELIEVE THIS I BELIEVE THIS IS
A BETTER BILL BECAUSE OF OUR
WORK TOGETHER IS IT IS IT
PERFECT WELL THERE IS NO
PERFECT ALL AND HOPE THAT WE
YOU KNOW THIS BODY WILL ALLOW
THE WORK TO CONTINUE IF THERE
IS A DESIRE FOR ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS AND- IT'S STILL TIME
IN MY TIME WE GOT WE GOT THE ON.
SO WE GET TO THE THIRTY FIRST
OF AUGUST SO WITH WITH WITH
THAT. I'M SORRY. WITH HAVE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO A CENTER
MONEY THANK YOU VERY IS
CHAIRMAN I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY AND I DO A THE ON AND
JUST TO HIGH A COUPLE OF THE
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE. THE
OPERATING. OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
PATIENTS ARE CONSTITUENTS.
THERE WAS AN EXAMPLE GIVEN OF
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NETWORK-
THAT WAS PURSUED THROUGH ANTI
ANTI TRUST AUTHORITY OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THAT
DIDN'T REACH CLOSURE UNTIL
YEARS AFTER. THE PAYERS
PATIENTS UNIONS THAT MAINTAIN
COVERAGE FOR THEIR MEMBERS
BUSINESSES THAT MAINTAIN
COVERAGE FOR THEIR MEMBERS. IN
A SETTLEMENT IT WAS DETERMINED
THAT THEY OVER CHARGED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. THAT
LITIGATION NOBODY GOT A REMEDY.
FOR FIVE YEARS SEVEN YEARS AND
STILL IN LITIGATION. IT'S NOT
JUST THAT ONE SYSTEM MEMBERS
STATEWIDE LOOK IN YOUR
DISTRICTS SOME MORE PRONOUNCED
THAN OTHERS NOT MY WORD THAT
USC UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
NEW YORK TIMES LA TIMES
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM RATES
ARE GOING UP IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
RATES ARE GOING UP IN A MANNER
NOT COMMENSURATE TO THE COST OF
LIVING. NOT COMMENSURATE TO THE
COST OF SUPPLIES WERE
PHARMACEUTICALS RATES ARE GOING
UP BECAUSE OF MARKET DOMINATION.
THAT IS ON STEROIDS RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY DURING OUR
ECONOMIC CRISIS. WE ARE THE
LINE BETWEEN OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND THESE MARKET FORCES IT IS
LONG AS WE LIVE IN A FOR PROFIT
MEDICAL SYSTEM THE DRIVING
MOTIVES. OF THESE LARGE SYSTEMS
IS TO MAXIMIZE. YOU MAXIMIZE
PROFIT BY MINIMIZING SERVICE.
IN BY DOMINATING A REGION.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT US AGAINST.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DOESN'T
SEEK TO BLOCK TRANSACTIONS
AFFILIATIONS THAT'S NOT MY
INTENT OUR INTENT IS TO PROTECT.
JUST QUICKLY IN MY OWN DISTRICT
TWO EXAMPLES ONE WITH THE
NONPROFIT IN SOUTH SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHERE A BUYER FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LARGE
HOSPITAL NETWORK. SOUGHT TO
SECURE AN AREA IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS SOUTH SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AN AGRICULTURAL AREA THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL KAMALA HARRIS
WHO HAD JURISDICTION. BECAUSE
IT WAS A NONPROFIT INVOLVED
WITH THE PERFORMER PROFIT.
TRIED TO SECURE A COMMITMENT
FROM THE BUYER TO MAINTAIN
EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES IN
SOUTH COUNTY. THE BUYER WAS NOT
WILLING TO MAKE THAT COMMITMENT
THE SALE WAS NOT APPROVED UNDER
EXISTING LAW. THAT FACILITY WAS
NOW ACQUIRED BY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. BY THE COUNTY HEALTH
SYSTEM AND WE MAINTAINED
SERVICES TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
FLIP OVER TO WATSONVILLE ONE OF
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE
AVERAGE FAMILY INCOME EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FAMILY
NOT INDIVIDUAL. PRIVATE
WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL. FOR SALE
IN DISTRESS BUT BY A HEDGE
FUND. THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
TRUST THE COMMUNITY BASED
CLINICS WENT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THE SERRA AND ASKED
FOR HIM TO REVIEW THIS SALE TO
PROTECT SERVICES IN WATSONVILLE
AN HOUR AWAY FROM SANTA CRUZ
EMERGENCY ROOM AN HOUR AWAY
FROM SALINAS LIFE AND DEATH.
THE GENERAL SAID SORRY I DON'T
HAVE JURISDICTION. THIS IS A
FOR PROFIT HEDGE FUND. FROM OUT
OF STATE ACQUIRING A FOR PROFIT
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. SO THAT
SALE WENT THROUGH. AND NOW THE
COMMUNITY WAIT TO SEE ESSEL
VALUABLE LAND OWNED BY THE
HOSPITAL THAT THE COMMUNITY
WANT TO USE FOR NURSING HOUSING
HOUSING FOR NURSES. FOR
CHILDCARE FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. ON THE AUCTION BLOCK.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO GIVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL REVIEW A THORNY. WITH
THE STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP.
AND IT EMPOWERS FRIENDS OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINIC OUR COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES. TO SAY THIS
TRANSACTION IS TAKING PLACE MR
OR MRS ATTORNEY GENERAL MILLS
ATTORNEY GENERAL WE WANT YOU TO
HELP US MAKE SURE. THAT WE
PROTECT EXISTING SERVICES WHERE
POSSIBLE THAT WE EXPAND
SERVICES. WE ARE IN A HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THAT IS IN CRISIS
THAT IS DRIVEN ITS LIFEBLOOD IS
PROFIT IT'S MOTIVATION
SECONDARILY I WOULD SUBMIT IS
CARE AND CONCERN FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. THERE SIX SECTIONS
TO THIS I'M. CONCERNED THAT
MANY OF THE OPPONENTS WOULD NOT
FALL UNDER THE SCOPE OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND WHAT IN FACT BE
PROTECTED BY IT. A GROUP OF
OPTOMETRISTS ARE DENTISTS OR
DOCTORS WHO WANT TO MERGE WITH
EACH OTHER OR LEASE A BUILDING
OR TWO GROUPS GET TOGETHER.
THIS BILL THERE'S NO TRIGGER
THAT. THEY'RE NOT INVOLVED IN
THAT REVIEW. UNLESS THEY HAVE A
HEDGE FUND. OR AN INVESTOR
GROUP BEHIND THEM AND EVEN
THERE IT DOESN'T PREVENTIVE IT
JUST SAYS OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING
TO REVIEW AND MAKE SURE THE
COMMUNITY IS PROTECTED. SO
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF. WANT TO THANK
EACH OF YOU I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY. I'VE HAD THE
pOF YOU. I LOOK FORWARD. TO YOUR
VOTE THIS EVENING THAT LETS US
MOVE THIS. CONVERSATION FOR
CALIFORNIA FORWARD AND ALL MY
DOOR WILL REMAIN OPEN. TWO
LISTENING TO YOUR CONCERNS TO
EXPLORING OTHER AMENDMENTS. OUR
HOPE WOULD BE TO MOVE TO
APPROPRIATIONS FROM HERE.
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS. AS
OFFERED BY THE CHAIR. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR MONEY- WE HAVE A
MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER NAZARIAN A SECOND BY
MR BONTA THE MOTION WOULD BE-
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN TWO BASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD
I'D MACE MACE KNOW AGUIAR-CURRY.
I I'D- BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA
ICEBERG. CORREO AEREO I FLORA
FLORA NO HE MOANED. LIMóN NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS. RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON NOW.
FIVE ICE FOR KNOWS I WILL LEAVE
BILL ON SAN DIEGO SANTIAGO III
SIX ICE. THE BILL A CALL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JUST TOOK A LITTLE BIT OF AN
ANNOUNCEMENT HERE AS WE MOVE
ON. TO WE HAVE A SENATOR PAN IS
GONNA JOIN US NEXT- IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY WE'RE WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO LIMIT OUR TESTIMONY OF THE
ME TOOS. SO WE'RE NOT LIMITING
THE TESTIMONY OF OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL TAKE TEN PER
SIDE- AND ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
BE LISTED AS A ME TOO THAT- HAS
HAD DOESN'T. ISN'T CALLED IN
TONIGHT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT YOUR- YOUR MESSAGE TO US
THROUGH OUR PORTAL AND THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECORD SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT THAT IS RECORDED FOR
THE RECORD SO- WITH THAT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO- THEM I'VE
NEVER EIGHT S. B. FOUR OH SIX
BY SENATOR PAM. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU CHAIR WH AND
MEMBERS. GOOD EVENING. SB FOUR
OH SIX IS NON TO. ON THE BILL
THAT THAT DOES THE FIRST TO
CODIFY THE FORMAL CARE ACT
PROVISIONS REGARDING ANNUAL AND
LIFETIME LIMITS AND PREVENTIVE
SERVICES. EXTENDS THE SUNSET ON
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM ARCHER BURKE.
FOR TWO YEARS. CLARIFIES THE
LAW REGARDING RECOVERY
RESIDENCES AND CLEANS UP AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX- AUTHORED
BY SOME OR STONE OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN REGARDING THE STATE
ORGANIC PROGRAM. ALSO THERE ARE
MANY MINTS THAT WOULD ALSO
EXTEND THE ELECTRONIC VITAL
RECORDS PROGRAM BY ONE YEAR
ADDED URGENCY RELATED TO CURE
BURKE WHICH EXPIRED ON JULY
FIRST AND CLARIFY THAT
SPECIALIZED PLANS THAT DON'T
COVER. ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS ARE EXEMPT FROM THE
ANNUAL LIFETIME LIMIT
PROVISIONS- THERE'S NO ARE
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THE MOTION A SECOND- ARE
WITNESSES THAT OUR WITNESS
TESTIFYING FROM ABOVE IS THAT.
WHAT I UNDERSTAND. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS NICK LOUISA'S
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS- TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
YEAH YEAH I JUST BRIEFLY- WE
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHORHE
GRACIOUSLY TOOK AMENDMENTS TO
THE ACA COMPLIANT. OF THE BILL
THAT WERE SUGGESTED BY THE PLAN
THE NEEDS CHANGES CHANGES
STRENGTH IN. THOSE PROVISIONS
IN WHAT AVOID ANY KIND
CONSEQUENCE A YOU KNOW AS THE
AUTHOR STATED. THE BILL EXT THE
OFFER DATE OF BIRTH PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES THE IN CAR
ANOTHER ANALYSIS TO LATEST ON
MAY BILL. ON THAT PROGRAM IS
THROUGH AND FEE HEALTH PLANS
AND ARE YOU KNOW OUR MEMBERS.
BAD FOR THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM-
FOR A LIMITED YET VERY
IMPORTANT. PURPOSE AND SO FOR
THE REASONS DASH CAPITA SUPPORT
OF S. B. SAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH WE HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS THE PHONE. GOOD EVENING
THAT CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS DIANA
THE MONTH ON BEHALF OF HOW
ACTIVE CALIFORNIA THE PEOPLE
HEALTH CARE. AND COALITION WE
ARE ALSO PLEASED WITH THE POOR
SB OF SIX WHICH AS WE HAVE TO
DISCUSS WITH. HEALTH LAWS VITAL
PROVISION OF THE EIGHT AND WE
CAN. THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFITS PRO. AT THE OH SIX ONE
CALIFORNIA'S CONTAIN ACT TO
PRESS CARE FREE FROM COKE
ANOTHER COSTS. AND PREVENT
PLANS WISHING DEVON LIKE LIMIT
ON COVERAGE. I'D BE ABLE TO
AUTHORED BURKE AND WE SUPPORT
ADEQUATE NUMBERS OUT THE FOR
ALL THE AFFECTING HEALTH AND
MANDATE FOR PROBABLY FORTY FOUR
SIXTEEN AFTER I ABOUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONCERN. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES AS
A- UP IN THE- GALLERY JUST YOUR
NAME AND OR- PLAY SURE GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS CORR ON THE
DRY OF THE CHIU PRO. I IN
SUPPORT HERE IS A PER CITIZEN
THANK THANK YOU. JUSTER NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
OBJECTS PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT A LINE.
WHICH THREE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF
OF THE- COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALIVE ALIVE AND SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE'S BEEN
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FOR SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS MARK CURTIS ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THE PHYSICALLY OF THE
MAN THAT HE NOTICED ANY NOT
THAT THE PROVIDES TO ELECTRONIC
REQUEST A VITAL RECORDS THANK
YOU SO MUCH COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M ALIE IN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY INTO PORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
ALIVE AND ALL SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THERMIC DATING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN THREE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHARE A COUPLE WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ALIVE IN SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHERRI DALY WITH THE
HELP CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS AND
PORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE RIGHT NOW LIVE IN SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS AYE MARKLAND
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IN PARTICULARLY IN SUPPORT
OF AMENDMENT FIVE B. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY I THINK THAT
THAT'S TENS OF THAT WILL BE OUR
OUR OUR LIMIT OF SUPPORT IF
ANYBODY ELSE IS IN SUPPORT OF
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THAT
WITH THIS PLEASE FEEL FREE TO.
SEND US A NOTE THROUGH OUR
PORTAL. AT THIS POINT WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON IS
THERE IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED WITNESSES FOR- FOR
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION. SIR
ANYBODY IN THEIR WITNESS ROOM
IN OPPOSITION NO THERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
MADAM MADAM A MODERATOR YOU'RE
WELCOME TO OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANY OPPOSITION JUST THE. LET
HIM TALK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
HAVE ONE THAT QUEUED UP IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT OKAY THANK
YOU. BY ELEVEN- TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS I DON'T KNOW
IT'S A BIG GAME OR NOT AND
BOTTOM FORTY THIRD BIG PEOPLE
AND THAT WAS THE BILL. I THINK.
THANK YOU. YES SIR ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU AT THE TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE FOR THE AUTHOR.
SEEN NONE. WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION BY MISTER RAMOS A
SECOND BY MR RAMON THE MOTION
WE DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
DR PAM WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ITS RESPECTFULLY ASK OUR
NEIGHBORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
DR PAM MILLER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SB FOUR
OH SIX WOOD I WOULD I'D MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW BIGELOW II BONTA BONTA
I'D BURKE. DARIO THREE OH AYE
FLORA FLORA I LIMóN. LIMóN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. WAS IT NAZARIAN AYE
RAMOS. RAMOS I'D RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON I. BURKE I SANTIAGO.
FOURTEEN ICE ZERONOS BILL
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BELIEVE THE ROLE OF AN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS YOU HAVE ANOTHER
BILL SENATOR GET HANDS SB TWO
TEN TWENTY NINE THIS THANK YOU
AT YOUR WORDS AND NUMBERS- I'M
PLEASE PERCENT S. B. TEN TWENTY
NINE I FIRST WILL BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TEN
ELEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS THANK U.
S. B. THANK YOU. SB TEN TWENTY
NINE IS A DISTRICT BILL OFF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY TO ESTABLISH
A LOCAL HEALTH AUTHORITY
THROUGH A COUNTY ORDINANCE THE
HEALTH AUTHORITY WILL BE ABLE
TO DESIGNATE WHICH PLANTS CAN
COMPETE FOR THE STATE CONTRACT
FOR MEDIC CAL PROVIDE ON GOING
LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY THIS BILL
ALSO PROVIDES THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE HEALTH OF GOING TO
COUNTY TO ENACT OTHER FORMS
LIKE TRANSITIONING TO A TWO
PLAN MODEL COUNTY. FOR MANY
YEARS SACRAMENTO'S GEOGRAPHIC
MANAGED CARE MODEL HAS CAUSED
PROBLEMS FOR BENEFICIARIES AND
PROVIDERS ALIKE EXISTING SYSTEM
IS FRAGMENTED LEADING TO
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS FOR
PROVIDERS DIFFICULT EXCESS CARE
FOR PATIENTS RADICALLY ONE OF
THE REASONS FOR THIS BILL HAS
BEEN THE LACK OF COORDINATION
BETWEEN OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM
HEALTH PLANS WHICH ONLY
CORRECT. LEAGUE CONTRACT WITH
THE STATE AND NOT GET ANY
COUNTY OR LOCAL INPUT AND
INTEGRATION WITH LOCAL- COUNTY
PROGRAMS LIKE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THIS COURSE HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED WITH KOBE- SO IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN A BROAD
GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS BEGAN TO
MEET TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
AND TO DEVELOP THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
MEDICARE ON SACRAMENTO AND
pROBUST LOCAL OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ALLOW THIS
KIND OF. INTEGRATION AND
PARTNERSHIP SO SB TWENTY NINE
ESSENTIALLY DOES THAT THROUGH
THE NEW HEALTH AUTHORITY
SACRAMENTO STAKEHOLDERS WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
PRESSING LOCAL MEDIC CAL ISSUES
AND HELP DETERMINE THE PLAN TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL SERVICES IN THE
COUNTY IN THIS IS ACTUALLY
FAIRLY SIMILAR TO WHAT MANY
COUNTIES ALREADY HAVE IN THEIR
OWN COUNTIES JUST THAT
SACRAMENTO DOES NOT. WE HAVE
SEEN THAT THE COVER NINETEEN
CRISIS EXACERBATES PROBLEMS
CAUSED BY THE STATE CUSTOM
ESTABLISHING TISSUE BETWEEN.
MEDIC COW WE REPRESENTS OF OVER.
OF ALL OUR- PEOPLE IN THE SAN
COUNTY INCLUDE COUNTING FOR
HEALTH IMPROVE SEX COUNTY
CAPACITY TO DRAW COVERT NOW.
FINALLY NEEDS IS PLANNING TO
CONDUCT A STATE RE PROCUREMENT
OF MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
NEXT YEAR AND SB TEN TWENTY
NINE MAKE SURE THAT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY STAKEHOLDERS HAVE A
VOICE IN THAT UPCOMING PROCESS
AND IN ITS OWN MEDICAL PROGRAM
FOR YEARS TO COME. SO STRICTLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE AND I HAVE DR
PETER BILLINGTON WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR COUNTY HEALTH.
DEPARTMENT FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY ON THE PHONE TO SPEAK
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WITH A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND A WITNESS ON THE
PHONE MATTER MODERATOR PLEASE
ALLOW OUR WITNESS TO. PROVIDE
HIS TESTIMONY. DON'T SEE PETER
DIALEDIN IF YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE LINE PLEASE PRESS STAR
ZERO. OVERWEIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY. IN
SUPPORT. NO ONE IN OUR WITNESS
ROOM. YOU HAVE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. MADAM MADAM MODERATOR.
I DON'T SEE DR PETER WHITE IN
JUST YET IS THERE IS A DO YOU
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. EVERY GIRL I AM
SEVEN THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS KATHY MUST WORK WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE AUTHOR AND AFTER
PAN WE AGREE AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU A LINE ALIVE IN
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANA DOUGLAS WITH HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALIVE ALIVE IN THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
Q. AND A LINE ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS DR
PETER BEYOND. ARBON OF HEALTH
SERVICES DIRECTOR FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M SPEAKING
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN
TWENTY NINE FOR OVER TWO
DECADES MEDI CAL SACRAMENTO IS
THE RUN AS PART OF THE- MANAGED
CARE SYSTEM UTILIZED ONLY BY
SACRAMENTO AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. HOWEVER SAN DIEGO
COUNTY HAS FAR MORE ABILITY TO
HOLD THE METAL CAL MEDI CAL
MCOT COUNTABLE THEIR GMC
STRUCTURE THANK TO LEGISLATIVE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. INDEED SACRAMENTO
COUNTY HAS VIRTUALLY NO POWER
TO HOLD MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR
JURISDICTION ACCOUNTABLE EITHER
ON HOW COMMON SATISFACTION
METRICS. OR ON INFLUENCING
CONTRACTS WITH THE MC OF. THIS
LACK OF OVERSIGHT HAS RESULTED
IN A SITUATION WHERE FOUR OF
THE FIVE PARTICIPATING NGOS IN
SACRAMENTO ARE IN THE BOTTOM
QUARTILE OF ALL MEDICARE ALLEN
CHAU STATE WIDE IN TERMS OF
OUTCOMES. AT THE CENTER PAN IS
MENTIONED. SB TEN TWENTY NINE
GIVE THE COUNTY TEETH IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS. IT'S SET UP A
SACRAMENTO COUNTY MEDICARE
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION THE POWERS
THAT COMMISSION TO BOTH HOLDEN
CEOS ACCOUNTABLE FOR ACHIEVING
CERTAIN GOALS AS WELL AS GIVEN
THE POWER TO DO COUNTY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER AN MCO WILL
BE ALLOWED TO BID ON FUTURE MCO
PROCUREMENT. BY STRUGGLING MEDI
CAL NCOS WILL HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OVERSIGHT COMMISSION
EVERY SPONTANEOUS CONCERNS THIS
OVERSIGHT ABILITY WILL MOST
CERTAINLY RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN ACCESS TO AND
QUALITY OF. THAT CARE FOR THE
COUNTIES FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND MEDICARE RECIPIENTS
AND I HAVE HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN ALIVE IN FORTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MY GOOD DAY
CHILDREN NOW IMPORT YOUR. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. BRING IT THE C.
A. R. R. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION AND LOOKING IN THE
CHAMBER AND NO ONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
OUR ROOM SIR ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL- PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR OPPOSITION MADAM MODERATOR.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. I'M
SORRY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
LIFE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE FOR SENATOR
PAM. MISTER NAZARIAN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. CENTER THIS BILL
HAVE ANY STATEWIDE APPLICATION.
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT AGAIN YOU
ARE COURSE DOESN'T HAVE A
STATEWIDE APPLICATION. SO
CERTAINLY THIS BILL IS A
DISTRICT BILL WOULD ADDRESSES
AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. OKAY I THINK
MANY OF US TO CARRY DISTRICT
BILLS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
INTERFACES BETWEEN STATE
PROGRAMS THAT'S WHY REQUIRE A
STATE BILL. AND THE LOCAL
SITUATION. OKAY SO IT'S A VERY
LOCALIZED BILL WITHOUT.
IMPACTING OR BENEFITING THE
ENTIRE STATE TO GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC RAGING THROUGH THE
STATE DOES THIS BILL NEEDS TO
BE PASSED THIS YEAR. I WOULD
SAY THAT THIS BILL ACTUALLY
WOULD IMPROVE THE INTEGRATION
BETWEEN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. WHICH OF COURSE HAS
TREMENDOUS RESPONSIBILITIES
DURING KOBE AND OUR MEDICAL
CARE SYSTEM THAT IS TAKING CARE
OF THESE CODED PATIENTS AND SO
IN FACT EVEN. BEFORE KOBE CAME
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MAIN
DRIVERS OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL
BUT CERTAINLY COVE IT HAS
ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHTED HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY BE. PASSED HERE SO WE
COULD ACTUALLY GIVE THE COUNT
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO. BRING
THE PLANS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TOGETHER SO THEY CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO CONTACT
OPENS UP THE- ACCOUNT.
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT. HEALTH PLAN.
DOES SO YOUR CLIENT REALLY. A
COMPLAINTS YOU'RE BASICALLY
TELLING ME THAT ESTABLISHING A
LOCAL TWENTY MEMBER COMMISSION.
WILL HELP THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONA VIRUS. WELL I WOULD SAY
THAT THE OPRAH SITE THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDED AT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WHICH CURRENTLY HAS NO.
AUTHORITY TO OVERSEE THE
MEDICARE HEALTH PLANS
ESSENTIALLY MEANS OVERSEE MEDIC
COW AT ALL BECAUSE WE HAVE
GEOGRAPHIC MANAGED CARE WOULD
MEAN THAT THEREFORE THERE IS
LITTLE INTEGRATION BETWEEN OUR
MEDICARE PROGRAM WHICH COVERS
YOU HEARD FROM DOCTOR PHELAN
SENT. OVER YOU KNOW FOUR PEOPLE
OR A THIRD A THIRD OF ALL THAT
RESIDENTS OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
INTO PUBLIC HEALTH EFFORTS AND
I THINK THAT THAT'S IN TYPE OF
UNIT. THAT SHOULD HAPPEN AS
POINT OUT THAT MANY OTHERS HE'S
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THERE ACTUALLY IS. COUNTY INPUT
INTO THEIR MANAGED CARE GRAHAM
RELATED ATTIC HOUSE WHETHER
THEY ACTUALLY OPERATE BECAUSE
THEY AS A PLAN. EVERYONE PLAN.
OR BMC WHICH TWENTY TWENTY IS
THE ONLY OTHER COUNTY TO THAT
THERE'S A LANGUAGE IN THERE THE
CO TO ALLOW THEM TO PROVIDE
THAT INPUT TO THEIR DEGREE
MATCH CARE PLANS HOWEVER IN
SACRAMENTO DOES NOT EXIST SO
THIS ESSENTIALLY ESTABLISHES
DATAPOWER. AND IT HAS TO HAPPEN
THIS YEAR THAT WENT IN A TIME
WHEN WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING. ON
THE CORVETTE NINETEEN IMPACTS
AND MANY BILLS HAVE BEEN CAST
ASIDE AND SACRIFICE THIS THIS
YEAR IS THE YEAR TO DO THIS
BILL. BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
DIRECTLY IMPACT THE CORONAVIRUS
ISSUE. I WOULD SAY IT CERTAINLY
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO THE PEOPLE
OF SACRAMENTO. THAT THIS
HAPPENS AS I POINTED OUT THAT
ACTUALLY THIS BILL WAS ACTUALLY
INITIALLY DRIVEN BY THIS
DISCONNECT BETWEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OUR HEALTH AND OUR
MEDICAL PROGRAM WHICH WE VERY
INTENSIFIED EVEN PRE CODED. AS
A SAID THAT AND SO THE FACT
THAT KOVITZ COME ABOUT BECAUSE
ONLY UNDERSCORED HOW IMPORTANT
MOVING THE BILL FORWARD IS AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH SERVICES ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE. AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH MANY
OTHER STATE THERE SO IS THE
PART OF A PROCESS IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR OVER A YEAR BUT I
WOULD POINT. TOLD IS ONLY UNDER.
THE BILL IS PARTICULARLY DURING
ED OF THE- TO IN PUBLIC HEALTH
AND OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM. HI MR
SHAPIRO MAYBE JUST. MAKING
FINAL COMMENT. YOU KNOW I WE
HEAR A LOT OF THINGS AND WE
HEAR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ARGUING A CERTAIN. POINT BILLS
HAVE BEEN HELD THAT HAVE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPACT PEOPLE'S
LIVES. RIGHT NOW. AND YET
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IMPACTING
ONLY ONE PART OF THE STATE IS
BEING BROUGHT UP AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IN ANY WAY.
BENEFITS THE ENTIRE STATE SO- I
WILL NOT BE VOTING FOR THIS
SENATOR. THANK YOU ARE THERE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
SENATOR PAM. XENON WILL BRING-
WILL SAVE THE BILL DOES HAVE A
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS YES IN YOUR OPENING
SO. IT HAD A IT HAD A MOTION IN
NINE IN THE SECOND FROM OVER
HERE SOMEWHERE AND I CAN'T. WAS
THIS THE MOMENT WAS THIS MOTION.
SECOND MISS AGUIAR-CURRY OR
VICE VERSA- MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL UP IN A
CLOSE PLEASE. OH I'M SORRY YEAH
YOU CAN DO THAT NEVER MIND.
YEAH I DON'T ORDER WHAT I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL I APPRECIATE- THE- WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT CERTAINLY IT'S EACH
MEMBER'S PREROGATIVE DECIDE HOW
THEY WANT TO VOTE I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE IN FACT
I THINK EVEN THIS COMMITTEE
HEARD THE DISTRICT BILLS
BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE TO DRESS
NEEDS IN OUR DISTRICT EVEN
RELATE TO COVET. I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT EACH OF US WHO
HAVE. HAD THE- RELIGION BUT
ALSO THE DUTY OF CHAIRING
COMMITTEES AND HAD TO MAKE HARD
DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH BILLS
THIS YEAR OR NOT. IN FACT I HAD
A BILL IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
WHICH THE CHAIR CHOSE NOT TO
HEAR. AND YOU KNOW WHAT I EVEN
THOUGH I WAS IMPORTANT TO ME
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
RELEVANT. TO OUR CALVET BECAUSE
THAT DEAL WITH PUBLIC HEALTH. I
ALSO RESPECTED THE DECISION OF
THAT CHAIR. SO WE ALL HAVE TO
MAKE HARD DECISIONS. AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT IS A
DISTRICT BILL. AND WE ALL MANY
OF US CARRY DISTRICT BILLS WE
NEED TO TRY TO SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS AS WELL. AND
CERTAINLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ITEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR PAN AND JUST TO CLARIFY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. M. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB TEN
TWENTY NINE DUE PROCESS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WARD BY WARD
I'D MAYES. OUR GEAR CURRY I GET
A CURRY I BIGELOW. BONTA BONTA
I'D BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO NOT VOTING FLORA.
LIMóN LIMóN AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
NOT VOTING RAMOS. RAMOS NOT
VOTING. RAMOS NOT BOATING
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO. WALDRON. SIX I ZERO
NO BILLING CALL IT A CALL TO DO
BEFORE YOU- FREEDOM PART SENATE
HAND MY- I NEED TO ASK AYE ON
THE LAST BILL- YOU'RE A B. R.
S. B. FOUR OH SIX YOU DID
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THERE
WERE YES I DID JUST LET US
CLARIFICATIONS OF THE MOTION.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AND IT WAS NOT
SO- IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS SO
I'M I'M CLEAR FIND OF THAT
MOTION AS WITH YOU HERE NOW AND
THEN- IF I THINK ABOUT WAS
FOURTEEN ZERO SO- SO WE'LL WILL
BE AFFECTED SO OKAY THANK THANK
YOU WHEN THE REMOTE YOUR BILL
UP OKAY THANK YOU. MOVING YES
SIR FIFTY EIGHT SENATOR DINO.
GOOD EVENING- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME PRESENT SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOUR STAFF
AND MY STAFF AND EVERYONE FOR
WORKING SO DILIGENTLY ON THIS
BILL TO GET IT TO WHERE IT IS
TONIGHT HOSPITALS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVE RESPONDED
QUICKLY TO THE CORONA VIRUS
PANDEMIC. CONVERTING PHYSICAL
SPACE TO SPEND MANY PROCEDURES
AND SERVICES PURCHASING
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
FOR EMPLOYEES AND STAFF AND
BRING ADDITIONAL STAFF AND MUCH
MUCH MORE- WITH GREAT DEDICATED
EMPLOYEES WHO GO ON THE FRONT
NINE THREE SINGLE DAY. THE
SHORT A LOT OF THE NEEDS AS WE
READ IN THE PAPER AND SEE.
EVERY DAY NO ONE SHOULD HAVE A
LEVEL ONE. AFFECTED BY THIS
PANDEMIC BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT
JUST ABOUT EVERY FAMILY HAS-
WITH NEARLY FORTY COUNTRIES
ACTION WE COUNTIES ON THE WATCH
LIST AND OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
HOSPITALIZATIONS. HOSPITALS ARE
ENGAGED IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
RESPONSE TO THIS PANDEMIC. THE
EFFORT IS CONSUMED
PROPOSITIONAL CAPACITY AND
DEVASTATED THEM FINANCIALLY
MANY HOSPITALS THIS MEANS THEY
MUST HALT ALL NON CRITICAL
OPERATIONS AND RECONSIDER MAJOR
EXPENDITURES THIS INCLUDES THE
TWENTY THIRTY SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS. THIS MANDATE
REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO RICH TO
RETROFIT AND REPLACEMENT
HOSPITAL BUILDINGS TO ENSURE
THAT THE OPERATIONAL AFTER A
MAJOR SEISMIC EVENT. ON AVERAGE
HOSPITAL REBUILDING TAKES
APPROXIMATELY TEN YEARS AND A
RECENT REPORT ESTIMATES THE
COST OF THE MAN THAT COULD BE
OVER A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
FOR HOSPITALS TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY DEADLINE- THEY
WOULD NEED TO BEGIN DEVELOPMENT
NOW. SENATE BILL SEVENTY
EXTENDS THE DEADLINE FOR THE
TWENTY THIRTY MANDATE TO TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN AND CREATES A
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
TO EXAMINE HOW CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
PREPARES IN RESPONSE. TO THE
MASTERS OF COPS UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCED TOO
MANY DISASTERS OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS WE'VE LEARNED MANY
LESSONS THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WILL EXAMINE
OUR RESPONSE AND RECOMMEND GET
YOUR PATHWAYS FOR STATE FOR THE
STATE. OUR HOSPITALS AND OUR
CARE SYSTEM TAKEN. I'M FIFTY
EIGHT LAUPEN HOSPITAL. THE
NEEDED TIME TO A- AND STABILIZE
FROM THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. BEFORE BEGINNING TO
MEET A SEISMIC OR OTHER
DISASTER REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOSPITALS IN THE IN MY DISTRICT
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS
WILL BE CRITICAL. TO ENSURE
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY AND
DRESS. DISASTERS WE BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LARGELY
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS REGARDING THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSION ON THE
REMAINDER OF THE CONCERNS
SHOULD THE BILL MOVE OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. THERE'S WORK
TO BE DONE AND WE'RE ALL READY
TO DO IT. ON THE PHONE TEST OF
I HAVE CAPTURE. AUSTIN SCOTT
WITH A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND KAREN. ANY
OTHER CEO OF MADERA COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL- I'M HAVING SAFE
WORKPLACE. I IT JUST ABILITY.
TO DO IT ARE NOT ME EXCLUSIVE
IN THIS BILL SEEKS TO MERGE
THOSE TWO IMPORTANT ENDEAVORS.
AND WITH THAT A LOT MY
WITNESSES TESTIFY. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER CATHOLIC
WITHOUT RETURNING CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AS
MENTIONED BY THE ALCOHOL
BREAKING THE MARK AS THEY
GRAPPLE WITH THEIR RESPONSE THE
CRIME BY. FIFTEEN DOCTORS FONG
WILL HAVE A LASTING EFFECT ON
OUR OPERATIONS ASIAN
RELATIONSHIPS AND FIND. THE
LOCKERS AND YET. OF THE. WILL
LOCK INTO NEXT. ALTHOUGH THE OF
THE TERM OF LONG TERM UP OR ON.
TO ABOUT. I THINK SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT OF THE VAN TO
REPORT FACTOR ON THE LAW TERM
OUT OF THE ENDEMIC. IT
UNDERSTAND AND TO OF A
RESPONSIBLE INCLUDING
DEVELOPING FOR THE NEXT. FIFTH
ON WHAT I'VE LEARNED FROM THE
AND PAST THE DOCTOR. AND A
SEVEN YEAR EXT OF THE TWENTY
THIRTY MANDATE REQUIRING
HOSPITALS. OPERATIONAL AFTER. A
MAJOR EARTHQUAKE AS WE THOUGHT
ABOUT THE EXPANSION RECOGNIZE
THE COUPLE OF THINGS. OCTOBER
FIFTH LARGE DEFICITS BRITAIN
INCOME FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
INCREASED EXPENSES. AND EXTREME
I'M CERTAIN. YOUR REVENUE.
EQUIFAX ARE REALLY TO INVEST
INTO ON THAT IN THE COMING YOU
MUST HAVE TIME THERE'S BEEN
THEIR KIDS OFF IN FOR THE HAVE
THE CONFIDENCE TO TAKE THE DEBT.
AND OR MAINTAIN THE BONTA WITH.
FOR THEM AND THE- BEFORE THE-
THIRD OF ALL HOSPITALS WERE IN
THE RED IT IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
OF THE TIME TO SAVE THEIR
OPERATIONS AND FINANCES FOR
FACING THE NUMBER EIGHT I WOULD
LIKE TO. TURN IT OVER CARE
YOU'LL ERA. SURE THEIR
EXPERIENCE KAREN. MR WILL AND
THEN THAT IS HELP COMMITTEE
HELLO MY NAME IS KAREN HALL
ALLEY AND IF YOU THINK OFFICER
MADERA COMMUNITY HOSPITAL THANK
YOU FOR PROVIDING ME WITH THIS
OPPORTUNITY. OUR COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL DEPRIVE PRIVATE NOT
FOR PROFIT INDEPENDENT ACUTE
CARE HOSPITAL. WE ARE
CONSIDERED A SAFETY NET
HOSPITAL FOR OUR COMMUNITY 80%
OF OUR PAYER MIX OF MEDI CAL.
ON MARCH SIXTH. MADERA
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL THE FIRST
HOSPITAL THAT THE TREVALLY CARE
BARCODE NINETEEN PATIENT. WE
HAVE SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PREPARING FOR THE THIRD WE ARE
NOW EXPERIENCING. IT IS A
PUBLIC NINETEEN WE HAVE WALKED
OUR PRIMARY REVENUE WHICH IS
SCHEDULED SURGERIES ARE IN THE-
NOW DOUBLE 50% OF OUR PATIENTS
ARE COVERED POSITIVE AND ARE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT FENCES. IS
THAT A HUNDRED THIRTY PERFECT.
WE HAVE A TRADE AMOUNT OF FOOD
THAT WE HAVE SPENT A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR CAFFEINE
MEDICAL THERAPY STAFFING.
STAFFING AGENCIES ARE CHARGING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR TO GET A
REGISTERED NURSE TO COME TO OUR
FACILITY. THE PANDEMIC HAS
ELEVATED THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
HOSPITAL IN OUR WORKFORCE AND
YET. HI MARK THIS IS NEVER BEEN
HAPPIER MA'AM FINANCES ARE
SUFFERING. YEAH MAKE IT. OUR
HOSPITAL FINANCIAL DATA BILL. I
HAVE A REPUTATION OF COMMON
SENSE AND DOING THE RIGHT THING
AND IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT FOR
YOU TO FIND A TESTIMONY FROM
ANYBODY MORE PASSIONATE ABOUT
PATIENT SAFETY THAN ME. OUR
GOAL IS TO BE OPERATIONAL IN
ANY KIND OF A CRISIS AND- WE
CANNOT REASONABLY BE TO FIVE
MINUTES FIVE MAKE REQUIREMENTS
CONSIDERING THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS OF THE CO THAT RESPONSE.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT MADERA
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL WOULD NEED
TO SPEND. THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE TO MEET THE
FIVE MEGAWATT REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE COST FOR
HOSPITALIZED FIVE. IT WILL TAKE
SEVERAL YEARS FOR OUR HOSPITAL
TO RECOVER FINANCIALLY. BECAUSE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE SUPPORT
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERING HOW. ARE
WILL PREPARE FOR DISASTERS.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC WE HAD
VERY GOOD CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
FINANCIAL ABILITY TO MEET THE
MANDATE. IN CLSING MR WORD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MEETING THESE REQUIREMENTS
WHICH SHUT DOWN OUR HOSPITAL
AND RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF
COBIT ORACLE HAS NEVER BEEN
MORE NEEDED BY OUR COMMUNITY.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. VERY MUCH- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY THERE'S NO
ONE IN OUR WITNESS ROOM SO-
MADAME MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR OTHERS IN
SUPPORT JUST NAME IN OUR- AND
WILL BE LIMITED TO TEN. PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT. IF YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
KARNATAKA ON BEHALF DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NINE TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
LIGHT THE CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
AT THE END OF HELP LEVEL WHEN
THE UNIVERSITY HEALTH PEAK AND
BEVERLY HOSPITAL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER TEN WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FIVE THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE
ARE A COUPLE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
THAT THE PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOHN COMPLAIN ABOUT THE SCRIPTS
HELP IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FIVE EIGHT THANK YOU. NINE
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING TELLING
BACK MILAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MEMORIAL HEALTH CARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FIVE ELEVEN
NINETY TWO PLEASE GOING. IT IS
MADDEN REPRESENTING WASHINGTON
TOWNSHIP HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
LOCATED IN FREMONT CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MEASURE
MEMBERS THIS IS FRED NOT WHERE
WITH STANFORD HEALTHCARE
SUPPORTING SENATOR PORTANTINO'S
SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW ELEVEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATHLEEN SORIANO ON BHALF OF
TECH MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BELIEVE THAT WAS TEN SO WILL.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OFFICE. AND IF
HAVE TO WITNESSES THE PHONE.
SEVERAL OF. WELL THE I BELIEVE.
MATT MATTER LUIGI. FOLLOWED BY
JR. SO THEY OPEN THE OPEN THE
LINES MADAM OPPER MIGHT MADAM
MODERATOR. JACKSON ABOUT MATT
IS NOT KEEPING. OKAY. PLEASE
SIR PLEASE PROCEED THEM. HI IF
YOU'RE HERE IN MEMBERS I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND APOLOGIZE ON
BEHALF OF MATT HE'S HAVING SOME
ISSUES GETTING HER ON THE PHONE
LINE UP AT THE TOP TO KIND OF
COVER BOTH OF OUR POINT- IF
THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU. THANK
YOU. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WE ARE UNITED WITH OUR LABOR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO I KNOW
YOU'VE ALL HEARD FROM THE
RECENTLY IN OPPOSITION AT THE
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT. LABOR HAS
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OCCURRENCE SPONSORS SINCE
JANUARY OF TWENTY NINETEEN. I
THANK I THINK THE SCANNER WHICH
CLEARLY PREDATE. THERE WERE
SOME TO OF PUBLIC. HEALTH INFO
HERE ON TWENTY. I THINK
REQUIREMENTS JUST SEVEN MONTHS
AGO EVEN THOUGH I KNOW IT SEEMS
LIKE A THOUSAND YEARS AGO. AND
YET ONLY A FEW WEEKS AGO THE
LANGUAGE YOU ARE VOTING TODAY
WHAT THAT AMENDED INTO THE
BILL. C. H. A. SAID THEY NEED
TO. CALL THE NINETEEN BUT THE
BILL INTRODUCTION DATE TELLS
THE TRUTH OF THE HOSPITAL'S
ORIGINAL INTENT. THE DESIRE FOR
THE HOSPITAL DID. TO GET OUT
FROM UNDER THE ENTIRE. I THINK
THEY DID. AND A BLANKET LAW
TERM NEXT. PUTS THEM THAT PATH.
LATER WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER MUCH MORE. TRIMIX
COMMENSURATE WITH THE LATEST IN
THE PAST. TELL ME ABOUT THE
TRAIN OF RECEIVE OF DOLLARS IN
FROM THE FEDERAL BILL AND ARE
LIKELY TO RECEIVE MORE IN THE
NEXT ROUND WE WOULD ALSO
REQUEST YOUR COMMITTEE AMEND
BILL TO INCLUDE STANDARDS THAT
ALLOW THE STATE TO COLLECT CASH
FROM THE AND REPORTS. AND OTHER
INFORMATION TO ENSURE ONLY
SMALL WORLD HOSPITAL TO THE
TROOPS FUNDING RIGHT THAT WILL
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT EXTENSION.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REQUIRE HOSPITALS
SUBMIT A COMPLIANCE SCHEDULE
DATE PROTECT YEAH AND WHAT THE
TENSION WITH NO INTENTION TO
EVER ACTUALLY COMPLY. BECAUSE
BILL WOULD BE DEAD OF THE
SENATE AND IT SUBSTANTIVE
POPCORN IT DOES NOT HAVE TO
RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE. MAYBE THE ONLY POLICY
COMMITTEE WEIGHING IN ON THAT
SUCH. WE LOOKING YEAH. PAUL
PEOPLE. THANK YOU WERE READ IN
TWENTY ONE IF YOU WILL NO ON
THE BILL TODAY. CALIFORNIA IS.
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
AMERICAN SURGERY. I THINK THAT
HYGIENE SUCH AS HAND WASHING
WILL GRIND TO A HALT BECAUSE
WATER WILL NOT BE COMING OUT OF
THE PRICE. THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS LAID BARE
THE TRAGEDIES. THAT OCCUR WHEN
HOSPITALS ARE NOT PREPARED FOR
DISASTERS. LET'S NOT MAKE THE
SAME MISTAKE TWICE. LABOUR
ASPREY OR NO WELL ON SB SEVEN
FIVE EIGHT IN ITS CURRENT FORM
THANK YOU RICHARD JR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO WE WILL WE HAVE
MADAM FROM POSSIBLY OR NOT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A- BETTER.
FUTURE THE SITE FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES GETTING
AND- MATHIS A ON BEHALF OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
ABOUT YEAH YOU. WARNING YOU'RE
PUTTING WITH OUR LABOR BROWN
AND SISTERS. SO OPPOSITION AND
A MESSAGE POSITION SB. BOB THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE ABOUT THAT
SEVEN EIGHT PUT CALIFORNIA ON A
PASS TO REPEAL A TWO THIRTY
STANDARD PUTTING ACCESS TO CARE
RISK AFTER SEISMIC ABOUT I
WOULD KOBE CRISIS SUCH US OUR
HELP YOUR MUST PREPARED. FOR
EMERGENCY BEFORE HIT
COMMUNITIES HAVE A RE I
HOSPITALS WILL BE A TO PROVIDE
DURING AND AFTER EMERGENCIES
WHEN WE NEED THEM THE MOST I
VOTE FOR THIS BILL IS A SIGNAL
TO YOUR COMMUNITY THAT
HOSPITALS DO NOT NEED TO BE
FULLY FUNCTIONAL AFTER
EARTHQUAKE WHIH IS A STANDARD
THAT BANK LATER THAN TWENTY
YEARS IN HOSPITAL YOU NEED
TWENTY THIRTY WE RECOGNIZE THE
REALITY OF THE CURRENT ECONOMIC
CRISIS AND WE BETTER SHORTER.
PENSION WOULD REQUIRE THE
HOSPITAL COULD TO MAKE TOWARDS
EXPANSION OR EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS IN LAW THERE BOTH
ALMOST ALL OF. TO BY THIS I
THINK THERE HAVE REQUIRED
HOSPITALS MAKE. REST EXISTING
LAW. THE LEGISLATURE HISTORY
ISRAEL HOSPITALS FOR. TEACHERS
THAT MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS
MEETING THE I THINK. AND WE
REQUIRE ANY REASONABLE. INCLUDE
THOSE REQUIRED IT IMPORTANTLY
IN THAT MEMBERS IN THEIR
CURRENT FORM- AS WE HAVE HEARD.
RUMORS ABOUT HAVE NOT SEEN THAT
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHARGE
DEVELOPING THOSE BENCHMARKS- SO
AS WE HAVE SEEN- I ONCE AGAIN
YEAH DURING THIS EMERGENCY
BABIES ARE STILL BEING BORED
SURGERY STILL NEED TO HAPPEN IN
CANCER PATIENTS STILL NEED TO
GET CARE. HOSPITAL THE EXISTING
TWENTY THIRD THE STANDARDS.
COME COMMUNITY HAVE THAT CAR.
CARE THAT IS SO IMPORTANT. IN
OUR VIEW THE CURRENT AMENDMENTS
TO NOT GO FAR ENOUGH TO. THESE
CAN. OUR STATE. IS THAT THIS
MAKES PROGRESS ON THE COMMITTEE
OF THE MANY TO MAKE PROGRESS
THANK YOU MAKE UP. HOWEVER WE
STILL NEED TO BE LANGUAGE ON
THE REPORT ENSURE THE THEY ARE
NOT UNDERCUT THE CAR PLIGHT
STANDARD. MOST IMPORTANTLY
ABOUT SEVEN YEAR I CAN X. WITH
THE- IS WITHOUT. GIVEN THE LONG.
TIME BUT CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
HAVE HAD TO PREPARE. FOR THESE
REASONS AT TI YOU RESPECTFULLY-
I MUST JOIN WITH OUR LABOR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ARE NOT
SPREAD OUT. AT. FIFTY VERY MUCH.
I KNOW THAT WE DON'THAVE ANY
IN THE- WE HAVE NO ONE IN OUR-
WITH. ROOM THIS IS ME HANG ON A
SEC. FOR MORE WORK SO MINIMUM
TO WE HAVE A OTHER ANY UP ON
THE PHONEJUST WILL BE JUST
ASKING FOR THE AND ORGANISE
ONLY PLEASE. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AFTER
EACH TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR
ENERGY ASSISTANCE FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT PROPOSALS
NOTED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIGHT ALIVE IN TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE ONE ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE ON
THE LINE FOR FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT INTERESTING
REPRESENTING THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR FROM
THE COMMITTEE. MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. SENATOR LONG
NIGHT- I WANT I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR TO HELP
OUR HOSPITALS ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AND HOW THE BILL IS
DRAFTED TODAY. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THE PRIOR SEISMIC
SAFETY EXTENSIONS HAVE ALWAYS
INCLUDED TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS AND BENCHMARKS
LIKE CONSTRUCTION SCHEDULES.
WHY IS THIS LEGISLATION GIVING
AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN YEARS MORE
TIME WITHOUT AY ASSURANCES
THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN ALL
HOSPITALS WILL ACTUALLY BE IN
COMPLIANCE. I'M ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BROAD APPLICATION OF
THE BILL I KNOW THERE ARE
HOSPITALS ON TRACK TO MAKE THE
TWENTY THIRTY SCHEDULE DEADLINE
AND I BELIEVE THAT THOSE CAN'T
ACCOMPLISH THAT THOSE THAT CAN
ACCOMPLISH IT. SHOULD I LOOK
FOR THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
AND BILLS. I FEAR THAT FEAR
THAT THIS PROPOSAL COULD
ENCOURAGE HOSPITALS TO HAVE THE
MONEY AND THE PLANS TO DELAY
THEIR WORK. CAN THIS
LEGISLATION BE LIMITED TO
HOSPITALS THE SHOW TRUE
FINANCIAL NEED FOR THIS
EXTENSION. SINCE THESE BILLS
ARE ONLY GOING THROUGH ONE
POLICY COMMITTEE IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR ME THAT WE GET
THIS RIGHT. I BELIEVE WHAT THE
OPPOSITION PROPOSED IS VERY
REASONABLE. SINCE THIS BILL
LANGUAGE WAS ONLY AMENDED IN
JULY I WILL SUPPORT TO MOVE IT
ALONG BUT I ASK YOU TO WORK
WITH THOSE OF THE REQUESTED
CHANGES BEFORE THE NEXT BOAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS.
THE REMEMBER CURRY A GUITAR
CARRY ANYBODY ALSO QUESTION OR
COMMENT FOR CENTER PORTANTINO.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO CENTER PROJECT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY MY APOLOGIES- MISTER
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SORRY I WAS IN A
CONVERSATION- CENTER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I'VE AS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON EARTHQUAKE RELATED
RESILIENCY ISSUES FOR SOME TIME
NOW SO I. WISH YOU BEST OF LUCK
IN MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD I
MYSELF WILL NOT BE VOTING ON
THIS ONLY BECAUSE A LOT OF
THESE EFFORTS STARTED OUT OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO- WHAT WILL
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS AGO WHEN
THE NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE TOOK
PLACE. AT AND WE WERE CAUGHT
FLAT FOOTED AND SO WE NEEDED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE MADE THE
APPROPRIATE GRADES SO THAT WERE
NEVER IN A VULNERABLE POSITION
THAT WAY AS WELL SO. I'M GONNA
BE STANDING LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
YOU ANY ANY OTHER MEMBERS. SEE
NONE WILL NOW BRING IT BACK TO
YOU CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU
AYE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE- PROCREATE COMMENTS
OF- COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT KOVIN HAS. CHANGED NORMAL
I MEAN HERE WE ARE IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER ALL WEARING
MASKS AND NOT IN A COMMITTEE
ROOMOUR SCHEDULES HAVE BEEN
TRUNCATED AND CLEARLY OUR
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN DEEPLY
AFFECTED IN THOSE HOSPITALS
WERE IN A BETTER FINANCIAL
SITUATION- AND A COVERED HAVE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION.
THEIR REVENUE AND THEIR IN A
CREASE THEIR COSTS I WOULD SAY
THAT THE TIME HAVE CHANGED I
THINK THE IMPORTANT. OF THE-
MANY AND THE MAKEUP OF THE
COMMITTEE I THINK IS GOING. TO
ENSURE THE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT THE S.
MEMBER HAS HAS REQUESTED I
THINK THE CONCEPT OF BENCHMARKS
TO SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE DISCUSSED- I
HAVE NO. DESIRE TO SEE ANOTHER
AFTER COME BACK FIVE YEARS FROM
NOW AND SAY WE NEED MORE TIME I
MEAN THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET A- BARS. POLICY COMMITTEE
OF THE SPEAKERS ON THE PHONE
REYES CLEARLY IF THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE SEE SOMETHING
COME BACK TO THE SENATE THAT IS
NOT- RIGHT THEY HAVE EVERY
ABILITY TO CALL IT OUT AND
HAPPY HEARING ON IT IF YOU SEE
SOMETHING THAT SO THAT IS A AS
THAT. WE NEED OF A OF A
DETERRENT NOT HAVE THE BILL
MOVED TODAY AND I THINK THE
CHAIR STAFF HAS DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB IN TRYING TO GET
THE SUITES ON AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY. ABOUT THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I'M- I'M I'M
LOOKING FOR A MOTION IF THERE
WAS ONE AYE PART. THE MOTION BY
MISTER MASON THE SECOND I
MISSED A SECOND BY MISTER RAMOS
I APOLOGIZE HAVING A HARD TIME
WELL IT. IT COULD BE MISTER
BIGELOW BUT WE'LL CALL THIS
TRAUMA AND SO THE SAME PERSON.
SO ANYWAY WE'RE YOU KNOW WE GOT
A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT'S
pPASS AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATE
ACTIONS- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SB SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT DUE PROCESS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD. WOOD I'D
MAYES. MAYES I AGUIAR-CURRY ARE
YOUR CURRY I BIGELOW BIGELOW II
BONTA. BONTA NOT VOTING BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLORA I'D LIMóN. LIMON
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NOT VOTING RAMOS MOST OF
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON I. TEN I EIGHT ZERO NO
BILL PASSESTHANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO YOUR BILL IS OUT
WITH A REAL OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU OF. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF A PARTICULAR THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING SO DILIGENTLY ON
THE BILL. YOUR SUGGESTIONS
AMENDMENTS WE ACCEPT THE
IMPROVE THE BILL A PARTICULAR
JUDY BABCOCK. THANK YOU ALSO
FOR INVITING ME TO SIMPLY
CHAMBERS HAS BEEN THIRTY YEARS
OR SO SINCE I'VE STOOD HERE
BEFORE- THIS BILL SB SIX SIX
FIVE WILL ESTABLISH THE JAIL
BASED COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
INNOVATION PROGRAM. THE J. B.
C. M.H. I. T. EASY FOR ME TO
SAY. AND WHAT THIS DOES IS THIS
PERMITS THE USE OF PROP SIXTY
THREE FUNDS TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT IN JAIL. OF
MAYBE YOUR COUNTY SAME AS MINE
AN ORANGE COUNTY LARGEST MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITY ORANGE COUNTY
JAIL OVER 30% OF THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED THE ORANGE COUNTY
JAIL. NEED MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
THIS BILL ALLOWS THAT A PORTION
OF THE FUNDS THAT ARE RATED THE
POOL OF FUNDS THAT ARE
GENERATED BY PROP. SIX THE.
I'VE OF THE TOTAL POT B. L. G.
TO BE USED FOR HEALTH THREE IN
JAILS SO IF A MATCH THE POT OF
MONEY THE POT OF MONEY THAT
EXISTS 5% AT POT IS DESIGNATED
FOR INNOVATIVE INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS. YES EIGHT COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VOTES TO
APPROVE THAT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE BOARD THE BOARD. OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION IF THEY ALSO VOTE.
TO APPROVE THE INNOVATIVE
PROJECT THAT'S PROPOSED THEN IT
MAY GO FORWARD BUT THIS IS A
PILOT PROJECT. FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROJECT ONLY IN EIGHT YET TO BE
SPECIFIED COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT. THIS DOES NOT TAKE
AWAY MONEY FROM OTHER.
RESOURCES SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
NO MY CUNTY A CINEMA COUNTY
WHEN THIS POT IS DIVIDED UP
EACH COUNTY GETS A CERTAIN
PORTION OF IT. THEY CAN USE IT
SO LONG AS APPROVED BY THE
REVISES AND ALSO THE BOARD THAT
OVERSEES THE FUNDS. IF MY
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE USES THAT
MONEY IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY FROM
NAPA COUNTY IT DOESN'T TAKE
AWAY FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. ALSO ONE OF THE OTHER
PERHAPS MISCONCEPTIONS IT
SOMEHOW IT WON'T BE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT INDEED.
WITH THOSE TWO SAFEGUARDS WITH
THE BOARD REQUIRING APPROVAL
WELL AS THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REQUIRING APPROVAL
IT WILL CERTAINLY BE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THAT'LL BE
PROVIDING THE TREATMENT TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT IN OUR OFFICE.
WITH THE NUMBERS OF. OF THOSE
INCARCERATED INCREASING IN OUR
COUNTY JAIL- EITHER BECAUSE OF
CHANGE IN LAW BECAUSE THE
COVERT CRISIS AND WITH THE
COVERT CRISIS CREATING
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESS IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
NOW WE PROVIDE THE RESOURCES
THAT ALREADY EXIST THAT ALREADY
EXIST PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES
TO THOSE WHO ARE IN DESPERATE
NEED OF MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
URBAN AYE VOTES. YOU VERY MUCH-
SEE YOU HAVE WE HAVE ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT YES UP MISS ERIN WINGER
YES SHOULD BE ON THE PHONE. SO
WILL OUT OF ADAM ASKAR
MODERATED TO ALLOW AIR AND
WIENER. TO OPEN HER LINE IN AND
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ONE MOMENT WHILE REJOIN THEM.
IF YOU'RE A BE ONE MORE MOMENT
HERE OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
ROBBIE JOINING RIGHT NOW JUST A
MOMENT HERE.
THE OTHER WAY FOR
THE WITH. DAISY IN TEHRAN WE DO
NOT HAVE AIR INDIA. IF YOU CARE
TO PROCEED OTHERS THAT MAY BE
ON THE PHONE SUPPORT. THERE ARE
OTHERS HERE HE WISHES TO BE
CONSERVATORIUM. GRANT TAKE OUT.
GIVE YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA WANNA LIVE IN FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLYDE WANTED
ONE FINE. YES THIS IS MY
UNDERCARD CARDI ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND A COALITION OF
OTHER. SUPPORTERS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA THE FIVE OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE UNDER
DISTORTION OF PROGRAM TO PUT
ONE TO REGISTER STRONG AND
OPPOSITION OF BILL. THANK YOU.
WHERE DO I LIVE IN SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES DANNY
OFFER FROM PLATEN VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NANI CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO REGISTRY NAMI CONTRA COSTA
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
LINE TWELVE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY TSHOMBE HALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE TWELVE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JERRY
NUMBERS WANTED TO HEAR WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN OPPOSITION.
RESTRAINT TWELVE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
AND TWELVE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
OCHO A RESIDENT OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH WITH TRANSFORMING JUSTICE
OF THE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB SIX SIX FIVE. I BELIEVE WE
WERE ACTUALLY STILL TRYING TO
DO UP TO DO SUPPORT SO. WHIZZER
MADAM MADAM MODERATOR RESERVE
IS THEIR SUPPORT AND OTHER
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL PLEASE. WE
HAVE NINETEEN LINES THAT CUTE
OUT OKAY. FOR SUPPORT. WE JUST
HAVE BEEN NINETEEN THAT CAME
INTO Q. WHEN I ASK FOR SUPPORT
YET WE KEEP HAVING SEVERAL
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION SO I'M I'M
SO I WOULD ASK THAT WHOEVER IS
IN THE QUEUE FOR PART IN THE
NUMBER AT THE WRONG TIME. OKAY
WE'RE LIMITED TO TEN EACH-
WE'VE HAD I THINK ABOUT FOUR IN
OPPOSITION NOW AND A COUPLE IN
SUPPORT OF OUR LOST TRACK QUITE
FRANKLY. SO PLEASE WHOEVER'S
OUT THERE PLEASE IF YOU WERE
SUPPORT FIRST WE ALSO HAVE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THAT BY
PHONE WHO WERE WHO WERE GOING
TO TESTIFY SO PLEASE. I'M
ASKING FOR PEOPLE IN SUPPORT AT
THIS POINT. THANK YOU MATTHEW I
TWELVE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FLORIDA LINE TWELVE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS ERIN WINNER CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU AND I AM ACTUALLY-
TESTIFYING THAT EVENING WHAT
THE PORT AT AT GETTING YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AND
WEBER AND- OKAY I GUESS WE'RE
OKAY SAID A CONTINUANCE FOR
DOING THAT THREE M'S ARE DOING
THREE MINUTES HERE. THREE
MINUTES GO AHEAD. I'M THE
DEPUTY AGENCY DIRECTOR OF
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH
CARE AGENCY ORANGE COUNTY IS
EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE OF
SENATOR UMBERG LEADERSHIP WITH
THE INTRODUCTION OF SB SIX SIX
FIVE WHICH WOULD ALLOW A SMALL
SCALE PILOT PROGRAM UTILIZING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING IN JAIL IF APPROVED BY
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. IN ORANGE COUNTY
ABOUT 30% OF THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION IS IN NEED OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADDITIONALLY
APPROXIMATELY ONE FIFTH OF
COUNTY JAIL INMATES ARE TAKING
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION WHICH
IS A 25% INCREASE SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN. THE PROVIDER OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
ORANGE COUNTY JAIL I RECOGNIZE
THE SIMPLE REALITY THAT
INCARCERATED PERSONS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE THE
SAME PERSON SUFFERING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ORANGE COUNTY
BEGAN AN INITIATIVE LAST YEAR
CALLED THE INTEGRATED SERVICES
VISION TO BETTER COORDINATE AND
STRENGTHENED THE COUNTY SYSTEM
OF CARE AND PROMOTE PUBLIC
SAFETY PRIORITIZING BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PREVENTION AND REENTRY
EFFORT. INTENSITY BE HEALTH
TREATMENT. IN CUSTODY
VOCATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE COURT. IN FURTHER INTO
DOUBT VISION THE COUNTY INVEST
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY MILLION
ANNUALLY IN COUNTY GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPLEMENT MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDING IN THE JAIL. THE
CREATION OF THE JAIL BASED
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
INNOVATION PROGRAM WILL ALLOW
UP TO EIGHT COUNTIES TO USE AN
HSA INNOVATION FUNDING WHICH
COMPRISES 5% OF AN HSA
REVENUES. TO HELP DETERMINE
WHETHER THE EXPANSION OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN COUNTY JAILS
PROVIDES BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN NEED OF SERVICES
IN THE COMMUNITY AND WITHIN A
COMMUNITY CHECK. THIS
INNOVATION BROWN WOULD PROVIDE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY TRACK
AND TEST THE VALIDITY OF THE
ARGUMENTS BEING MADE IN SUPPORT
OF INCREASING THE FLEXIBILITY
OF IMAGE MHSAA DOLLARS. TO FUND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
COUNTY JAIL. TO ENSURE THE BEST
POSSIBLE OUTCOME IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT SUPPORTS PEOPLE AND
ENSURES THAT THERE IS NO
DISRUPTION IN THE HEALTH
SERVICES WHETHER THERE ARE
COMMUNITY OR IN OUR COMMUNITY
JAIL. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SIX FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO NOW WE WILL GO BACK TO THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT- MATAMATA
MODERATOR- THE OPEN THE LINES
FOR OTHERS AND SUPPORT JUST
THEIR NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE TEN
EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TEN EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ACTUALLY I'M IN. WILL OVERRIDE
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T LIVE IN NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I'M
IN OPPOSITION SO OKAY WELL
WE'LL FIND OUT LINE ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
KNOW A LOT OF IT ALL SIX PLEASE
BAD. THE LAST LINE WE HAVING Q.
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MICHELLE SUCCULENT IN
OPPOSITION. SO THERE IS NO MORE
IN SUPPORT IN THE AND IN THE
QUEUE THEN AT THIS POINT MATTER
MODERATE SOUNDS LIKE THAT
ANYWAY. I TELL YOU WHAT WE'LL
DO IS WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. AND IF
THERE ARE ULTIMATELY OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT. WHEN WE CALL OPEN THIS
UP WILL ALLOW THEM TO
PARTICIPATE AS WELL SO I THINK
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN A LITTLE BIT
MIXED UP HERE SO- SO LET'S GO
TO OUR WITH WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BY PHONE I BELIEVE.
HAVE A OF A RIND. AND A DAISY
SHAH S. SO. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLACE.
THE TICKET NUMBER IS HIRING THE
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE TO THE STATE.
REGRET WE ARE PART ACTUALLY.
FIVE I CAN'T REMEMBER DE BEEN
WITHIN KIND OF I MEANT. I'VE
BEEN. THINKING WITH THE INTENT
OF THE METAL SERVICES ACT ANY.
GROUP I CAL. VOTERS IN THOUSAND
FOUR AND CREDIT FUNDING THANK
YOU. BIG HEALTHCARE THANKS
THANK YOU DAVID FROM PART. I OF
TIME NEED TO RIGHT THING REPORT
ARE. THAT ACCOMPANIED BY. YOU
CAN OF THE MA. I WOULD AGREE BY
THE BY. IF YOU REDUCE LONG TERM
ADVERSE IMPACT ON INDEED.
FAMILY AND DATA HOPE FOR
UNTREATED NOT ALLOWED. ALL I
MEAN SURE THEY- WITH BE IN. BUT
THERE ARE COPPER VISION ABOUT
HOW YOU'RE MOST. INCLUDING FOR
HOPE. EMPOWER RESPECT SPECIAL
ACTION SOUTHWEST. AND TALK WITH
HER. THE RECOVERY VISION IT
THANK DEPENDS UPON. GETTING CAR
TRADED THAT HE. AND NOT TO JAIL
PENDING BUT WE CREATED THEIR
FIRST ON WHAT SOME OF THE HAVE
TO BE PARKED BEFORE THEY-
RECEIVE HOW. SB SIX I'M- FOR
THE COMPANY. PANDEMIC TEND TO
BACK AND- THEY DONT THAT
PROJECT FOR THE YEAR. COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL THAT THEY NEEDED TO
A BILL DOLLARS AND I'M BEING
DUE TO. BACK AND THE IMPACT THE
CULPRIT NINETEEN. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME MEDIC OKAY THEIR TO
BY POINT TWO BILLION BENEFITS.
AND THE CURRENT. ANGLE TO THE
BENEFIT FOR A. THE INDIVIDUAL
FILE IN PARTS AND YOU CORPORATE
AND- MANY COUNTY THE END OF AN-
PROJECT BOND. AN EMPLOYEE WE
ARE ANY IT A COMMUNITY SERVICE
EVENT BUT BOND AND LET
CONSIDERABLE FEDERAL. SHIFTING
FUND INTO THE JAIL COULD COME
OVER THE. HE ORGANIZATION FBI
YOU RACIAL AND ETHNIC MINORITY
GROUPS THANK HIGH TRIP BY
COLLEGES AND MANY OTHERS. WE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
FROM THE IN OUR OFFICE ABOUT
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OKAY
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION THE BODY CHARGED
WITH APPROVING INNOVATION
PROJECT AT THE STATE LEVEL. THE
DEPOSIT BACK BE THICK THICK
FIVE THREE REASONS WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO BUT NO ONE
ACTUALLY PICNIC FIVE AND HONOR.
THE WILL OF THE VOTERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANOTHER WITNESS SAID CHAVOUS.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAVID CHAVEZ AND I AM A MEMBER
OF TRANSFORMING DUCTED ORANGE
COUNTY IN THE POLICY ASSOCIATE
WITH INITIATOR IS AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THINK THAT
FIVE BY TEN I'M BURKE CONFIRMED
OF THIS IS A COALITION
COMMITTED TO THE CORPORATION IN
OAKLAND COUNTY WE CARE VERY
MUCH ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN ORANGE
COUNTY JAILS AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER WE
UNEQUIVOCALLY OPPOSED THE USE
OF ANY TYPE THE FUNDS TO
SUPPLANT THE OBLIGATIONS I JAIL
PACK PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ALONE
REACHED OVER TWENTY OF ORANGE
COUNTY DISCRETIONARY BUDGET
INCLUDING MILLIONS INTENDED
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN THE JAIL
AS SOMEONE. WHO HAD MULTIPLE.
ANYTHING CARD ASIAN AS A RESULT
OF THEIR COUNTRY MENTAL. I HAVE
SEEN THE RIPPLE OF NOT
PROVIDING IN THE- FOR AT. MY
LEVEL OF BREAD. ROBERT MENTAL
WITH BROTHERS. BY THE-
FACTORIES. AFTER HE WAS
RELEASED HE'S GOT TO ACCESS
HOUSING A CHIEF. STABILITY AND
GET MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT HE
WAS ULTIMATELY REDIRECTED AND
SENT BACK TO JAIL. HE NEEDED
CARE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
NOT THERE BE IN THE JAIL. THIS
IS THE EXPRESS INTENT AND
PURPOSE OF THE MA TESTING. THIS
IS WHAT VOTERS UNDERSTOOD AND
APPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
ANY CHANCE THE FUNDS WERE
INTENDED FOR COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
THAT CAN PREVENT ARREST AND
INCARCERATION. INCREASE AFTER
VERSION OF THE PHILIPPINE
REENTRY PEOPLE CANNOT GET WELL
IN ITSELF. I STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON SENATE BILL FIFTY
FIVE AND TO LISTEN TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THIS. CALL.
FOR HELLO I THINK CAN AND WE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO WE HAVE WILL NOW WITH THE
OTHER IN OP JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WE WILL WE
HAVE FIVE FIVE MORE. FOLKS THAT
CAN DO THAT SO NOT MISSED
MATAMATA MODERATOR PLEASE UP
THE LINES FOR OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME A
MORE BOTTOM LINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL WILL RIDE
OF LIFE FOR TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE FOUR TO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WHAT A
WIDER MARGIN. I'M SORRY LEVINE
YEP M. HAWKINS I REPRESENT ERIC
EVERYTHING FROM WORKING AT THE
UNITED PARISH FONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
OPPOSITION. YOU. LINE FIVE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M HERE
REACHED THE PATH WE NEED PROUD
MOTHER OF AN ADULT SON WITH WHO
LIVES TO RADICALLY WOULD GET TO
AFFECTED DISORDER STRONGLY
OPPOSING- AND A MEMBER OF NANNY
CONTRA COSTA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE FIVE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEEON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE FOR NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
STACEY HERE A MODEL WITH PEMCO
THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES COLLISION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
OKAY I THINK THAT'S IT. OKAY WE
WILL BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MR MAYS. I SENATOR IT
IS NINE O'CLOCK MY GOODNESS- SO
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS- THAT IS
COME UP AND ACTUALLY EVEN FROM
MY LOCALS IT SEEMS TO BE NOT SO
CLEAR THAT YOU BROUGHT THIS UP-
IN YOUR YOUR OPENING- IS
WHETHER THE COUNTY SUPERVISOR
FOR LOCALS AND GET TO OPT IN OR
BUT MATTER OPT OUT OF THIS
PROGRAM CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THAT
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE I'M NOT
QUITE SURE WHETHER IT BE
OPPOSITION IF THE COUNTY
THEMSELVES. WILL HAD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LOCAL CONTROL SO
CAN YOU DRESS THAT. I THANK YOU
MR MAYES- I HEARD SOME COMMENT
WITH RESPECT TO COUNTIES- SO
FAR AS I'M AWARE THERE'S NO
COUNTY THAT'S OPPOSED TO. EIGHT
SB SIX SIX FIVE. THIS IS A
PILOT PROJECT. EIGHT COUNTIES
ARE ELIGIBLE. TO PARTAKE IN THE
PROJECT NO COUNTY IS FORCED TO
BE IN. NO COUNTY IS FORCED TO
BE OUT AND INDEED IF I COUNTY
OPS IN IN A PROPOSAL INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS SO FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS. LACKING IN
CRITICAL IS A HAND OFF FROM
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED TO
THOSE WHO ARE RETURNED BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY. SO IF I COUNTY
DECIDES THAT THAT'S AN
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM THAT THEY
WISH TO PURSUE. AND THEY GET
APPROVAL FROM THE- THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY I SHOULD WHO HAS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE- THE
PROBE. OF THOSE. THEN THEY CAN
DO SO BUT FORCED TO AND INDEED
AS I SAID EARLIER IT DOES NOT
TAKE MONEY AWAY FROM ANY OTHER
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE. THERE IS
THOSE THAT ARE CONCERNED AT
THIS MONEY MIGHT BE DIVERTED
FROM ONE PROGRAM INTO A NOTHER
PROGRAM. THE LOCALS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION EVEN THOUGH- THERE'S-
EIGHT EIGHT OF THESE COUNTIES
THAT CAN- THAT THEY CAN BE PART
OF THIS. THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
IF THEY'RE NOT FORCED TO BE
THEY STILL RETAIN LOCAL CONTROL
TO DO SO ABSOLUTELY CAPSULE. AT
THE END THERE'S A PROVISION THE
BILL THAT DOES NOT THAT FORBIDS
THE SUPPLICATION OF FUNDS
ANOTHER WORDS YOU CAN'T USE
THIS MONEY BY HAND CUFFS. MISS
WALDRON. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SB SIX SIX FIVE SIX TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE MOST
PRESSING ISSUES IN OUR STATE-
IN FACT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN COUNTY JAIL AND
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT I CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT GETTING TREATMENT
TO JUSTICE INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS
WILL REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND HELP
PEOPLE HEAL AND HAVE SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY. I'VE STUDY THE ISSUES
RAISED ON BOTH SIDES AND
UNDERSTAND THE STILL
SIGNIFICANT DEBATE ABOUT. THE
USE OF M. H. ESSAY FUNDS FOR
THIS PURPOSE BUT I'M SWAYED
THAT THIS IS INDEED APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE IT FURTHERS THE INTENT
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THAT. THE PILOT ROOM IS LIMITED
TIME IN SCOPE AND THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT SAFEGUARDS. BECAUSE
OF THE DIRE NEED FOR THESE
RESOURCES. TO PREVENT
RECIDIVISM AND TREAT- URGENT
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES I
SUPPORT THE BILL AND THEN KURT
AND I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE. MISTER
ROBERTS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- THANK YOU OF
CENTER FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD I JUST WANT TO I KNOW
WE TALKED- AND TRY TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THE ITEMS IN
THE BILL AND I MENTIONED WHILE
WE'RE ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE WORKED- WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TO USE SOME
OF THIS THESE DOLLARS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE WAS- SOMEONE GOING
OUT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIREFIGHTERS ON THAT WAS ONE
THAT MADE THAT MESSAGE WHAT THE-
OUR- THE OFTEN STILL WOULD BE
MADE AT THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
I. THERE THE FUNDING MECHANISM
OF IT ALSO WOULD THAT BE AT THE
LOCAL BOARDS DISCRETION OR
WOULD THAT BE AT THE STATE-
WITH THE DOLLARS COMING IN. SO
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION. THE FUNDS
ARE DIVIDED AMONG THE COUNTIES
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT IS IT DOESN'T PROVIDE
ACTUALLY ANY ADDITIONAL MONIES
OF THE INNOVATIVE FUN AND
ALLOWS THE COUNTY TO USE THOSE
INNOVATIVE PROBLEMS SHOULD THEY
APPLY. TO BE USED IN THE JAIL
FOR MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT SO
THE LOCAL BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
HAS CONTROL OVER HOW MUCH MONEY
IS SPENT OF THAT POT AND WHERE
THAT MONEY IS SPENT OF THAT.
NOW THEY DON'T HAVE EXCLUSIVE
CONTROL BECAUSE THE BOARD THAT
OVERSEES THE ALLOCATION THE
USES PROP SIXTY THREE MONEY.
ALSO HAS TO AGREE. NOW WE ALSO-
TOUCHED ON- ONE OF THE OTHER
TOPICS AS FAR AS- COUNTY JAILS
AND SOME OF THESE FUNDING
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO USE BE USED
IN THE IN THE STATE. PRISON
SYSTEM RIGHT THERE IS- FELONIES
AND THESE ARE THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT. BUT WE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT NOW IN THE COUNTY
JAIL WE HAVE A MORE OF A I
THINK THE THREE TIER. SENTENCES
THAT ARE BEING- FOR PLAYED OUT
IN THE COUNTY AREA SO HOW DOES
THAT PLAY WITHIN THE DOLLARS.
THE I THINK COME UP DOLLARS I'M
GOING TOWARDS- THOSE TYPES OF-
FELONIES IN THOSE TYPES OF
PRISONERS THAT ARE FROM THE
STATE. SO IT IS TRUE THAT SIXTY
THREE MONIES CANNOT BE USED IN
PRISONS AND THIS DOESN'T APPLY
TO PRESENT THIS APPLIES ONLY
TO. COUNTY FACILITIES OF
INCARCERATION IT'S ALSO TRUE AS
YOU MENTIONED THAT THAT PEOPLE
ARE SPENDING LONGER PERIODS OF
TIME BUT- IF YOU'RE IN A COUNTY
JAIL. OVERWHELMINGLY I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGE BY
VENTURE TO SAY IT PROBABLY OVER
90% OF THOSE IN THE COUNTY JAIL
ARE ARE CUTTING BACK. WELL TO
BE SURE TO. HELP OF THE
COMMUNITY. SO FOR US IN A
PROBABLY ALL AGREE MIGHT
PROVIDE A WHOLE. SOME TO
PREVENT THEM FROM GOING A
FACILITY BUT ONCE THEY'RE IN
FACILITY BECOME BACK OUT. AND
SIMPLY SAY WELL TOO BAD YOU
LOSE YOUR IN JAIL NOW SO YOU
DON'T GET ANY TREATMENT. THAT
SEEMS TO ME TO BE SHORTS. THANK
THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE OF AN
I DO THINK THEY ARE GETTING
SERVICES IN THE JAIL THIS
HANDSOME. GRAHAM WITHIN THE
JAILS I BUT- AND CERTAINLY WERE
ALL ON THE SAME PAGE OF TRYING
TO. MAKE SURE THAT THOSE THAT
NEED SERVICES. GET THE SERVICES
OF THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU.
THAT'S CORRECT. THANK YOU
SENATOR CAN YOU PLEASE- ADDRESS
ON MY COLLEAGUES GOT A QUESTION
IN TERMS OF ARE THESE TYPES OF
SERVICES AVAILABLE NOW IN THE
COUNTY JAIL WELL THEY VARY FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY BUT YES THERE
CLEARLY SOME COUNTIES THAT ARE
PROVIDING MORE MENTAL SERVICE
OTHER NEXT A- TO COUNTY IS THE-
ADEQUATE SERVICE WITH ADEQUATE
RE THEY NEED NOT. OKAY IN. THEY
PUT THE NAY THOSE THERE ARE
NONE OR AREN'T BEING USED
EFFECTIVELY THEY CAN WITHDRAW.
WELL I ASKED THE QUESTION
BECAUSE AND L. A. COUNTY IN
SPECIFICALLY IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- THAT I REPRESENT. ARE
MY CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
COUNTY SHERIFF'S HAVE BEEN THAT
THE JAILS ARE INCREDIBLY OVER
POPULATED. THERE IS A LOT OF
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH CARE-
AND THE DEPUTY SHERIFFS DO NOT
HAVE TO BE. THE SOURCES THE
TRAINING THE RULES. TO DEAL AND
MANAGE. A LOT OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH BEHAVIORS THAT ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDING RESOURCES
SO I THINK THIS IS A AN AN
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES THAT AT
THE END OF THE DAY. IS BERMAN
LOW. AND WHAT ABOUT. AIR I
THINK A MINUTE BUT NINETEEN THE
MENTAL STRESS THE JUSTIN MEANT
BEHAVIORS AND GEN STRESS THAT
BOTH PEOPLE THAT ARE
INCARCERATED AS WELL AS THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THE
FACILITIES ARE FACING IS VERY
REAL. AND SO I YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
WELL FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK.
WHAT. CAN I GET THE PARA
CONECTAR OTHER COMMENTED ON
COUNTY IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY NOT THIS IS THE TIME
FOR THE FOR THE MEMBERS TO
DELIBERATE SO I APPRECIATE DO
YOU WANT TO PAY FOR THEIR BUT
THAT'S THAT TIME IS OVER NOW.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I WAS THANK
YOU SKINNER AMBERG- SB SIX
SIXTY FIVE IS AN OUTSIDE THE
BOX IDEA. MAYBE NOT COMPLETELY
OUTSIDE THE BOX AND SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S BEING DONE IN OTHER PLACES
BUT BUT CERTAINLY- IT
ENCOURAGES. INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES TO IMPROVING THE
CONTINUITY AND QUALITY OF CARE
FOR CITIZENS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. IS NOT DEGRADE THE
JAIL TO BECOME THE STATE'S
MENTAL INSTITUTIONS PER PER
MENTAL HEALTH IN CITY REMAIN.
INDIVIDUALS WHO OFTEN GOING TO
JAILS HAVING NEVER RECEIVE THE
SERVICES IN THE OR I DON'T FEEL.
ONE HABIT TEABING COMMUNITY
BASED CARE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
THERE ISN'T A SMOOTH TRANSITION
A CARE PLAN TO THE- FAILURE
NUMBER TWO. WHEN PEOPLE ARE
RELEASED FROM JAIL. THERE'S
THERE ALSO MAY NOT BE A WARM
HAND OFF BACK TO COMMUNITY
BASED CARE. THIS RESULTS IN
PEOPLE DROPPING THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND OUT OF CARE ONLY TO
CYCLE THROUGH RETURNED TO JAIL
AT SOME POINT IN THEIR IN THEIR
FUTURE. WITHOUT EVER RECEIVING
THE NAVY THE NEEDY CARE THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO THAT'S FAILURE
NUMBER THREE. I HAVE TO BELIEVE
THERE'S A BETTER WAY. I AGREE
WITH YOU MR BURKE THAT IT'S
TIME FOR JAIL IN OUR COMMUNITY
BASED. HEALTH BAKER SERVICES TO
FOCUS NOT ON THIS THIS SYSTEM
OVER. OVER THE OTHER OR WHO
CONTROLS THE MONEY. BUT TO
INSTEAD FOCUS ON COORDINATED.
WHILE. JUST ONE MORE THING
TONIGHT. ONE OKAY. ADD ME BACK
UP TO THAT SENSOR. APPARENTLY
IT WAS A REAL SHOCKER- I HAVE
TO BELIEVE THERE'S A BETTER WAY
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT IT'S TIME
FOR A JAILER COMMUNITY BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
FOCUS NOT ON THE SYSTEM OVER
THE- OR WHO CAN. THAT FOCUS ON
COORDINATED EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE IN THE NEED OF CARE
ARE RECEIVING THE CARE THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO FROM THE COMMUNITY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LOCATION
WITH COMMUNITY. SB SIX SIXTY
FIVE IS A NARROWLY FOCUSED
PILOT PROJECT. THAT PROHIBITS
SUPPLANTING WHICH YOU POINTED
OUT OVER OVER FUNDING OVER
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES IT LIMITS
IS THE FUNDS TO BE USED TO
THOSE THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
ALLOCATED FOR THE INNOVATION
FUNDING 45% THE COUNTIES IN
JUST A MONEY. BUDGET INCLUDE.
PUTTING THE COUNTY THREE YEAR.
IN COUNTY THREE YOUR
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN MHS PLAY MHA
IS I MET AN HSA PLAN AND IT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE THE
OVERSIGHT THAT YOU SPOKE OF. IT
MUST BE ADOPTED BY THE COUNTY
BOARD. IS AN ALL OF THE BY THE
COMMISSION JUST WE SAID AND-
REQUIRES GREAT. EDUCATION
COLLABORATION AND INTEGRATION
BETWEEN COUNTY BEHAVIORAL STAFF
AND JAIL PERSONNEL IN THE
REMOTE PATIENT STATUS MEETINGS
AND PLANNING SESSIONS. MY
BELIEVE IS YOUR BILL WILL
PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT DATA TO
SUPPORT IMPROVED THANK YOU IN
COMMUNITY IN THE COMMUNITY'S
RESPONSE TO THE TREATMENT OF
MENTALLY. INDIVIDUALS WHETHER
THEY'RE- NOT. FOR THESE REASONS.
I SUPPOSE YOUR BILL I THANK YOU
FOR CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR OUR CITIZENS THANK
YOU SENATOR OF BURKE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO QUIT- THANK YOU CHAIR
ANY COMMENT ON MY WOULD TRACK
FROM VERY ELOQUENT THING YOU
ORIGINAL VOTE ON I'M JUST BE
FOR ANOTHER. DOWN THE LIGHTNING
OR SOMETHING HERE COME OFF OF
IT SO I. LOOKING FOR A MO. I'M
SORRY SO MOVE MOVE BY MR BONTA
SECOND FIVE MOVE BY MR BONTA
SENT SECOND BY MISS MISS BURKE.
THE QUESTION IS- DO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MEDITECH PRAYER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB SIX SIX
FIVE DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD I WOULD I'D MAYES. MAYES
I ARGUED HURRY. ARE YOUR CURRY
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW I BOUGHT.
BONTA I'D BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLUORIDE
LIMóN. MCCARTY NAZARIAN. RAMOS
RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO Y. WALDRON WALDRON
NINE. ELEVEN NINE ZERO NO BILL
PASSES THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
BROTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CENTER WINNER IT'S
REALLY NOT. YOU KNOW WITH THIS
REALLY. YOU ARE. WE NEED TO
MEET THE PHONES PLEASE IF
POSSIBLE. YOU ARE NOT LAST BUT
NOT LAST BUT NOT LEAST YOUR OF
YOUR VERY WELCOME IN OUR
CHAMBER SENATOR WIENER. I'M
GONNA INTRODUCE A BILL TO
REVERSE ALPHABETICAL ORDER I
THINK IN. TRUST ME AS A
SOMEBODY ELSE AT THE END OF THE
ALPHABET I LOVE THAT IDEA YEAH
THE MINORITY WE ARE AND I WILL
CALL IT AS A- BILL TOGETHER.
HAHAHA SORRY. PLEASE PLEASE
PROCEED WITH THAT SB EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE. OKAY I THANK YOU-
MRS HERE FIRST I WANT TO. I
THANK THE CHAIR AND ALSO THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING ON
VERY HARD WITH US- ON THIS-
BILL- AND WE- WILL BE. MAKING
THE- AUTHOR AMENDMENTS ARE
CONTAINED IN OUR SERVICE- THERE
ARE NO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
ALL THE ROOMS. WE WILL BE
MAKING UP EXCEPT. ARE WE WILL
NOT BE- REMOVING THE DEFINITION
OF MEDICAL NECESSITY AFTER
DIALOGUE WE DECIDED. NT TO DO
THAT OUR GOVERNMENT THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR. WORKING WITH US.
ALSO GOING TO. CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE. I'M WITH
PARMA MANAGE HEALTHCARE. ON THE
OUT OF NETWORK PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL FURTHER REFINING THAT.
MEASURE ACCOMPLISHING OUR- OUR
GOAL. I'M CALLING. TO SB FIFTY
FIVE. I THANK YOU VERY VERY
SIMPLE EVERY. I HEALTH
INSURANCE. TO COVER ALL
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TREATMENT
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION. THAT YOU MIGHT ASK
YOURSELF WHY DOES NOT REQUIRE A
BILL- IT'S SORT OF COMMON SENSE
OF A DOCTOR UNDER PREVAILING
STANDARDS. SAYS THAT YOU NEED
THIS TREATMENT FOR YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH OR ADDICTION THIS ORDER.
ARE YOU SHOULD BE COVERED FOR
UNFORTUNATELY OUR INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE VERY FREQUENTLY
REFUSING TO COVER. ANY KIND OF.
EARLY INTERVENTION OR BASIC
CARE FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION. ARE ONLY COVERING
PEOPLE IF THEY ARE ALREADY A
CRISIS. THEY'RE ALREADY GOING
TO THE SITE EMERGENCY ROOM
THEY'VE ALREADY LOST THEIR JOBS
AND THEIR HOUSING THEY'RE
ALREADY SO IT'S DETERIORATED. I
DO TOO. OKAY CHEN. THEN THEY
ONLY OFF COVERED FIRST TERM.
OCT CARE TO GET THEM STATE
AGAIN AND THEN THE COVERAGE AND-
SHOULD BE THE SAME AS SAYING.
WHAT WE KNOW YOU WERE JUST
DIAGNOSED WITH STAGE ONE
CANCER. COME BACK AND SEE US
WHEN YOU'RE A STAGE FOR AND
WILL COVER YOU THAT. WE WOULD
NEVER EVER IN A HUNDRED YEARS
TOLERATE THAT. AND YET WE HAVE
TOLERATED THIS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH. CONDITION AND WE HAVE A
CONCEPT OF PARITY AND THE US
AND IN CALIFORNIA THAT MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT MENTAL HEALTH
AFFLICTIONS. ARE DIFFERENT THAN
PHYSICAL ILLNESSES AND WE
SHOULD TREAT THEM THE SAME WE
HAVE A TERRIBLE CRISIS IN THIS
COUNTRY WE HAVEN'T. DONE ENOUGH.
CALIFORNIA'S MENTAL HEALTH
PARITY LAW IS. INSUFFICIENT IT
LEAVES OUT SOME OF THE MOST
COMMON AND SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS THE CURRENT PARITY
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO COVER PTSD
TREATMENT OR TREATMENT FOR
GENERALIZED ANXIETY DISORDER OR
FOR A NEW OR USED DISORDER OR
ALCOHOL USE DISORDER BINGE
EATING DISORDER. FOUR MAJOR NEW
AUGMENTED THE ORDER DO
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY. THESE
ARE SEVERE CONDITIONS AND YOUR
CURRENT LAW DOESN'T REQUIRE
THAT AND TO BE CARP. BECAUSE
HELP IS FOR PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE IS OFTEN SO LIMITED
AND WHAT IT WILL COVER FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
CARE. WE SEE PEOPLE IN THERE
WAS AN ARTICLE ABOUT THIS THE
OTHER DAY. CANCEL THE INSURANCE
COVERAGE AND SIGNED UP FOR MEDI
CAL. BECAUSE MEDIC CAL WAXAY
COVERAGE SO THE TAXPAYERS ARE
LEFT HOLDING THE BAG.
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE BEFORE
COVERED WE HAD A CRISIS AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S ONLY
GETTING WORSE- AND WE SEE IT
HAPPENING EVERY DAY INCREASES
IN OVERDOSE- JUST GROWING
MENTAL PROBLEMS THIS BILL WILL
HAVE. PEOPLE COVERAGE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
I WENT TO ON THE PHONE OR DAVID
LLOYD SINGER POLICY ADVISER THE
KENNEDY FORUM- AND- IRAN VENDO
THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT- OF
SAFE IF YOU'LL MENTAL HEALTH
INSURANCE ADVOCACY OF ALL.
THANK VERY MUCH FOUR ONE TO ARE
WITNESSES- HAVE NO. BUT IN THE
GALLERY TO PAIRS BUT WE DO HAVE
TO I THINK WE HAVE TO. TWO
WITNESSES BY PHONE MERRIAM THAT
AND- DAVID LLOYD SO MADAM MADAM
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WHITE ARE OPEN. THANK
YOU- CHAIR WOULD IN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HI MY NAME'S DAVE
AVOID THAT SENIOR POLICY
ADVISER I WITH THE CAN BE FORM
WHICH IS JOHN MOORLACH FORMER
CONGRESSMAN PATRICK KENNEDY
AUTHOR OF THE BATTLE PAYER
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY AND
ADDICTION EQUITY ACT. ASSEMBLY
COULD BE ALIVE. OKAY
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS-
CALIFORNIA THE PROUD POSTPONED
SERVE AS THE EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
WITH OUR PARTNER THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE. ARE WE HEAR STORIES
FROM PATIENTS EVERY DAY WHO
BEEN WRONGFULLY DENIED MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION TREATMENT.
AND ALTHOUGH NEARLY ALL PLAN ON
THE PATH TO FOLLOW THE PATH.
YEAH PLAN. BASICALLY TWO ONE IN
IN RUN AROUND. ALL SIMPLY BY
DENYING COVERAGE AND NOT.
MEDICALLY NECESSARY. AND MANY
PEOPLE CAN'T GET THE COVERAGE
NEED A ARE SHIPPED ON TO MY-
TAXPAYERS THE FORM OF PUBLIC
THIS. UNLESS INCARCERATION. SO
FUNDING EIGHT B. ACTED AS
SPEAKER 5% STANDARDS GOVERNING
HOW HEALTH PLANS COVER MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT. SO THAT
PEOPLE GET GET THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION TREATMENT
THEY NEED. FOR THEIR NECK ARE.
IT ALL UPDATE THE TOP MINIMUM
PARITY ACTOR ALL MANY HEALTH
NEEDS OF USE TO. NOT TO SMALL.
THE COMPUTER CONDITIONS AT THE
FOR. GETTING PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION CARE THAN
HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE. WHAT
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS QUIETER.
WITH THE CORPORATE NINETEEN AND
THAT. OVER RATE FATAL OVERDOSE
HOW CERTIFICATE PERCENT LAST
YEAR. AND THE ONLY FVE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE CHAU SYMPTOMS OF
UPS OF ANXIETY OR DEPRESSION
CURRENTLY ACCORDING TO THE
LATEST. DATA ACTUALLY WE'VE
BEEN MANY OF TWENTY TWO BY
CALIFORNIANS DIET DUSTED
DESPAIR RELATING TO COPE AND-
SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE IS A
CRITICAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSIVE AND THEY MAKE
BECAUSE IT ENSURES HEALTH PLANS
ARE COVERING CRITICAL MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION ERVICES
I'M NOT CHECKING THOSE
PROBLEMATIC. SB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE AS A BROAD RANGE OF OVER
SEVENTY SUPPORTERS FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS TOP ADVOCATES
PROVIDERS LABOR AND LONGER
COURSES. INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HELP.
ACTUALLY ARE YOU HELP ACCESS
YOU H. W. WHAT AN ONLINE
POVERTY ACT COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR IS NOT A
CALIFORNIA- CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK HEALTH NETWORK THE
CALIFORNIA CAP. SHE THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
BOB YEAH THIS I YOU COMMITTEE
TO SERVE EIGHT AT AT EIGHT
FIFTY. AND NOW AROUND BEEN DONE
BALL TESTIFY. FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I THANK YOU CHAIR
WOULD AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ROBIN DOT
AND I RESIDE IN SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA I'M A
PSYCHOTHERAPIST ATTORNEY AND
FOUNDER IF I COULD FEEL A LOT
FOR HELPING PATIENTS AND
FAMILIES CHALLENGE RUNKLE
INSURED NILE OF MANAHAWKIN THAT
COULD BE TREATMENT. I'M DONE
KHALID'S COUNSEL FOR THE
CERTIFIED NATION MY CLASSES AND
WITH UNITED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
I TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AT
EIGHT FIVE FIVE BECAUSE THE
BILL STATE LIFE. PARTICULARLY
IN LIGHT OF THE INCREASED NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT DUE
TO THE TRAUMA INFLICTED BY COKE
IT'S NINETEEN. SB EIGHT FIVE
FIVE HELLO THIS MAJOR GAP IN
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT ALLOW
INSURERS TO DENY COVERAGE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE WITH
IMPUNITY. CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA MENTAL HEALTH PARITY
ACT APPLIES ONLY NINE MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCES OF A CHILD. THIS
IS INDEFENSIBLE GIVEN THE
PREVALENCE OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AND COUNTLESS OTHER TREATABLE
DISORDERS INTO MINE. IT IS ALSO
INDISPENSABLE THE CALIFORNIA
LAW LACK THE UNIFORM DEFINITION
OF MEDICAL NECESSITY AND DOES
NOT MANDATE THAT INSURANCE MAKE
COVERAGE DETERMINATIONS THAT
ARE CONSISTENT BUT GENERALLY
ACCEPTED STANDARDS OF CARE. AS
A RESULT OF THE GAPING HOLE
CALIFORNIANS ARE ROUTINELY
DENIED AFTER MEDICALLY
NECESSARY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. ENSURE THAT
PRIORITIZE PROFITS OVER CARE.
SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE REQUIRED
INSURERS TO MAKE COVERAGE
DETERMINATIONS PURSUANT TO
GENERALLY ACCEPTED STANDARDS OF
CARE. SET FORTH BY NONPROFIT
CLINICAL SPECIALTY AT FIFTY
ASIAN RATHER THAN BUY INSURANCE.
HOME COOKED GUIDELINE. WE YOUR
BEHAVE HEALTH FOR THE PRIME. OF
AN INCH DEVELOPING EFFECTIVE
COVERAGE CRITERIA FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. FOLLOWING A TEN DAY
BENCH TRIAL AGAINST THE
COUNTRY'S LARGEST HEALTH
INSURER HEADQUARTERED IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE UNITED STATES
DISTRICT COURT FOR THE NORTHERN
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA FOUND
THAT YOU'D BE JUST FINANCIAL
CONFLICT INSPECTED A GUIDELINE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. AND THAT
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PATIENTS
INCLUDING THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN
WERE WRONGLY DENIED OUTPATIENT
INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT AND
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES. BASED ON
CRITERIA THAT WERE INCONSISTENT
WITH GENERALLY ACCEPTED
STANDARDS CARE. IN MY
EXPERIENCE AS THANK A FAIR BIT
AND THE TO. YOU B. H. IS NOT
ALONE THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
SYSTEMATICALLY LIMITS COVERAGE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BATES AND ACUITY AND QUITE THE
STANDARD. RATHER THAN
ACCOUNTING FOR DISEASE GRANITE
CITY AND SUPPORTING GENUINE
RICK. SB EIGHT FIVE LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR CONSUMERS
EMPLOYERS PROVIDERS AND
REGULATORS CAN BE ASSURE THE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A REAL SHOT
AT RECOVERY. ALL IN YOU'RE
PLAYING BY THE SAME. SB EIGHT
FIVE. ALL ENSURE AT THAT THE
BAKED ON STRICT ADHERENCE
GEOGRAPHIC AND TIMELINESS
STANDARDS. AND GUARANTEE THAT
WRONGFUL COVERAGE DENIALS I
REVIEWED BY COURT A FRESH.
RATHER THAN THROUGH THE LENS OF
UNDUE DEFERENCE. LIKE ANY OTHER
PARTY TO CIVIL LITIGATION
INSURANCE SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO
DEFEND THEIR CONDUCT ON A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THAT
A MODERATOR WILL OPEN THE LINES
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF TEN TEN
TEN CALLERS- JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN
THIS IS FOR SUPPORT WHAT A LINE
OF TWELVE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING. BY ON
BEHALF OF FEDERAL SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE FIVE
SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AMANDA MEDIA THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU'RE RIGHT TWELVE FOR SIX
WEEKS AGO I HAD. HI THIS IS
NEAR MARTIN AT THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN TWELVE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
ADRIN CHILDREN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
Q. THANK YOU A LINE TWELVE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS SHERRY DALY REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS AND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWELVE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANTA DOUBLES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. YOU RAIMES SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SIX EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LEVINE THE LINE TWELVE.
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE TEACHER IN MEMBERS
WANTED TO NARROW IT TO THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RYAN TWELVE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JOHN VAN OVER ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPRESSION AND
BIPOLAR SUPPORT ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORTER
RUGBY EIGHT FIFTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE
ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS ONLY AVAILABLE
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OKAY I THINK
THAT BELIEVE THAT'S TEN NOW SO-
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
OUR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AB
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO
MADAM MODERATOR YOU CAN OPEN
THE LINES FOR A BELIEVE IT'S
GOING TO BE NICK LOUISA'S AND
PRESTON YOUNG. THANK YOU BYE
BYE. GREAT THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NICKEL WINDOWS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS WELL WE'VE
TAKEN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON SB EIGHT FIVE HAVE
GENERALLY OPPOSES MANDATE BILLS
BECAUSE THE INCREASE THE COST
OF CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND EMPLOYERS. HAVING
SAID THIS WE ARE TAKING THE
RARE STEP OF OFFERING
AMENDMENTS TO A MANDATE BILL
SPECIFIC EIGHT FIVE THAT RETAIN
THE FUNDAMENTAL GOAL OF
EXPANDING COVERAGE TO INCLUDE
ALL WILL HELP SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. WE'RE ABLE TO DO
THIS BECAUSE THE UNDERLYING
MANDY CREATED BY THIS BILL. IS
IT REALLY THE PRIMARY ISSUE FOR
OUR MEMBERS- DESPITE SOME OF
THE ARGUMENTS YOU'RE HEARING
FROM THE OFFERING THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL. BERMAN
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS BASICALLY UNIVERSAL
IN CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS OF SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE. NINETY NINE
POINT 8% OF ENROLLEES IN
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAVE
COVERAGE FOR THE SERVICES
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL. AT
PARITY WITH OTHER MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. TAKING THAT INTO
ACCOUNT- OUR OBJECTIONS REALLY
OUR FOCUS ON THE CERES A
FUNDAMENTAL AND PRECEDENT
SETTING POLICY CHANGES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS MEASURE- AS WE
PROVIDED THE AUTHOR WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD MITIGATE
THE NEGATIVE QUALITY OF CARE
AND COST IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
MEASURE. IN WITH YOU TENSION OF
ONE AMENDMENT TO ONE PARAGRAPH
OF THE BILL ON WHICH WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR HAS
REGRETTABLY TAKEN ALMOST NO
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED EITHER BY
THE ENTITY THAT WILL IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL. FOR THE STATE
REGULATOR THAT ONE FOR IT. SO
WE'RE LEFT WITH THE SERIOUSLY
FLAWED BILL. THAT IS LARGELY
PREMISED ON A FEDERAL COURT
CASE- THAT IS FAR FROM FINAL IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH STATE
REGULATED OR LICENSED HEALTH
PLAN PRODUCTS. WE BELIEVE USING
THIS CASE IS NOT ONLY BAD
POLICY BUT A BILL TO THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE WORK THE PLAN
REGULATORS IN CALIFORNIA. ARE
ACCOMPLISHING ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT THE BILL ALSO WISELY FUN
WISELY. ME ATTEMPTS TO CODIFY
DEFINITION OF MEDICAL NECESSITY
FOR A SUBSET OF SERVICES.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT PLAN
CRITERIA IS ALREADY SUBMITTED
TO STATE REGULATORS FOR REVIEW
AND APPROVAL. THIS DEFINITION
WOULD WOULD CREATE CONFUSION
AND DISPARITY I MUST BE
REMOVED- INITIALLY IT APPEARED
THAT THE AUTHOR WAS REMOVING
THIS DEFINITION AS INDICATED IN
YOUR ANALYSIS BUT APPARENTLY
THINGS HAVE CHANGED- THE BILL
ALSO SHIFT COSTS SHIPS COSTS
AWAY FROM PUBLIC PROGRAMS IN ON
TO EMPLOYERS AND INDIVIDUALS IN
THE COMMERCIAL MARKET- IT DOES
NOT DEFINITIVELY STATE THAT
PROVIDERS AND THE RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT. CENTERS DELIVER
THESE SERVICES MUST BE
LICENSED- INVESTIGATE THE USE
OF LEGITIMATE CHECKS AND
BALANCES TO COMBAT. THE
POTENTIAL FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE
PARTICULARLY IN THE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT SPACE
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH PLANS ARE
DEDICATED TO DELIVERING THE
SERVICES- WE KNOW THEY'RE A
LONG TERM CHALLENGES BUT WE
MUST DEAL WITH THEM
COLLECTIVELY. ON AND USING GOOD
EVIDENCE AND ENTER THAT POINT
YOU KNOW I WOULD I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS. THE CALMATTERS
ARTICLE THAT CAME UP IN THE
AUTHOR'S STATEMENT- YOU KNOW WE
ARE NOT AWARE OF ANY EXISTING
DOCUMENTED EVIDENCE THAT
PATIENTS ARE BETTER SERVED BY
COUNTY RUN MENTAL HEALTH
AGENCIES. OF I DIDN'T THINK. IS
TREND REALLY HAPPENING. THE
RUBIO BE ARCTIC CITES THE-
STATISTIC. ABOUT THE FROM. OF
DROPPING COMMERCIAL COVERAGE IN
GOING TO CAO A PROGRAM.
ACTUALLY SO THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
FOR THAT- AND WE BELIEVE IT'S
RECKLESS TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
DROP THEIR PRIVATE COVERAGE TO
SEEK COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BECAUSE- THERE ARE SO
MANY OTHER MEDICAL SERVICES
THAT THEY WOULD LOSE. ON IN
THAT PROCESS SO- WE DON'T USE
ANY EVIDENCE FOR THE USE THAT
ARTICLE- IN ANY CASE- WE'VE
OFFERED AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL.
THERE ARE TWO. AREA BUT THE
BILL MAY IS THAT ISSUE ALL A
MATTER MISS THE MARK INCREASE
AND CONSEQUENCE. FOR THESE
REASONS CAP MUSTERS OPPOSE EACH
FIFTY FIVE UNLESS IT IS.
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- PRESTON YOUNG. YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESS TWO
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THAT WE
ARE OPPOSED TO SB FIFTY FIVE
THE OVERARCHING CONCERN WE HAVE
AND THE REASON FOR THE
OPPOSITION IS THE FACT THAT
THIS BENEFIT MANDATE AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT. ARE GOING TO BE
PASSED ON TO THE INSURED
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA
CORRECT EARLY EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES AND ACCORDING TO THE
TRIP URBAN ALICE'S I THINK THE
PREMIUM INCREASE THAT WERE
LOOKING OUT WITH SB FIFTY FIVE
WOULD BE OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
NOW. AND IT IS LIKE BEING
COVERED POLY CAME OUT WITH AN
ANALYSIS WITH THE ANTICIPATED
PREMIUM WRAPPING ANYWAY 44% IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE DUE TO
THE UNANTICIPATED COVERT
RELATED CAR EVER EXPERIENCED.
THIS YEAR. FOR NOW THE LATER ON
IN. PREMIUM ON OF WHAT CONTENT
GET 40% THINK IN PRE TO THE
TWENTY ONE. IT'S GOING FROM A
DIFFICULT SITUATION AND IT'S
MAKING IT THAT MUCH MORE AND
MANAGEABLE SO. WHEN WE'RE
HAVING THIS THIS SURROUNDING
HEALTH IN THE CARE TO BE
PERCENT USE DISORDER IT IS A
LEGITIMATE CONVERSATION TO BE
SURE. BUT IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO KEEP IN MIND THE FULL
PICTURE HERE. AND UNDERSTAND
HOW IT IS WE'RE GETTING TO THE
POINT THAT THAT MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT IS GONNA BE PAID FOR
RENTERS SO IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THAT SPEED
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL LAST
NOW THE MODERATE TO OPEN THE
LINE FOR- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION JUST THEIR NAME AND
OR A POSITION ONLY NAME
ORGANIZATIONALLY- AND WILL TAKE
TEN TEN CALLS ON THAT. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR Q. IF YOU
WILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN A TO OF SB
EIGHT FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVERLYING
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE ONE SEVEN
FIVE. YEAH JOHN LINGER ON THE
OPPOSITE THAT HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS AND OPTIONS THANK YOU.
BLIND ALIVE AT ALL SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE ONE ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE THE
LINE TWICE BEFORE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WITHOUT TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR YES PLEASE CALL. HI THIS
IS SHERIN READY ON BEHALF OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL I THOUGHT
I WAS IN Q. FOUR REPORT THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL MAKE. THANK YOU
JUST YEAH JUST TO NAME A
REGULATIONS FINE THANK YOU.
LINE SIX EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM SIX EIGHT SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOOKBINDER BY
TWELVE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S MICHAEL IN
FROM SENATOR COUNTY AND I'M
ACTUALLY IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
S. B. HI OKAY WE HAD A WE HAD
TEN IN SUPPORT OF A READY SO
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ACTUALLY NOT
ENTERTAINING ANY FURTHER
SUPPORT IF YOU IF YOU IF YOU
WANNA REGISTER SUPPORT YOU'RE
WELCOME TO SEND. A LETTER TO
OUR TO OUR S. OF PORTAL
COMMITTEE AT OUR HEALTH
COMMITTEE- BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
TAKING OPPOSITION AND- SO
PLEASE- IF ANYBODY OPPOSITE
SUPPORT PLEASE. SEND YOUR SEND
YOUR MESSAGE TO UP TO OUR TO
OUR- OUR PORTAL RIGHT NOW WE'RE
JUST ENTERTAINING OPPOSITION SO.%
MATTER ARE A MADAM MODERATOR.
PLEASE ALLOW. EIGHT MORE
OPPOSITION CALLS. Q. IF YOU ARE
IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT YOU
CAN REMOVE YOURSELF BY
REPEATING THE ONE ZERO COMMAND
WE ARE TAKING OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TO STAY
IN Q. LINE EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHT
SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEVADA LINE FIVE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRY A
LINE TWELVE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWELVE NINETEEN YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAVE NO
FURTHER MY LIVING Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF SENATOR WIENER. THE MISS
WALDRON. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AS A MEMBER OF THE STANFORD
FIVE YEAR INITIATIVE ON
ADDICTION IN THE BRAIN WE HAVE
COME TO UNDERSTAND. THAT THERE
IS A VERY PHYSICAL READ FOR
ADDICTION AS WELL AS WE LOOK AT
MENTAL HEALTH IT ALSO INVOLVES
DIRECTLY PHYSICAL HEALTH. THIS
BILL MODERNIZES A- MUCH NEEDED
MODERNIZATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY ACT NO WE
LOOK AT THE FACT THAT ONE OF
THE LARGEST OBSTACLES. TO CARE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH IS THE LACK
OF PRIORITIZATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN PARITY WITH
PHYSICAL HEALTH. AND YOU KNOW
IN IT AND WHEN YU ADD IN
STIGMA TO THAT THE NEW GOT THIS
THIS WHOLE- A PROBLEM WHERE
ABOUT 50% JUST UNDER 50% OF THE
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ARE NOT GETTING
TREATMENT WE LOOK AT ALSO THE
NUMBER OF EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
ANNUALLY AVERAGE FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION FOR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. THE NUMBER OF VISITS TO
PHYSICIANS OFFICES WITH MENTAL
HEALTH MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
DISORDER FIFTY SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION ANNUALLY THIS IS
ALREADY A BIG COST TO OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. WHEN ARE WE
LOOK AT OUR- MENTAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH ARE INTRICATELY
BOUND TOGETHER ACCORDING TO THE
CDC. MENTAL ILLNESS AND WE JUST
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE DEPRESSION-
CAN INCREASE THE RISK FOR MANY
PHYSICAL HEALTH PROBLEMS.
ESPECIALLY LONG LASTING ONES
LIKE STROKE TYPE TWO DOVER
DAVIES AND HEART DISEASE AND
SIMILARLY- THE REVERSE IS TRUE
THE PRESENCE OF HEALTH CARE OF
CHRONIC CONDITIONS CAN INCREASE
THE RISK FOR MENTAL ILLNESS. SO
THIS AS I SAID IT'S ALREADY A
BIG COST IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM WE CAN INCREASE I THINK
THE RATE OF TREATMENT IF WE FOR
ONCE DURING MENTAL HEALTH. ARE
TREATMENT INTO PARITY WITH
PHYSICAL HEALTH. SO IT NEEDS TO
GET THERE AND- WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE NEEDED TO DO THAT FOR A
LONG TIME I REGION I WILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON ANY OTHER MEMBERS LIKE
TO ASK A QUESTION I HAVE A
COMMENT. C. NINE DO WE HAVE A
MOTION THANK YOU YEAH. OKAY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MCCARTY A SECOND BY MISS BURKE-
CENTER WIN IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IT DOES ENJOY TO
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD. WOULD I'D
MAYES MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AYE DIRECTORY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA. BONTA
I'D BURKE. BURKE HI CARILLO.
CARILLO. FLORA. CARILLO NOT
VOTING FLORA. I'M SORRY DARIO
II. FLORA LIMóN LIMóN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S.
RAMESSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NINE. THIRTEEN I KNOW
ZERO. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY- I WOULD LIKE TO GO
BACK AND I'D I'D LIKE TO GO
BACK AND LIFT THE CALL ON S. B.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN ITEM NUMBER
SIX AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MONEY NINE SB NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN EXCUSE ME ITEM NUMBER SIX
SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN MONEY.
BURKE. BURKE NOT VOTING.
MCCARTY MCCARTY II RAMOS. RAMOS
NOT VOTING RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ
I. EIGHT I FOR KNOWS BILL
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
THEN MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER TEN
SB TWENTY NINE TEN TWENTY NINE
I WANT TO LIFT THE CALL AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW II
FLORA. SANTIAGO SB TEN TWENTY
NINE. SENATOR PAN. SANTIAGO I
WALDRON. WALDRON I. TEN ICE.
ALMOST NINE RAMEAU'S NOW
BOARDING TO I'D. CARILLO NOT
VOTING TO I'D. RODRIGUEZ NOT
VOTING TO AYE. THIRTEEN ICE
ZERONOS THANK YOU WELL NOW
MOVES TO OUR FINAL ITEM OF THE
OF THE- EVENING SB NINE THIRTY
TWO SENATOR WIENER WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND- AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT.
OTHER COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ARE
CALLING TO ASK YOU NINE THIRTY
TWO- ADDRESSES A VERY REAL AND
LONG STANDING ISSUE FACING THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. MAY I
SPECIFICALLY THE LACK OF DATA
COLLECTION IN THIS CASE- AND
HEALTH SETTING. HISTORY OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY IS A HISTORY OF
FIGHTING AGAINST INVISIBILITY
AND SOCIETY'S EFFORT TO RAISE
US AND PRETEND THAT WE DON'T-
EXISTENCE. I'M PARTICULARLY IN
THE HEALTH CARE CENTER IN THE
BILL STARTED OUT AS A CO CPAS
BILL BECAUSE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WAS NOT COLLECTING
ANY DATA AROUND COVER NINETEEN
THEM TYPE OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY WE NOW. EXPECT THAT
IT'S ALL. OVER HERBAL
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE. WE ARE
SEEING WHAT DATA SHOW US OF THE
M. OF. IN PARTICULAR. ON
COMMUNITIES COLOR ON OLDER
PEOPLE- WE NEED TO HAVE THIS
DATA AROUND LGBTQ COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I GO.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO OUR WITNESS BY
THE PHONE. REVIVE MISTER
KILLING THIS IS BY THE FONG
SKEWS ME YES RICK SUBURBAN
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND AMEND
THE WATER FROM THE LGBTQ HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK
THANK YOU THANKS FOR SAVING ME
I COULDN'T PRONOUNCE THE LAST
NAME MY BAD SO TO WITNESSES
SUMMIT THANK. MADAME MODERATOR
THE SERVER AND ADAM WALLER
AMANDA WALTER IT'S YEAH WHY ARE
OPEN. YEAH GREAT- CAN YOU GIVE
ME THIS IS THAT RICK THE BURKE
POLYTECHNIC IMPRACTICAL QUALITY
CALIFORNIA MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU THIS EVENING
PARKWAY EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN
TESTED HOPE IN NINETEEN BUT OUR
GOVERNMENT NOT TRAPPED THE
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR GENDER
IDENTITY OF A SINGLE ONE. WE
DON'T KNOW THE DEGREE TO WHICH
COVERED NINETEEN QUIETLY
DEVASTATING THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY WE DON'T KNOW IF AND
WHEN THERE ARE OUTBREAKS IN THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND ANY OF YOUR
DISTRICTS OR ANYWHERE IN OUR
STATE. IN RECENT MONTHS THERE'S
THAT INVALUABLE REPORTING ON
FATALITY RECORDS WITHIN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SOMETIMES
THREE TIMES HIGHER THAN AMONG
THE GENERAL PUBLIC. IT MAY.
BEING USED OUT. BY TWEET LATIN
THAT MEANS AND WE ONLY HAVE
THAT BECAUSE THE CRITICAL DATA
BECAUSE DATA COLLECTION IT TOOK
RESPONDED OUR PUBLIC OFFICIALS
NOT JUST TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH GENERALLY BUT TO ATTACK
THE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES LIKE
MAYBE THE COLOR LIKE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ELDERLY
AND LYFT LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE.
LAST WEEK DR- GUILTILY I DOWN
NEUBERGER YOU REGULATIONS
REQUIRING HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
PORTLAND JERRY DATA ON THE
GENDER IDENTITY AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION A PATIENT WITH
RECORDABLE DISEASES INCLUDING
KOBE NINETEEN WE APPRECIATE AND
APPLAUD GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS
MINISTRY FOR THAT. WE ALSO. FOR
EVERY REPORT ABOUT THE ANY NEW
THREATS OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH
THAT MAY EMERGE WE MUST NEVER
ALLOW PUBLIC NUDITY LIKE OURS
TO BE IGNORED OR RAPED AGAIN
BECAUSE WHEN LGBTQ PEOPLE ARE
LOCKED OUT OF THE DATA BROUGHT
WE'RE ALSO LEFT OUT OF THE DATA
DRIVEN RESPONSE. THAT'S NOT
CONJECTURE IT'S NOT HARD FOR
THE IT'S THE TRUTH I KNOW
BECAUSE I CAME OF AGE- THAT
CAME OF AGE IN THE AIDS CRISIS
I HELD THE HAND OF MANY OF MY
YOUNG FRIEND BACKED AND- WELL
THEY LAY DYING. AT OUR GOT.
LOOKS THE OTHER WAY. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEN AND NOW
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WE%
DIDN'T HAVE AN LGBTQ CAUCUS WE
DIDN'T HAVE DINNER WIENER
APPROACH ON ATKINS AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE STRONG ALLIES
EITHER LIKE GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION ARE YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
TODAY DIFFERENT WE DON'T HAVE
TO REACH THE END OF THIS CRISIS
OR ANY FUTURE HEALTH CRISIS AND
LOOK BACK WITH REGRET WE DON'T
HAVE TO WONDER WHAT IF WE DID
NOT WORK AND WHAT IF WE HAD
ACTED SOONER. GOD KNOWS I THINK
THAT THE TOO MANY FUNERALS AND
THAT TOO MANY GOODBYE WELL OUR
GOVERNMENT THE OTHER WAY CAN'T
LET THAT HAPPEN AGAIN NOT NOW
NOT EVER NOT IN CALIFORNIA.
ACCORD CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMANDA
WALLER. IF SHE'S ON THE PHONE.
THANK AT YEAH HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. GREAT SORRY IF THE
HOMEWORK CAN'T WAIT HERE
YOURSELF- GOOD EVENING- MY
NAME'S AMANDA MCALISTER WALLNER
I AM THAT I DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBTQ HEALTH
SERVICES NETWORK- AND HONORED
TO BE YOUR FINAL WITNESS A BIT
YOU CAN HOPEFULLY. AND THAT I
WOULD NEVER OF OVER SIXTY I. G.
B. T. Q. PROGRAM ORGANIZATION.
EIGHT ORGAN THAT ARE- GRAPPLING
WITH HOW TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITY AND- IN THE WAKE- A
PANDEMIC THAT IS. RAVAGING OUR%
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW- WE'RE GETTING
UPDATE NEARLY EVERY DAY ABOUT
THE CALL HOLDCO THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE CALIFORNIANS. TO
DATE WE'VE HAD FIVE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND ACRES. AND
NINE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
ONE DOWN HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING- BUT I'M
GLAD I DIDN'T BURKE MENTIONED.
THERE YET WE ARE YET TO HAVE
ANY DATA REPORTED ON LGBTQ
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE CURRENTLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION NAY. TO
COLLECTING THE DATA MOVING
FORWARD AND THE BILL WILL MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT THE PEOPLE REPORT
THIS DATA FOR COOKING AND
FUTURE OUTBREAKS IN FUTURE IT.
MOVE FORWARD. WE CAN'T WAIT ANY
LONGER. WE KNOW THAT LGBTQ
COMMUNITY IS. RIGHT WELL THE TO
COMPANY. INCLUDING EVERYTHING
SHE AND HIRING JOB AND HIRING
THE BUNDLING HEALTH CONDITION
THAT AFFECTED CANCER HIV AND
DIABETES. BUT WITHOUT THAT DATA
THAT INCLUDES PERSONAL
EDUCATION GENDER AGAIN WE CAN'T
DIRECT INTERVENTION NEEDED TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE. I'M
PRETTY CAN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OKAY FOR SB NINE
THIRTY TO GET. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL NOW TAKE.
SUPPORT WILL TAKE TEN CALLS IN
SUPPORT- JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION ONLY PLEASE AND
LAST MATTER MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR THE TEN
CALLS IN SUPPORT. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
AT NINE THIRTY TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHAT A LINE TWELVE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN I'LL BE OUT TO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND SPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CURRENT NUMBER SO
THEY ARE SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES REPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TWELVE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU DON'T ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BY TWELVE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SANTA DOUGLAS
WITH HEALTH ACT OF CALIFORNIA
IMPORTANT THANK YOU. BY TWELVE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JUST TO THINK THE GIRL
ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER BECAUSE A LOT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BRIAN
TWELVE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANYTHING MEMBERS WANTED
TO KNOW WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FIVE FIVE SIXTEEN TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND LINE TWELVE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS ERIN EVAN ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE THANK YOU
AT THE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LISTED WITNESSES. SO I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY IN THE GALLERY
THERE'S NOBODY IN OUR WITNESS
ROOM. SO MADAM OP MATAMATA
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THIS THEIR NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE THIRTY TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MATTER MODERATOR. WILL BRING
THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. NINE WE HAD A
MOTION FROM MR MAYES A SECOND
FROM MISTER FLORA- MISTER
WINNER WHICH I CLOSE I LOVE
BIPARTISANSHIP EXPECT BEST
FRIEND I DON'T I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD ACTUALLY BOTH
THOSE FOR AND I THINK THEY'RE-
PRETTY CLEAR IMPORTANT NOW MORE
THAN EVER. AND I WANT TO THE
JOB SITUATED EJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- IT IS A THE
MOTION WILL BE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS NOW
ASK A MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB NINE THREE
TWO MOTION IS DUE PROCESS OF
MENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WOOD I
WOULD I'D MADE. MAYES AYE OUR
DIRECTORY. OUR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIG AYE BY. BONTA AYE BURKE
BURKE HI CORREO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLORA I LIVE ALONE LIMóN
AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS
RAMESSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN EYES NOSE
ZERO. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO START FROM THE
TOP AND GO THROUGH I KNOW WE'VE
GOT SOME- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
BILLS A CALL BUT WE HAVE- BILLS
WE NEED TO- AND ALLOW OTHERS TO
ADD ON TO SO WE'LL START THE
TOP I. FOR ONE THESE THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SB
EIGHT OH THREE BONTA. BONTA I.
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN ICE NO ZERO
THANK YOU THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH IS SB ONE SIXTY TWO- BY
SENATOR GALGIANI PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY II CAREER. CARILLO
III MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN ICE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN ICE NO ZERO
THANK YOU- ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
SEVEN FORTY ONE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY. I GARY CURRY II
CORREO. CARILLO III MCCARTY
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN. WHICH IS.
I'M SORRY SB SEVEN FOUR ONE YES.
NAZARIAN AYE. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
Y. THIRTEEN ICE ONE NO. THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER FOR SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE OTHER WAS KNOWN FOR THE
NINETEEN NINETY THREE WE'RE
DONE. SO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
TWELVE OH SEVEN. OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS IF
THERE ARE ANY. BONTA. SB TWELVE
OH SEVEN BONTA SB TWO OH SEVEN
JACKSON. BONTA I NAZARIAN. SB
TWELVE OH SEVEN SENATOR JACKSON.
PAUL NAZARIAN AYE. TWELVE ICE
ZERO NO. AND THEN WE DID I
THINK WE'VE WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
SIX SEVENTY SEVEN NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN AGAIN ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE WAS WAS%
WITHDRAWN BY THE AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AS BEFORE SIX
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN EYES NO ZERO
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER NINE WAS
WITHDRAWN BY THE IT WAS
WITHDRAWN- ITEM NUMBER TEN. SB
TEN TWENTY NINE CENTER PAN I
THINK WE WENT THROUGH THAT I
THINK IT'S FIFTEEN ZERO NOW.
I'M SORRY FOURTEEN ZERO. IT
ALSO OPEN. THE ROLE IN THAT AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FLORA
FLORA BY. FOURTEEN I KNOW ZERO
OKAY. I THEM NUMBER TWO
SEVENTEEN WAS WITHDRAWN BY THE
AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER TWELVE OF
THE RIVER LEVEN EXCUSE ME SB
TWO SEVENTEEN WAS WITHDRAWN BY
THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT SENATOR
PORTANTINO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE
MALL. LIMóN NINE. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I. TWELVE ICE NO ZERO
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
SB SIX SIXTY FIVE AMBER PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LIN'AN. LIMON AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING. FOURTEEN
ICE ZERO NOW THANK YOU AND
THEN- S. THE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA. THIRTEEN
ICE ZERO NOW AND THEN I THINK
WE DISPOSED OF FULLER ABSENT.
OKAY IN SB NINE THIRTY TWO.
OPEN THE ROLE I THINK. WE GOT
THAT ONE WE'RE GOOD OKAY.
THAT'S IT- AT THIS POINT I
BELIEVE ME JUST CHECK MAKE SURE
OKAY OKAY THAT'S IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT THIS ENDS THE
AND HEARING OF THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE.